hey guys
welcome to this full stack java course
java is one of the most popularly used
languages for desktop app development
and if you wish to learn java full stack
then you're in the right place
but before we begin if you haven't
subscribed to our channel already make
sure to hit the subscribe button and the
bell icon to never miss an update so
let's look at what's in store for you
first we learn about version control
systems like git
followed by which we'll understand core
java concepts like operators loops
inheritance encapsulation and so on
moving ahead we have a section covering
maven and jenkins
now it is crucial to understand
front-end app development tools as well
the next section will include
tutorials on html css and angular and
finally we'll conclude the session by
learning database management systems
like sql and mongodb so i hope you're
excited to learn all of this
now let's jump right in
hello and welcome to git commands my
name is chidanand and i am with the
simply learn team today i am going to
cover few essential git commands and
walk you through a demonstration for
most of it i begin by installing a git
bash on the git client and configuring
it for its first time usage once i'm
done with configuring the git client i'm
going to spin up few repositories
locally and work on these repositories
using git commands once i'm happy with
my local changes i'm going to commit few
of them and then push these changes to a
git server of my choice for today's
demonstration i plan to use github.com
which is a cloud hosted free service and
it provides free account registrations
for anyone eventually i will cover few
topics regarding git branching and
merging because these two in my opinion
are the killer features of the git
distributed version control tool kit is
one of the most popular distributed
version control tools of recent times
and like any other distributed version
control tool it allows us to perform
various version control tasks without
really needing a network connection
before i jump into my demonstration let
me spend some time explaining to you the
git client server working model what
does it take for a couple of users to
collaborate and start working with git
the bare minimal thing that any user
would need in order to start working
with kit is something called as git bash
or the git client this comes as an
installer for all popular operating
systems like windows all flavors of
windows
linux mac os and other operating systems
so once you install git bash you get a
command line utility using which you can
fire up your git commands and ensure
that you can bring up repositories you
can work with these repositories by
adding files to it committing changes to
it and all those git commands would work
perfectly well so you can bring up a
small repository and you can work with
your repository using this git bash but
what does it take for you to share this
repository with another user who has
also got git bash installed on his
system this is where you would need
something called as a gig server
so for user user1 or one user to share
his repository with another user he
would need to collaborate using
something called as a git server so in
the present market there are a bunch of
git servers which are popularly
available some of them are free some of
them come with cost because they are
licensed a bunch of these servers that i
can think of are github which is one of
the most popular kit servers that is
around in the market for a long time now
it comes with two variants one is the
cloud hosted one which is the github.com
and then the other one is an enterprise
server which comes as a black box that
can be installed into your data centers
so typically organizations who don't
want their source code to be put up on
the cloud but go for this github
enterprise servers wherein they buy
these servers and these servers are
hosted on their data centers other
popular variant of the git server is
bitbucket this is from the famous
atlassian products and it integrates
very well with all other atlassian
products like jira in recent times
there's one other variant of the git
server called gitlab which is getting
very very popular these days because
gitlab not just provides a git server it
also provides something called as a
runner this is a part of the continuous
integration strategy where as soon as
you have a source code checking that is
going in you have this runner that kicks
up and builds your particular project so
all these are bundled together in a git
lab and gitlab also provides you with a
community edition which is almost free
of cost having said that there are a
bunch of these tools available for my
demonstration what i'm going to do is
i've already registered myself on the
github.com by providing my username and
my password and i'm going to use a free
account so whatever repositories that
i'm going to put up on this server is
all public by default so i will register
myself by using my username or my email
id and my password so this set of
authentication is also referred to as
https authentication
so in order for me to share my
repository with say user2 the first
thing that i got to do was have an
access to a git server where both user 1
and user 2 are set up so once i have
that i can push my repository onto this
server and provide right kind of access
so that user 2 or the other developer
who wishes to collaborate with me on
this repository can use his credentials
as long as he's registered properly on
the git server he can use his
credentials and pull down this
repository and work with this repository
so this is the https way of
authenticating and sharing repositories
another popular way of sharing
repositories or working with each other
is called as ssh authentication as many
of you would know ssh means nothing but
creation of a private and a public key a
bunch of keys public and private are
created on the client machine while i
create a keys i will be asked for a
passphrase i need to type in a
passphrase and remember my passphrase
and then i take this public key and kind
of post it on to my account within my
git server so that whenever i'm going to
connect next time using my command
prompt or any of the tools it's going to
challenge me for my passphrase as long
as i remember my passphrase correctly i
can authenticate myself and get into the
server so both https and ssh are popular
ways of communicating with the git
server having said this let me just get
started by installing the git bash on my
local system and then fire up some of
these git commands and build up some
repositories make some changes in my
repository commit these changes and
later use my github credential to
connect to my github server and push my
repositories out there let me now go
ahead and find my git bash for my
windows so that i can go ahead and
install it so i just type in get
client for
windows open up a browser and type in
for this the first one that i find as a
gui tool i don't need this gui client i
need this one
so this is the git client or the git
bash that i was referring to it's about
40 megs and let me just download this
pause this video for some time so that
the download happens and come back to
you once i have the download the
download seems to be complete when i'm
recording this video the version that i
have the latest version that is there is
2.19.0 and this is a 64-bit version for
windows so i've got that downloaded let
me go ahead and find it and install this
exe
all right i go ahead choosing all the
default options i want it to be
installed in c colon program files under
the git folder
everything looks good for me i'm not
going to make any changes here
get bash from windows yes i may want to
use git from windows command prompt that
sounds good for me open ssh that's fine
looks good looks good
no i don't want any of these new
features
so what i'm doing is installing the git
bash or the git client so that i can
start using my git commands
the version that i'm using is 2.19.0
which as i record this video this
happens to be the latest version
all right so looks good i don't want to
see the release notes i'll say launch
git bash
so what i get is this window so this is
the git command prompt so let me check
if everything is looking good say get
version it sounds good say get help all
right a lot of git help commands
everything looks good so
i ended up installing the git bash i can
go ahead with all other commands
now that i have git bash installed on my
system let me open up a git bash prompt
and start using it but before i do
anything i just need to configure it for
the first time stating what would be the
username and the email id with which i
want the git bash to be configured with
the command to do that is get config
hyphen iphone global which means that
this setting that i'm going to set would
be a global setting user dot name and
this the name of the user would need to
be specified within a double quote in my
case i am using the simplylearn account
which is the official account and this
is the particular username of this
account the other setting is nothing but
git config hyphen f1 global this is also
a global setting
and this would be the email id
the email id need not contain a double
quote
so in my case this is the email id that
i would be setting up git to work with
all right let me check if the
configurations were set correctly or not
all right if you see this the username
and the email id has been picked up the
way i wanted it to be picked up looks
good so far all right so what do we do
next by default whenever you open up the
git prompt you are placed into your home
directory let me create a folder here
which would be a repository folder from
where i'm going to create all my
multiple git repositories so i will
create a folder called let's say git
underscore demo
all right
there's already a folder called git demo
so let me just delete that in the first
place and let me create this git demo
again
all right let me navigate to this
particular folder
so this is the folder let me open up
that folder using a command prompt
this is my git demo
so this would be a folder so i would use
this folder as a base folder for
creating all other repositories as a
part of this demo so let me create my
first repository a repository is nothing
but a folder so let me create my first
folder called first
repo
and let me
get into this repo all right as of now
this is just an empty folder
if at all i navigate to this you could
see that this folder is empty there's
nothing much in this folder at all at
this moment
okay so let me create a repository out
of this how do i create a repository of
this it's pretty simple i just run and
get init command
when i say git init it means it's going
to initialize a repository as of now
the folder contained nothing on it was
an empty repository so it initialize an
empty repository in this particular
folder if at all i look at my content
you'd see that there's a hidden folder
this would be a hidden folder since i've
configured my explorer to view all
hidden folders i see it otherwise you
wouldn't see it so a folder by name dot
get is created within this first repo
and this was created because we ran the
command git init
if i get into this folder i see a bunch
of directories and other configurations
if you see there's something called as a
hooks directory a couple of
configuration files that are here in
this directory all these relate to one
or the other type of a client hook that
can be enabled and there's info there's
objects
there's references a bunch of stuff that
is there
so what is this folder this is a magical
git folder and this is created whenever
a repository is initialized so by
default if at all you get into any git
folder or any git repository you would
see this dot get folder a word of
caution do not get into this folder and
try to modify anything because if you
fiddle around with this and corrupt this
particular folder your whole repository
will go for a toss so let me come out of
this
and let me show you another thing
now if you notice here
when i was in the folder the repository
did not have anything after this now
when i say get in it there is something
called as a master that shows up so
typically what happens is whenever a git
repository is created for the first time
it creates a default branch the name of
the branch is called master and that is
why you would see master within braces
this doesn't mean anything else other
than we have a repository out in this
particular folder and by default there
is a
branch called master and we are
currently on that branch if at all i
create multiple branches in this folder
whenever i navigate to different
branches the branch name within these
brackets would change
all right so far so good so we created a
folder we made it a git repository by
initializing that with the git init and
then i have not put anything yet in the
repository so let me try to do that let
me create a few files within this
particular repository so i use a touch
command
touch is a linux command it kind of
creates this particular folder if you're
not comfortable with the file creation
by this way you can always use a file
explorer and create some files in this
so i create a file called
touchmaster.txt i'll open up in the
notepad
okay so this is my first file that's
what i'm going to write inside this
i save this and i come out of this all
right now let me do a git status command
so what does this
tell you there's no commit set you're on
the master branch there is an untracked
file and this shows up in red it also
gives you all the commands that is
supposed to be run so if at all you want
to add this file you would say git add
and the name of the file and then you're
going to commit it
so what happened is that when the
repository was initialized it was an
empty repository
now that a git notices that there is a
new file in this repository called
master.txt if at all you want you want
us to let git know that you want to
track this file we need to add this to
the repository so command to add that is
called git add i can specify either the
name of the file or i can give a while
character saying git add dot now if i
run the git status command again
it says there's no commits yet
added a file and the file which was
earlier in red now shows up in green and
it says it's a new file master dot text
all right it also gives you something
called git remove command if at all you
want to unstage or undo your changes so
what has happened is the file which was
earlier untracked is been added into the
git index or it is ready for staging or
it's in a staged state now i can go
ahead and commit this file if at all
that's what i want to do so let me do
that
i'll do a git commit minus m and i give
a message that i want i would say this
is my
first get commit
all right i run the gate status command
again
and see it says on the branch master
nothing to commit it's all nice and
clean so typically what happened was i
created an empty directory made into a
git folder by doing a git init i put a
file into it i made some changes to the
file i added that file into the
repository and i committed to the
repository if it error i run the git log
command
it says this was the commit id or the
commit
number or the commit hashtag and this is
the author if you notice this is the
email id and the username that we set
earlier this was done on this date and
this is the
commit message that is there all of it
looks so good let me do one more commit
into this repository so i will touch
master one dot text i'll put in another
file
i'll open up this particular file
write something into this
all right i save this change
let me also open up the older
file make some more change into this
all right so what i did i modified the
older file that existed i also added a
new file to my repository now if i run
the git status command
it says modified this file which is
showing in red and it says you have one
more file which is an untracked file
all right now let me add both these
files because these are the changes that
i want to
incorporate i would say git add dot i
run the git status command again
and it says now this is a modified file
this is a new file looks good to me let
me go ahead and commit this so git
commit with the message that says this
is my second commit
all right
if i do a git log now it shows both the
commits the first command is the one
that that shows up at the bottom and the
topmost one is the latest commit that is
there so far so good if at all you
notice
i'm doing all these git commands without
really connecting it to any git server i
don't need any network connection for
doing any of these things i can keep on
doing more and more git commands and run
git commands the way i want to
without really having any connections to
the git server
now that i have my changes the way i
wanted and i've checked in all the code
changes into my local repository i may
want to share my repository with
somebody else
and work in a collaborative way so the
way to do that is as i mentioned earlier
to host this repository or to push this
repository onto a kit server i already
have a github account wherein i've
registered myself using my username and
password so i log into my github account
using my username and credentials and
let me go ahead and create a new
repository
my repository is already there on the
local system so what i essentially need
is just a placeholder for my repository
so that i can link them together
and push the content from my local
repository to the server
if you notice the name of my repository
is this first repo
so let me copy this i will create a
folder structure or a repository
structure on the server with the same
name
so that
when i pushed my repository from my
local box it will go ahead and get
created in the server
so the repository name should be the
same as what i created on my local box
description i would say this is my first
git
hub
repository
on the server
this is just an optional description
that will show up
and if you notice
i can't have any private repositories so
whatever repositories that i'm going to
create here would be a public repository
so i choose public and i don't want to
initialize this with a readme file or
anything of that because i already have
a repository with some content with some
code checked in all that i need is a
placeholder for my repository on the
server
so with this option with just the name
and with an optional description and the
repository being public i go ahead and
click on the create repository button
so if you notice it gives me a bunch of
commands that i would need to run in
order to create a repository and pushed
onto the server and also important point
it shows me two urls one is the https
url and the other one is the ssh url as
of now we do not have any ssh keys that
is set up so let me use this https url
to connect my local repository with the
repository on the server
so i've done all these things i already
have the repository set up all that i
need is a placeholder for me to connect
my local repository with the server url
so this would be the command that i need
to copy
which essentially links or adds an
origin with the url of the git server i
just copy this command
and run it here
git remote add the name of the remote is
called origin and it points to an https
url which is nothing but the placeholder
that i've created on the server
all right so let me check if it's added
correctly
okay the url looks good i'm all set i've
got two comments in my repository i'm
done with all the changes so let me try
to push my repository onto the server
the command for doing it for the first
time is git push hyphen u this is for
linking the upstream
origin
master so get push hyphen u upstream
linking origin master link the master
uh branch of my local repository with
the master branch on the server
repository and where is it going to push
it is going to push by default to an
origin and the origin points to this url
all right let me try doing this
so it essentially opens up an url asking
me the credentials with which i need to
log into my github server so let me just
copy and paste
the username
and the password with which i have
registered
i would say login
okay success
so i'm able to create a repository on
the server and the content seems to be
pushed and it created a new branch
called master it has linked the master
branch from the local repository with
the master branch on the server so let
me go back to my server and refresh this
page
and see if all my commits have come in
master master one dot text if at all i
see the commits there seem to be two
comments this is my first comment this
is my second comment and if at all you
notice each of this commit comes with a
hash key or a hash id which contains the
details of my commits in this commit the
files were added this was a line that
was added if you look at the second
commit
i added these lines
i made this you know one line chain that
was there i also added this new file
which was not existing these are the two
commits that existed
and if you see the timestamp of the
commit
this is the commit which was committed
for 15 minutes ago so what does this
mean is that the commit is the timestamp
when we actually commented the code in
the client the pushing is just after we
committed the change we pushed it so
there's no timestamp of the push that
happen
this completes the first part of the
tutorial wherein i create a repository
on the client and then i pushed it to
the server after creating a repository
skeleton on the server
now let me demonstrate to you the ssh
configuration that is required for
creating a pair of ssh keys and ensuring
that i connect to the github server
using the ssh mechanism so for doing
that i need to first create a pair of
private and public key the command to do
that is ssh keygen
hyphen t i will use the rsa mechanism
for creating my keys capital c and i
need to specify the email id using which
i'm going to connect to or i need to
create the keys for
all right so generating a private and
public key pair it says let me know what
folder should i create the keys in so by
default the keys are created in the user
home directory under a dot ssh folder so
this is pretty good for me so let me go
ahead and say that that's fine enter a
passphrase
so let me enter some passphrase
keep in mind that i would need to
remember my passphrase because when i'm
going to authenticate myself using ssh
mechanism it will challenge me for this
particular passphrase i need to enter
the right passphrase so that i get
authenticated
so the key is generated and by default
it is created in this particular folder
so let me go over to that particular
folder
and this is the folder where the keys is
generated you would see a public key and
a private key that is created let me
open up the public key with
a notepad
and then copy the contents of the whole
file
and now i would need to stick it in
on the server so that i can get myself
authenticated using ssh keys so i've
logged in to github using my credentials
and go to my settings
and you will see an ssh and gpg keys let
me click on that as of now there are no
ssh key or gpg keys so i will click on
new ssh key and let me paste my
public key that i've copied
and i would say add ssh key
it prompts me for my password just to
make sure that
i've got the right kind of
authentication to be adding a new key so
this one looks good that means the keys
were added successfully let me check if
my ssh keys are working well
so i do ssh hyphen capital t i would say
git
at
github.com
this is just to double check if my ssh
keys
are authenticated correctly are you sure
you want the connection yes you want to
continue yes
all right now
a check for my passphrase let me enter
my passphrase
i hope i remember it correctly
all right
pretty good have been successfully
authenticated so that means now my ssh
keys are good and just by using my
passphrase i can connect to my github
server using ssh all right so for the
second use case what i would do is
create a repository on the server with
some content in it and then clone that
repository cloning is nothing but making
a copy of that repository linking the
origin so that i create an exact replica
of the repository which is there on the
server on my local drive so let me first
create a repository on the server i will
create a new repository
let me give a name for my repository and
let me kind of initialize that with the
readme file i would call this my second
repo
give some description
this is my
second repo
that is created
straight
on the git server on the github server
to be precise
it's a public repository this time i'm
going to choose this option the reason
being that i don't want to create just a
skeleton as of now i want to create a
repository with some readme file in it a
random readme file with no content in it
but then i want a repository to be
created on the server all right i say
create a repository
so
a random readme file with some content
in it gets created and i can see there
are two urls to this repository https
and ssh so this time let me copy the ssh
url so that i will use this url to clone
this repository on the server
rather from the server to my local box
all right so let me navigate to my root
folder the folder that i created for
making all my repositories git
repositories if you see my first deposit
is already here so let me clone my
repository
the second repo that i created on the
server the command to do that is get
clone the url of the repository that i
want to clone
oops
looks like i didn't copy the url
correctly let me copy that again copy
this url
all right so if you notice there's no
https to it i'm just cloning the url
that is ssh url of the repository
it asks for my passphrase again
okay
so i just had first repository earlier
now i have something called a second
repo this is an exact replica of
whatever was the repository content that
was created on the server so if i get
into
the repository there's just a simple
readme file that is there let me try to
add a new file out here i would say
notepad
second.txt
some text file i'm going to put in here
yes definitely you will not find that
file there
this is my second
file that
i will push onto the server
i'm going to put in some content out
there
i'm going to save this
and if i do get status
it says this this is a new untracked
file do you want to add this file onto
the repository do you want to track this
file yes i definitely want to track this
file let me also commit my change to the
file
with the message
this is my first
commit for the second repo
i'm giving some particular message
and this time around since i cloned my
repository from a server the origin is
already set for me i don't really need
to
add the origin and all that stuff
because what happened in the first case
was that i was creating a repository
from my local box and then pushing
another server which is why i had to set
up the upstream branches and stuff like
that in this case i have cloned an
existing repository from the server so
when i clone i get the replica along
with all references to my repository so
i don't need to do anything more other
than push the content i'll just say git
push to be in the safer side i would say
origin and master
ask me for the passphrase
okay it post the content onto the server
let me see if the contents have come in
here
okay wonderful i had only one comment
now i see my second comment so what was
added as a part of the second comment it
says a new file was added all this line
that never existed got added this is the
second file the content exactly what i
pushed onto the server
now this completes the tutorial when i
create a repository on the server cloned
it made some changes to the repository
and pushed it to the server using ssh
a quick recap of all the git commands
that we ran till now git init is used to
initialize a repository so if at all you
are creating a local repository you can
get into any of the folder which is not
a git repository and run this command
whenever you run this command a magical
folder by name dot kit gets created in
the folder and from that time onwards
git will start tracking any changes that
happen to that particular folder it also
creates a new repository and a branch by
default the branch that is created is
called the master branch
git add dot is a wildcard character for
adding any number of new files into your
git repository if you have a bunch of
files one file two file ten files a
folder containing multiple files in it
all of them could be added into the
repository using this command so once
you add any number of files into the
repository you can keep on adding more
and more files into the repository once
you're done with that you want to commit
the changes that has happened in the
repository you use the git commit
command git commit hyphen m with a
meaningful message
this will commit all the work items that
you've done in terms of the files that
got changed the files that got added all
this with one particular message get
status will give you the status of all
the files and folders any file that got
added any file that got created any file
that was deleted all the status of the
files will be obtained using the git
status command git log will show you all
the commit history with the latest
history or the latest commit showing up
on top git add remote origin this
command is used whenever you want to
link any local repository to a server
and this is when you want to really push
a repository from the local to the
server for the first time git push
hyphen u origin and master this is the
command that you would use whenever you
want to push contents from the local
repository to the server git clone and
the url of the server this is the
command that you will run whenever you
have an existing repository on the
server and you want to make a fresh
clone or a fresh copy of that particular
repository onto your local box
more than often many developers or git
users find themselves in situations
where they would want to go back in
history and modify
or change some of the files that they
recently committed or checked into the
repository now from a perspective of git
this is a very very simple activity
however from a perspective version
control tool you will have to be really
cautious about the chain that you're
gonna do in case the changes are pretty
local none of the developers or none of
the other users who are collaborating
with you would be affected by this
change you're good to go ahead and make
this change however if your repository
has been pushed to the server and you're
trying to modify something from history
this would have a very bad or adverse
effect on all the other users who'll be
using it you need to be really cautious
while running these commands in case
your repository contents are local you
have not pushed your changes to your
repository and if at all you made some
changes to the repository maybe to fix a
defect or to include a new feature and
you missed few things you can go ahead
and modify this with some of these
commands let's see i have this simple
repository called undo undo repo and if
at all i look at the logs of these i
have the commit histories which are like
this
i have about five commits that is there
in my repository and in c1 i've added a
file in c2 i've added another file in c3
i've also added some file in c4 i made
some changes to m1 and m3 and in c5 i've
added another file called m4 now this is
my commit history now let's say i made
these two comments but possibly i want
to club them together along with some
other changes because whatever changes i
did did not really fix things the way i
expected it to fix so there is a git
command called git reset this would
allow me to go back in history to go
back to any of the snapshot get rid of
all this commit history on the coming
messages but retain the changes that
were made as a part of these comments so
if at all i need to go back in history
and go back to this particular commit
and however i just want to get rid of
these commits that are there in terms of
the commit messages but i want the
changes that were there as a part of
these commits to still exist i would do
command called get reset
hyphen iphone soft
now this would go back or unwind my
changes back to this particular snapshot
getting rid of all the commit messages
that were there as a part of these two
comments but a soft would ensure that
the file changes that were done as a
part of these two commits would still
exist a full remain so the command for
that is git reset hyphen fn soft which
is the snapshot that i want to get back
to if this is the commit that i want to
get back to i just copy this
and i paste this
all right it doesn't give me any message
but if at all i do a git log pretty one
line
what it says is c1 c2 now the head which
is nothing but the current pointer which
is earlier pointing to c5 it's gone back
to c3 now what happened to the changes
that were there as a part of c4 and c5
if at all you do a git status if you see
the changes that were part of c4 were
some changes to m1 and m2 and c5 a new
file got m4 got added if what i do a git
status you'll see those changes still
exist however from the git history or
the git commit history c3 is the topmost
commit that exists as of now c4 and c5
have been gotten rid of but the changes
that were there still exist
all right now i can make some more
changes that i want if as a part of my
commit and possibly go ahead and commit
this whole thing as a new commit
altogether maybe
i'll open up a notepad and possibly
create a new file called m6.txt
and say
one
new file
that was missed out
i make this change
i go to a get status
all these files are still there i would
say git add dot
i'll say git
commit hyphen m
c4
rewriting history
and i do a get
log
pretty
there you go
so c1 c2 c3 still existed and whatever
was a part of c4 and c5 the older ones
i've gotten rid of this along with those
old changes i also added a new file i
made some changes and it was able to
commit it now if you look at my gate
history it's all nice and clean however
do this activity only when you don't
push your git repository to the server
one other most powerful and useful
command while undoing or resetting the
history is something called as revert
this is a safe way of undoing some
things remember what i talked about when
exactly you can do a reset it's only
when your changes are local and is not
being pushed to the repository take this
scenario wherein let's say i have a git
server
and i have the changes
which are c1
c2
c3
and possibly c4
all right so this is a bunch of comments
that has happened this was the oldest
comment and this is the newest comment
and if at all developer one as the one
who's responsible for pushing these
contents
in the first place so he has got c1 to
c4 on his history
i'm going to jump all these c2 and c3
and get into c4 and he's pushed all
these contents out here
and there are a bunch of people from the
server who has pulled this repository
and all of them are at the same level
now imagine a use case where developer 1
then figures out that by mistake he put
in the c3 which was the wrong thing to
do and possibly you know he could have
done a better job of fixing this in a
different way so he wants to get rid of
the c3 or c4 or any one of these
comments
if he's going to do that and push to the
server first of all the git server would
not allow him to go back in history but
assuming that he forcibly pushed
something
what would happen to all these people
who are looking to work ahead from c4
all of them would be affected in adverse
way so
in short never go back in history if at
all you need to undo something go ahead
and put in a new commit to undo
something
let's take this example maybe if at all
developer 1 wants to get rid of c3
better way to do that is by adding a new
commit which is ahead
say let's say c5 and what does this
commit do
this commit possibly gets rid of c3
instead of going back in history it
actually is taking your git history
ahead but as a part of this commit
you're undoing some part of the work
that was done as a part of c3 in short
you're removing a commit but to remove a
commit you're adding a new commit and
this is why you're doing it because
there are a bunch of other people who
are
you're using this repository
collaboratively and what planning to get
ahead in terms of history they cannot
afford to go back in history and modify
something in history all right the
command to do this is called the get
revert command
so let me take up this repository which
has got a bunch of commits in it and if
at all i do a git log
pretty one line
i have these bunch of comments
and c1 i've added a file in c2 hour
another file in c3 i've added one more
file and in c4 i made some changes and
this is the latest commit and this is
the oldest commit so if at all i see the
contents of the git
folder it contains m1 m2 m3 and m4
and let's say looking at the previous
use case that i mentioned i may want to
get rid of this particular commit
i want to get rid of the c3 which is
nothing but i've added a file called
m3.text but i added it by mistake
i need a better way of fixing it
possibly i look at it later on but for
now i don't want this particular commit
and the changes that were made as a part
of that commit to exist so the better
way to do that is using the git revert
command so git revert
and the commit id whatever i want to
revert so if i want to revert this
i copy this particular commit id and
bear in mind that considering a reset
revert works on one commit at a time so
i can do
one commit revert at a time i can club
bunch of them together and do one commit
but otherwise the revert always works on
one commit at a time so get revert
paste this essentially what i'm trying
to do i'm trying to undo this particular
commit while i'm undoing this commit
what does git do it safely adds a new
commit and a part of this new commit it
unders whatever changes that were done
as a part of this comment so if i say
git revert this
all right i forgot to mention the
message which is why this window is
showing up but that message is good for
me i say write and quit
all right and if i do a git log
all right if you see this c1 still is
there in history and our history is
going ahead from c5 i see another commit
but what was it as a part of this commit
actually is getting rid of this commit
c3 so if at all i see my files here
there's only m1 m2 and m4
m3 was added as a part of c3 now i've
gotten rid of m3
by getting rid of the revert command for
c3 so this is a better way of undoing
things
now that we have acquainted ourselves
with few of those basic git commands let
me get into a very very interesting
topic regarding git which is about
branching the topic is interesting
because kit deals with branches in a
completely different way compared to any
other version control tool
in most of the version control tools
whenever you create a new branch a
complete copy or a subset of the whole
repository is created which in my
opinion is very very cost inefficient
because it is a very very expensive
operation both in times of time and the
disk space
however in git you just create a very
very lightweight mobile pointer whenever
you create a branch there is no folder
or no copy of the repository that is
created in short the branches are very
very inexpensive and great so go ahead
and create any number of branches that
you need however once you create your
branches do all the work relating to
that branch in that specific branch and
once you've completed your task go ahead
and merge your branches back into your
base branch and then delete the branch
let me go ahead and create a repository
with some branches in this and give you
a demonstration of that
so let me go back to my base directory
which is git demo and then i'm going to
create a new folder here
i'll create a folder called arc details
all right this is my folder here
all right i navigate into this folder
and let me create a repository here
i initialize a repository a dot git
folder is created without any
files in it so let me create a few files
on it
say notepad name dot text
organization name
i create a name.text within this maybe
i'll create one more file in this
notepad
employees.txt
simply learn
has
over
3k employees
i just put in some content in this save
this content
all right
so if i try to go get status i just
see two files in it so let me go ahead
and
add these two files and let me commit my
changes so okay
commit iphone am or iphone m
first command
so if i do a gig log
i see only one commit and there are two
files so you can see those two files
that is here
all right
so at this stage let me go ahead and
create a new branch
and the command for creating new branch
is get
branch name of the branch
so let me name my branch as bangalore
branch blr branch
and this created a branch
but i don't see any changes in the
folder structure or in the file that
exists here
i've just created this branch so if at
all i do a git
branch
i see these two branches
and whatever star means i'm currently in
this master branch so let me go ahead
and get into the blr branch at this
moment the number of files that exist in
this repository is same there's
absolutely no change in any of the
branches both master and blr branch
point to the same snapshot
so let me get into
the other branch and the command to do
that is get checkout
blr branch i've actually switched into
bangalore branch if you see the content
of the files there's exactly two files
the way it was earlier because i've
created a branch from my base branch
which is a master branch and when i
created a branch there were two files
existing here if you see the content of
these files they would all be the same
all right so let me create a file that
is specific to panel branch
so i would just say notepad
maybe i want to put on the address of
this organization specific to bangalore
in this address.txt so i see notepad
address dot text
we'll say simply learn
angular office
say located in
some address
i would say bangalore
that is the content of this file
and i'm creating all this new file in
this blr branch so i would say git add
dot
and i would say git
commit hyphen m
bangalore
branch
commit
all right if you see this now i have an
address.text which is there only in the
bangalore branch that i'm presently on
now let me switch back to my master
branch the command to do that is git
check out
master branch
if you remember when i forked out or
when i created a new branch from the
master branch i didn't have this address
or text in it so let me go back to git
git check out master branch
and keep noticing this particular
what happened to the address.txt
it kind of disappeared
how did that happen it's all because of
this magical git folder so what happened
is now git knows that when you are in
the master branch the
file that was there in the bangalore
branch which was called the
address dot text didn't exist
so
git is playing around with the file
system snapshot so if i come back let's
say i come back to get check out
bangalore branch
if you see this the address.txt file
appears
so this particular file is only present
in the branch and git is playing around
with the file system snapshot by moving
the pointers across and ensuring that
whenever i'm switching to bangalore
branch i see this address dot text when
i go back to my master branch i don't
see this bangalore branch
contents which is the address.txt
all right now that i created this branch
maybe i may need to push this onto the
server so let me go ahead and create a
particular repository structure on the
server similar to whatever we did in our
previous exercise
so the name of the folder needs to be
exactly this one so let me copy this
and let me create a repository very
quickly
go here and say new repository
all right
this
is the name of the repository
get
branch demo this is what i'm going to
put in as a description i would say
public i don't want any readme files in
it because i already have a repository i
will just say create a repository
all right
let me use
the ssh url yeah this is the ssh url
this is good for me so let me copy this
url
let me add it here
i'm linking my local repository with the
server
and i would let me come back to my
master branch
let me first push my master branch so i
would say git
push
iphone u origin
master
it asks for my passphrase
all right
i pushed my master branch looks good it
says new branch master is created so if
i go back to my server and i do a
refresh
if you see it says only one branch
and it says what is the name of the
branch master
if you see the contents there is
employees.txt and name dot text
now
let's try to push the other branch that
is there the command to do that is a
little different compared to
the way we created it on the client
because on the client we created the
branch with a git branch command now
this branch doesn't exist on the server
and i need to push this new branch onto
the server so the command would be
gate
push
hyphen u
origin
and the name of the branch that i want
to specifically push
all right now it created a branch out
here
let me do a refresh of this
all right it says two branches
if i get into this bangalore branch i
would see the address dot text if at all
i go back into master branch i would not
see this address.txt
wonderful
now let me do one thing let me try to
get the changes from the branch that i
created back into the master branch that
is what i would mean by
merging i would want the changes that is
there as a part of the bangalore branch
to come back into my master branch so if
i go to click checkout
bankrupt branch i see this attention
this is there only as a part of
bangalore branch now assuming that i'm
done with the changes from the binary
branch i want to get those changes back
into my master so let me come back
to my master branch
and the way to merge in the changes is
get merge
so what is that you want to merge i want
to merge the bangle branch changes and
where will it merge it will merge it
into the current branch that i'm on
presently i'm in the master branch so
this command would merge the changes
from the bangalore branch into your
master branch so with this if you'll
keep looking here the content that was
there that was added as a part of
bangalore branch which is nothing but
the address dot text this file should
appear as soon as we do a merge
all right so it happened
quickly and you would see this address
dot text that is here so if you see
let's check the contents in terms of the
git log
all right so there is only one branch
that we had earlier which had only one
commit right now we are at this
bangalore branch commit which was there
as a part of the bangalore branch commit
so with this change let me push this
change onto the server as well gate push
origin
master
okay those changes were pushed to the
server and now
if at all i do a refresh out here
okay i'm in two branches
the branches master even if i'm in
master brands i should see this address
dot text that is there even if i'm in
the bangalore branch the content is all
same because we immerse these two
branches
now that i've merged this branch i don't
need this branch anymore so i would go
ahead and delete this locally as well as
push it onto the server so that it gets
deleted from the server as well so
delete branch locally the command is get
branch
hyphen d and the name of the branch
only thing you need to ensure is that
you should not be currently on that
branch which you're trying to delete so
i would say get branch
and i'm presently in the master branch
so i can go ahead and delete the other
branch so get branch hyphen d bangle
branch
all right this got rid of our bandwidth
branch locally
if at all i don't get branch hyphen we
it shows there's only one branch as of
now however this branch would still
exist on the server because server
doesn't know anything about the changes
that we have done
we need to specifically push our changes
onto the server
okay there are two branches still here
so let me go ahead and push these
changes so that the branch gets deleted
from the server as well the command to
do that is get
push
origin
hyphen iphone delete
and the name of the branch
all right
so this went ahead and deleted the
branch
from the server let's check that
okay if you see now there's only one
branch
these are the basic steps that you would
need to know before you work with any of
the branches within kit and as i said
before the branches are very very
inexpensive and good go ahead and create
any number of branches that you want but
just ensure that once you create your
branch finish of your task and once you
finish off your task go ahead and delete
the branch and before you delete the
brands please ensure that you merge in
the branches so that you get in or take
in the work that was done as a part of
that particular branch
to summarize the gate branching commands
are as follows to create a new branch
you issue a command git branch the name
of the branch and this would
automatically spin off or create a new
branch from the existing branch from
where you issue this command if you are
on the master branch and if you execute
this command git branch new underscored
branch it creates a new underscore
branch from the master branch once you
create a new branch in order to get into
this branch you would type in git check
out the name of the branch
this would automatically switch the file
system snapshot between different
branches now the branches that are
created are by default created on the
local repository in case you want to
push any specific branch onto the server
you would have to issue a command git
push hyphen u origin and the name of the
branch so this will ensure that the
contents of the new branch are pushed
onto the server at any time if you want
to list out all existing branches on
your local repositories the command
would be git branch hyphen av assuming
that you did all your work in a new
branch and you're happy with the changes
you would want to bring back those
changes into the master branch the
command to merge the contents of any new
branch into a master branch would be git
merge and the name of the branch
this would automatically merge the
branch contents that you specified into
the branch on which you currently reside
if at all you are on the master branch
and if you issue a command git merge new
underscore branch this would merge the
contents of the new branch onto the
master branch so once you merge the
contents of any branch you would
possibly want to go ahead and delete
this branch so the command to delete
those branch locally is get branch
hyphen capital d and the name of the
branch this again would delete the
branch locally in order to make this
change on the server which is in order
to remove this branch from the server
the command to do that is get push
origin hyphen iphone delete and the name
of the branch this would also delete the
branch that you created on the server
hello guys this is vikesh so when we
talk about java it is one of the most
popular programming language out there
and it was created way back in 1991 but
it was publicly released only in 1995.
it was developed by one of the famous
developers of our generation who is
james gosling at sun microsystems and
then later java was acquired by oracle
and today oracle owns java java is very
simple and easy to use and we will look
at different aspects of how it is easy
and simple to use
it's a write once run anywhere type of
programming language again we will look
at details into into into this
particular concept as well and when we
talk about the usage of java you can use
it to build web applications mobile
applications desktop applications even
command line applications and at the
same time you can also use it to build
complex applications like gaming
applications building microservices or
building distributed computing etc let's
talk about the features of java so one
of the most prominent features of java
is that it's a object oriented
programming language which means that
everything which happens in java happens
around objects
objects enable the execution of the
program objects talk to each other to
exchange data and messages we will look
at a look at the concept of objects in
details in the upcoming lectures
it's a platform independent language
which means that
again going back to the previous point
of write once run anywhere it basically
enables the program to be run on any
platform once compiled so once you have
prepared your program and you have
compiled your program then your compile
program can be run on any platform it is
a strong type checking language which
means that it will
force you to respect the contracts of
the variables to the data types for
example if you have created a collection
which should accept strings then
you can only insert strings in that
collection and it will not allow you to
add an a number or an integer into that
collection so it's a strongly type
checking language so when you run your
program it's a two-step process in java
you compile the program and then you it
then you execute the program which we
also call as interpretation so you have
a java compiler
and you have a java interpreter you
first compile your program and then you
run the program using the help of java
interpreter java also provides automatic
garbage collection it's a really
important feature and if you talk about
the languages prior to java like c or c
plus plus they did not offer this
capability and this capability made java
really popular because it could
automatically find the unused objects
and variables and remove them from the
memory to free up memory space for the
program execution it also provides
multi-threading support which means that
you can build multi-threading
applications like a gaming application
if you take the example of a racing game
for example so
there's there can be one thread which is
monitoring your leaderboard score there
can be another thread which is
displaying the speed of the car there
displaying the graphic there can be
another thread which is displaying the
sound so you see all of these threads
are working parallelly and java provides
the support to create such applications
using the multi-threading capability it
has
java is secure by default because there
are no pointers in java so there are no
possibilities of having any memory leaks
or any reference leaks from the
application again if you take the
example of uh programming languages like
c or c plus plus you had the concept of
pointers and we we witnessed lot of a
lot of scenarios and lot of incidents
where there was a memory leakage
happening in the in the production
application which was which was really a
bad experience for the organizations so
java removed the concept of pointers
totally from its programming language
it's also a very robust language because
it provides a really great exception
handling framework out of the box
which developers can use and implement
to build really resilient applications
so now let us understand how a java
program is run so at first you basically
write your java program and you store
your java program into a dot java file
then you compile your java file with the
help of the java compiler once the
program is compiled the compiler is
going to generate another file which is
a dot class file and this dot class file
is basically the compiled file or also
known as the byte code file so this byte
code or the dot class file code can be
run on any platform be it a linux
platform or a windows platform or a
macos platform or any other platform to
give you some more context the first two
steps where you write your java program
and you compile your java program can be
run on any machine let's take the
example that you ran these two steps on
a windows machine so you ran your you
write your program and you compiled your
program on a windows machine which
generated a dot class file then you
transported this dot class file to a
linux machine and it also worked there
you transported your class file to a mac
os machine and it worked there as well
and that's what brings the platform
independence concept of java that you
can write the program once
on any platform and once you have the
byte code available then you can run
this program on any other platform of
your choice
okay so that was about how the java
program execution works and how the
platform independence is actually
achieved now let us spend some time to
understand the anatomy of java so once
you download java and install java on
your local machine you will hear the
term jdk
actually if you will see that in the
next lecture that when you try to
download the java it will say jdk
download jdk stands for java development
kit so the java development kit is the
installation of the java this is what
you're going to install on your machine
once the jdk or java development kit has
been installed the jdk will provide lot
of other components as well like java
runtime environment or jre java virtual
machine or jvm
some class libraries and some other
supporting libraries so let us
understand what happens when your
program is run and how these components
work together to make sure that your
program runs as expected let's start
from here so you install jdk or the java
development kit you write your program
and then you compile your program with
the help of java compiler which is
provided by jdk once the program is
compiled your dot class file will be
generated and then you can
run that dot class file using gre in
fact if you just run your program on
your local machine jre will
automatically kick in and run your class
file so the java runtime environment or
jre runs your dot class file with the
help of these three components
let's talk about first component which
is java virtual machine or jvm so the
java virtual machine is actually the
virtual environment inside which your
program runs this is the real main
environment inside your dot class file
is running so when
when this program is running how does it
achieves this environment for achieving
this virtual virtual machine environment
it would need some runtime libraries and
that is provided by these class
libraries for example there would be a
runtime jar or rt.jar as a shorthand
which will be supplied to the program at
the runtime to make sure that the
program runs smoothly then there are
other supporting libraries as well which
your program may be using for example if
this program this dot class file is
let's say a calculator program
then it might be using a square root
function from java.math package so how
do how does the java.math package gets
supplied at runtime it would be supplied
by the other supporting libraries which
are present inside gre so jre will make
sure that your program runs inside the
java virtual machine it gets the
required runtime libraries and it also
gets the libraries which are referred in
your program at runtime and this all
together will make sure that your
program is running so you can see jdk
basically
provides gre automatically and jvm
automatically but you can also install
gre separately if you talk about that
use case where you compile your program
on a windows machine using jdk and then
you exported your dot class file to
another machine and there you just
installed the gre you don't install jdk
there you just installed the runtime
environment and you can run the dot
class file just using the runtime
environment let's get started with
inheritance
so inheritance is basically one of the
most important properties of any
object-oriented programming language
it's basically a concept and the concept
says that what if you have a scenario
where you want multiple classes to share
similar behavior and similar properties
let's understand this with the help of
an example let's take the example of a
bank
when you go to a bank to open an account
there are multiple types of accounts
there can be a savings account it can be
a type of current account there can also
be a different offering for personal
account and commercial accounts such as
for businesses
then you may also have loan accounts
which are having different kind of
properties so all of these types of
accounts are still
technically accounts and they will share
some similar properties for example all
of them will have to maintain some sort
of an interest rate for example all of
them will be used to either deposit
money or withdraw money so there would
be some kind of similarity across all of
these types of account classes but at
the same time there will also be some
sort of differentiality amongst these
classes the way you will calculate the
interest rate for a current account will
be different from the way you will
calculate the interest rate for a
savings account and the same applies for
commercial account personal account loan
account etc so you see that we have some
common behavior but at the same time we
also have some different behavior so
whenever you have such scenario always
think about applying the concept of
inheritance in your application there is
another simple way to spot whether
inheritance can be used at a particular
place or not inheritance is also called
is a relationship so whenever you read
the requirements from a customer just
try to find the words which use this
particular phrase is a
for example
car is a vehicle
savings account is a type of account
similarly you will find many other types
of similar examples so whenever you will
see that is a relationship between two
different kinds of objects or two
different kind of entities that means
that there might be an inheritance
relationship being applied between them
and that's how you will spot the usage
of inheritance
so so far we have understood this
concept that there would be some sort of
relationship between the two classes
what will be this relationship the
relationship will be of parent child
type there will be a parent class some
people also call that as base class and
then there will be a child class so the
child class will be inheriting the
properties and the behaviors from the
base class or from the parent class i
will be using base class and parent
class terms interchangeably during this
session but the basic idea and basic
premise is like that only that there
will be a child class and there will be
a parent class and the child class class
is extending from the parents class
remember the word extend because we are
going to use that and i've just shown
you the uh what you see here is
basically the official definition which
is given by javadocs here you can read
the definition as well and the basic
idea which i told you lies in the parent
and child relationship and this is how
you can conceptualize it that you will
have a base class or a parent class
and then you will you can have multiple
children of it and then those children
can again have their own children and so
on so forth so this hierarchy this whole
inheritance hierarchy can go as deep as
you want it to be and that's the basic
idea and basic conceptualization of how
you understand and how you visualize
inheritance now let's move to eclipse
ide and try to understand this with the
help of an example so for this
particular case i have created a set of
classes basically which we will be using
to demonstrate the relationship of
inheritance and i've taken the simple
example of a bicycle so a bicycle is
again a very generic definition of any
two wheeler and bicycles can have
multiple types there can be an
all-terrain bike there can be a mountain
bike there can be a city bike there can
be a bike which is specific specifically
made for ladies and similarly there can
be multiple different types of bikes but
all of these bikes will have some
similar properties
for example all of them will have two
wheels all of them will have a seat all
of them will have brake all of them will
have some sort of some sort of a
speeding mechanism whether they can
accelerate or de-accelerate so there
will be some commonality but at the same
time a mountain bike's features might be
very different from a city bike feature
a mountain bike features might featu
mountain bike might have gears for
example whereas a city bike might not
have gears because you don't need that
much of a variation in in inclination
and declination when you drive down the
road so i'm trying to conceptualize the
same example here where i've created a
class called bicycle and this is my base
class i define two properties in the in
the bicycle class which is
gear and speed we will come back to
protected in a while but
let's let's leave that there so i have
two properties which is gear and speed i
have a constructor where i'm
initializing the starting speed and the
starting gear and then
i have three methods here which says set
gear apply brake and speed up when i
apply brake the speed is going to get
reduced so that's why you see minus
equal to unity operator
and when i'm trying to speed up the
speed is going to increase that's why
i'm using the plus equal to unary
operator so when you use the method
speed up the speed is going to be
increased by the value you supply in the
method similarly when you apply the
brake the speed is going to get reduced
by the amount you supply in the method
argument and that is my base class
bicycle gear speed and three methods now
let's have a look at the child class
so the way you will define the
inheritance relationship in java is by
using this extends keyword remember i
told you to remember the extends keyword
so what you will do that you will write
your class name as usual and then you
will use extends keyword and then you
will use the parent class name or the
base class name so here i am saying
class mountain bike extends bicycle and
here i am providing an additional
property remember the whole commonality
versus differentiality equation so a
mountain bike might have an extra
property to adjust the seat height so
that's the extra property which mountain
bike is having and then
since this mountain bike is extending
the bicycle class
this mountain bike class has the
responsibility to initialize the bicycle
class as well and the way it will
fulfill that responsibility is by taking
all the arguments of bicycle class plus
the mountain bike class in its
constructor and that's why you see three
different properties here you see the
start height property which is the
property of this particular class which
is the seat height and then you see the
start speed and start gear property
which directly are not available in this
class but this class is inheriting those
properties from the base class remember
the keyword inheritance here and then
once you do that how do you initialize
the base class constructor is by calling
the super method this is again a keyword
in java and you will use this super
keyword to
refer to the base class constructor in
this way so what you will do technically
is that you will write super and you
will supply the arguments which is
required by the base class constructor
if i go back the base class constructor
requires two arguments start speed and
start gear
so i write super and then i write start
speed and start gear so whatever i got
from here in the constructor of mountain
bike i'm supplying those values as is to
super and java will automatically take
care of invoking this particular
constructor the moment it
encounters this kind of statement
another another thing to notice is that
the super keyword or super statement has
to be the first statement inside your
constructor remember that whenever you
are dealing with inheritance and
whenever you have to initialize the
super class constructor or the base
class constructor use the super
constructor invocation as the very first
statement inside your child class
constructor otherwise java will not
compile the program and then you will
initialize the local variable i should
call this as this remember i we
discussed about this in this in the
classes session
okay and then it just has a method of
set height so there's no extra method
which this mountain bike is providing
but this mountain bike will have access
to all the methods which have been
provided here and all the properties
which have been provided here this
mountain bike can access everything from
the bicycle class and that's the whole
idea of inheritance that the child class
can access the properties of the base
class by extending the base class
now let's look at how do we invoke this
particular class so for that i have a
simple class name as inheritance demo
which has a public static void main
method and then i am initializing the
mountain bike plus
i'm supplying three values as 20 10 and
so the 20 goes to start height
the 10 here goes to
start speed
and
one here goes to gear or the start gear
and that's how i'm setting the values so
when i call this particular constructor
here the mountain bike constructor is
going to this mountain bike constructor
is going to get called and which in turn
is going to call the base class bicycle
class constructor as well and everything
will be set accordingly and then let's
try to access the gear property remember
gear is not directly available in the
mountain bike class but i'm still able
to do mountain bike dot gear because
child class can access the parent's
class properties
similarly the same thing goes for speed
as well and seat height is the local
property of this particular class
mountain bike so it will anyways be
accessible so i can access all the
properties of the base class and the
child class itself seamlessly without
any differentiation now let's try to
call a method so here i'm calling the
method apply break remember apply break
was defined in the base class not in the
child class it's defined here
so i'm calling the apply break method
and i want to reduce the speed the
current speed by one and then i'm
printing the current speed saying that
bike speed after applying break is
mountain bike dot speed so let's run
this particular program and observe the
outputs
okay
so the the first statement which gets
printed is at line number seven which
says gear is
one because it's coming from here then
the seat height is mountain bike dot
seat height which is 20 which is the
first argument here and then the bike
speed is 10 which is coming as here and
getting printed here and then when i
apply the brake
let's go back to the apply break method
the logic is that whatever is the
current speed reduce it by the value i
supply in the method
so if i supply 1 10 minus 1 becomes 9
and that becomes the current speed if i
supply 5 here the current speed will be
10 minus 5 equal to 5. let's assert that
particular assumption as well yes we can
see that and similarly you can access
other methods of the base class as well
if i just do control space here and you
can see apply break is accessible set
gear set height speed up all the methods
which are defined in the base class are
accessible in the child class as well
this is the power of inheritance one
more thing which i said i will come back
to is around the usage of protected
access modifier
remember when we discussed about the
access modifiers in the previous session
i said that protected is used when you
are dealing with inheritance that
whenever you define something as
protected it will be available to be
accessible in the child classes of the
base class so if i define this
particular variable as as protected then
this particular property will be
accessible in the child class mountain
bike as well
let's play around this let's make this
as private and see what happens so if i
make this private now when i say private
the scope of this particular variable is
within the class only and nobody outside
the class will be able to see it
and you can see the effect of it i can
see an error being coming here in my
inheritance demo class because now
mountain bike object cannot access the
gear property because the gear property
is defined in the base class and now it
is private that's why the child class
now mountain bike class cannot access
the property gear
and the moment you make make it back to
protected it will be accessible the
error is gone there's no red line here
so that's how you can you can use the
protected access modifiers it is always
always recommended to use them when you
when you write any kind of inheritance
logic and inheritance logic as well
intentionally if you want to hide a
particular property from the child
classes just make it private and that's
all i want to cover in this particular
session where we uh dive deep into the
concept of inheritance we had a look at
an example using the bicycle and
mountain bike kind of construct and you
can apply the same kind of construct on
any kind of other other kind of business
requirement remember the is a
relationship
so that's all i want to cover in this
particular session and in the next
session we are going to talk about
another very interesting concept of java
which is about encapsulation let's get
started with encapsulation so again
let's understand what is encapsulation
in general and then we will apply that
concept to java encapsulation if you try
to break that word if i just write it
here in the form of a comment
it's n
capsulation just trying to break this
word into to make it more visual so you
see you see a word called capsule here
so if you try to imagine a capsule why
do you create that and what's the
concept of a capsule capsule tries to
pack a lot of things inside a small
tube-like shape and the concept of
encapsulation is sort of inspired from
that not exactly not literally but
that's the basic idea of of this root
word which is called encapsulation so
encapsulation basically means to
restrict
accessing the properties of a class to
the outside world if you want to protect
the properties of your class how do you
do that you do that with the help of the
concept called encapsulation so here you
this is a sort of a security feature you
can think of a think of it as a security
feature that you want to protect the
properties of your class
and you will use encapsulation to
protect the properties how you implement
encapsulation let's have a look at that
now so basic idea is to encapsulate the
objects create sort of a capsule around
the object which can provide that
protection layer and you will define how
the outside world is going to access the
properties of the class if needed so
i've created a simple class here
and
it's if you if you remember one of the
previous examples when we discussed
about classes i used the same class
which was the student class and i'm just
using the same class for continuity so
i've created a student class here and i
have created three different properties
of this particular class which is name
name of the student age of the student
and address of the student you see
intentionally i have used the keyword
private
in front of these three properties and
that is the first thing which you need
to do to implement encapsulation on your
object that you hide all the properties
from the outside world remember the
moment you make anything is private only
the class which is the student class
itself only the class itself can see
these variables or these properties
nothing outside the student class will
be able to
access the name or age or the address
directly from the student class it's not
possible that's the whole idea of making
it private because you don't want the
outside world to access these properties
so you make those properties as private
then you create a constructor the
constructor has to be public so that
anybody can initialize the student
object because you want your object to
be accessible remember so you want the
objects to be accessible but you want
the restriction on the access
of the properties of the object
and these are the properties of the
object
so you have restricted them by making it
private but that doesn't solve the
problem because there will be some
illegitimate consumers of the student
object which should not have access to
the student properties but there will
also be some legitimate consumers of the
student object which should be having
access to the properties of the student
for example the payroll
application will need access to these
particular
properties the examination application
will require access to these particular
properties so how do you do that
you create getters we call them getters
because they start with the keyword
get so you create a getter method for
each of the property you create the
method called as get name and this is
the naming convention with java promotes
that you write get and then you write
the name of the property in camel case
so you write get name and this property
is supposed to return the name property
of this particular object and you here
you say return name so you're returning
the the name which is being stored by
the current student object whenever
somebody calls student object dot get
name and this is the way you have
restricted the access of this particular
object as well so remember you made it
private so that nobody can access it and
then you defined your own way of
providing access to the
name property of this particular class
now if anybody wants to access the name
value of your student object there's
only one and one way to do that which is
via calling get name so you have
provided restrictions and you have also
provided prescriptive guidance on how
you are going to expose the properties
of your class that's the second
thing which you need to do to implement
correct form of encapsulation on your
object that that is to provide the
getter methods with the right visibility
you want to make them public so that
anybody can call them but
since you are governing which is what is
written inside the method you have full
control on what kind of exposure you
want to give for this particular
property similarly you create a getter
for age calling getage which returns the
age and then you call get you write get
address and return the address here it
is simply returning it but if you want
to do more stuff here feel free to do
that like i said you govern the control
of how do you want to return the name
maybe you don't want to return the
complete name and you want to just
return the initials then you can split
the string trim the string and return
only the initials so that's the basic
idea of getters
now after you have created the object
there might be use cases where somebody
needs to overwrite the values of the
properties like name age or address
whatever student's name was incorrectly
mentioned when they called the
constructor and now they want to
overwrite the name or fix the name so
basically they have to replace the
existing value of the name with a new
name
so in that case you need to provide what
we call as setters and they start with
set that's why we call them setters and
we follow the same kind of logic that
you provide the setters for all the
properties of your class so you had
three properties which were named age
and address and you provided the setters
for all three of them and how do you
provide that you write you again make
them as public because you want the
outside world to access this setter
method to overwrite the values of the
name this method is not going to return
anything so it is going to be void then
you write the name of the method which
starts with set and then the property
name in camel case and then you provide
the new value which is the value which
should be which should be the new value
and this is the value which should
replace the existing value so whatever
new value you want to supply you supply
that as the argument of the setter
methods for set name for set age or for
set address and then you write this
particular line which says
set the current name property of this
particular object with the name which is
coming in from the argument so this dot
name remember this dot name represents
the current objects property because
this represents the current object so
whatever is the current object property
value of the name is just override that
value with the argument coming in do the
same thing for age and set age method
and do the same thing for set address in
the in the set address method so this is
how you are going to provide the setters
and the getters
so setters and getters can also be
generated in smart id is like eclipse so
you just right click you go to source
and here you will see the option of
generate getters and setters if you
click on this it will give you the list
of the fields which are available to be
had to be having getters and setters
currently it says no fields or all
fields have getters and setters already
yes because they have it let me just
comment this and show this how this work
so for example let me comment all the
getters and setters so i'm commenting
them and if i right click
source
generate getters and setters i get all
the fields available for which setters
and getters can be generated so you can
select them and leave everything as
default hit generate and it is
automatically going to generate the
getters and the setter you see all the
code of the getter and setter is
automatically generated you do not even
need to write it and this is the power
of the smart ides let me just uh revert
what i did
so you created everything as all the
properties as private
and then you define how you want to
replace the values by providing the
setters and you define how you want the
outside world to access your properties
so you have full control of the class
now you you control the visibility you
control how they are going to get
initialized you are you are controlling
how the properties are going to be
overwritten or set and you control how
the properties are going to be returned
so you have complete control of the
class so you have created a perfect
capsule here a perfect form of
encapsulation in this class and this is
how you can implement encapsulation and
that's all i'm going to cover for this
particular session in the next session
we are going to discuss about
abstraction let's get started with
abstraction let's first understand the
definition of abstraction before we
relate this to java abstraction
generally means hiding something when
you want to hide some details of of a
particular object from the outside world
you apply the concept of abstraction for
example when you drive a particular car
you just hit the accelerator and the car
speeds up now it's not only one action
when you hit the accelerator the whole
machinery of the car and all the
components different parts of the car
work together to speed up they would be
engine there would be propulsion there
would be fuel there would be there might
be some if it's an electric car there
would batteries uh there would be whole
different kinds of pistons and plugs
which will make the car speed up it's
not only a single component it's a lot
of different components under the hood
and that's the concept of abstraction
that we only show the relevant parts to
the user and we hide all the internal
details from the user that's the basic
idea of abstraction so a car
manufacturer abstracts away all the
inner technical details from the driver
and just gives the driver a single pedal
to speed up the car for a user it's a
very good experience because he doesn't
need to know about all the internals of
the car but the car manufacturer can
hide all the details and provide a very
simple interface for the driver to
interact with which is just a gas pedal
and that's the basic idea of abstraction
and we try to apply the same kind of
concept to java in the form of
abstraction and java provides this kind
of concept implementation with the help
of a keyword which is called abstract
now abstract is a keyword which can be
used in front of a class or a method
when you use it in front of a class
the whole class becomes abstract
abstract class is a type of class so the
class itself becomes an abstract class
one of the things to remember is that
abstract class cannot be instantiated
but can be subclassed remember we talked
about the concept of subclass and the
parent class when we talked about
inheritance so if you make a class as
abstract class you cannot call the
constructor of the class because you
cannot instantiate it but you can extend
the abstract class and create a child
class class out of it that's the concept
of abstract class another concept is
abstract method you can also use the
abstract keyword in front of a method
and when you use abstract keyword in
front of a method then that method is
only declared without an implementation
you are not going to provide any
implementation of the method and you're
just going to declare the method
something like this we will see a
similar example in the in the hands-on
as well but that's the basic idea that
you just declare the method you are not
providing an implementation as to what
does move to method actually does
because that's the whole concept of
abstraction and it is the responsibility
of the child classes which inherit the
particular class in which the abstract
method would be sitting so that child
class will be having the responsibility
to provide a concrete implementation of
the declared method let's understand
this better with the help of an example
so here i have created a class called
graphic object and i have made the class
as abstract class
this is the keyword which you need to
use in front before the class keyword
and the task becomes an abstract class
now when you create an abstract class it
automatically gets some properties the
first property is that this particular
class must have at least one abstract
method and this is how you define the
abstract methods where you just provide
the declaration but you do not provide
the implementation of the draw method or
the resize method and the way you will
create the abstract methods is by using
the abstract keyword before the actual
method declaration starts so general
method declaration would look like this
and if you use abstract in front of it
this becomes an abstract method
declaration abstract class can also have
concrete methods so that is the liberty
which abstract class gives you that you
can have abstract methods which are just
declared but you can also have normal
methods which are which
where you can also provide the
implementation so you can have normal
methods and abstract methods as well in
an abstract class
so this is the abstract class now if if
you want to provide an implementation of
the draw and resize method you have to
extend this abstract class so we extend
this abstract class by creating two
child classes out of this particular
abstract class which is circle.java
where you can see i create a normal
class and i use the extends keyword for
inheritance and i'm saying that circuit
class is inheriting from the graphic
object class which was my abstract class
and once i use this extends keyword then
i have the responsibility of providing
the implementation of the abstract
methods actually java will force me to
provide the implementation of these two
methods if i do not provide all the
declared methods so there are two
declared methods here so if the circuit
class does not provide that the
implementation for both draw and resize
methods then java will throw an error
and it will ask you to take an action
which can be either define all the
methods meaning provide implementation
for all the methods or
make the circle class itself as abstract
let's see if i just comment this
particular out i get an error you see a
red line here and if you click on this
particular balloon here it will say
either you can add the unimplemented
methods or you can make the circle type
as abstract these are the two options
which you will get to fix this
particular error so an abstract class
can be extended by another abstract
class if the child abstract class is not
implementing all the methods of the
parent if you want to implement all the
methods then just implement them and
keep keep it as a normal class and
that's what i've done here i've just
created a normal class here and provided
the implementation and once you provide
the implementation of both of the
methods the error is gone similarly i
have also provided another child class
because it's
there can be
there can be multiple children of a
particular parent so rectangle also
extends from the graphic object and it
also provides its own implementation of
drawing and resize because generally the
way you will draw a rectangle and you
resize a rectangle will be different
than drawing or resizing a circle here
i'm not doing anything in the methods
because this is just to show you the
demonstration i'm just printing a cis
out saying drawing a circle and resizing
or drawing a rectangle and resizing a
rectangle and in the circle class
drawing a circle and resizing a circle
so one abstract class is the parent
class which is the graphic object and
two children circle and rectangle both
providing the implementation of the
abstract methods which were declared in
the base class now let's go to the main
class where i've defined defined the
public static void main method and here
you see i have created two different
kind of blocks of code here one block is
where i'm saying graphic object creating
a reference of the graphic object named
as circle and initializing the circle
object now you see a difference here
here is the abstract class and here is
the concrete class so whatever you
define on the right hand side whatever
is the type of object will be the type
of methods being called so if you
created a circle object and then if you
call the draw method and resize method
these methods will be called from the
circle class if you initialized it as
new rectangle then you are creating a
rectangle class object and then the draw
and the resize method will be called
from the rectangle class that's the
basic construct and that's how you will
initialize
a a particular class which is using an
abstract class so i i call a graphic
object circle new circle and i call
circle.draw and circle dot resize
similarly graphic object rectangle equal
to new rectangle and rectangle.draw
rectangle.resize
let's run this program and observe the
output so when i call this particular
block of code circle object gets
initialized and then circle.draw method
prints drawing a circle and
circle.resize method prints drawing
resizing a circle similarly when i
create the rectangle class object
referencing it with the graphic object
class
rectangle.draw prints this particular
line drawing a rectangle and
rectangle.resize
prints this particular line which is
resizing a rectangle and this is how you
will use the concept of abstraction
there's another very interesting thing
which which is which is going on here
remember i told if i do this and i i
create i just put a system out here
base
abstract plus so if i do this here if i
create if i still write a constructor
though java says that it cannot be
instantiated if i still write a
constructor of it and i do not do any
changes here and if i run this
particular program let's see what
happens you'll see the base abstract
class being called here let me just
reformat it by putting ln here so that
we get a better output so if i run this
particular program you see base abstract
class is getting printed somehow though
we said that abstract classes cannot be
instantiated but still the constructor
of this is still getting called somehow
when i create a circle class the base
class constructor gets called and when i
create a rectangle class again the base
class constructor gets called this is
this is the power of inheritance because
in inheritance remember how it works
when you call when you initialize a
particular child object referencing it
with the parent object see the
references of the parent class and the
object is of the child class so whenever
you do it like this
first the default constructor because
i'm calling the default constructor here
the default constructor of the circle
class will get called which will go here
remember i told you that java provides
the default constructor automatically if
you don't provide it so the default
constructor of circle gets called but
java sees that you are writing this code
here which says circle extends graphic
object so java is automatically going to
call the parent class and going to
initialize the parent class as well
because that's how it will be able to
see these methods and so so that's why
it will automatically call the base
class constructor even if you don't call
it explicitly in fact you cannot call it
explicitly java will not allow you to
initialize the graphic object class
explicitly it can only and only be
called by java itself indirectly via the
concept of inheritance if you try to do
this let's try to do this for fun and
and also for better understanding so if
i write graphic object
go equal to
new graphic object you see i don't even
get an option but let's write it and
let's see what happens so you see that
this particular it gives basically an
error because it's not able to find the
constructor of the graphic object class
though even i have defined the default
constructor here but still java is not
able to find it because this class is
abstract so hence proved abstract
classes cannot be instantiated
explicitly they can only be instantiated
by the child classes through the
internal mechanisms of java itself and
that's all i want to talk about in this
particular session where we looked in
detail about the concept of abstraction
couple of more things which i did not
cover in the previous session i just
want to call them out for clarity java
does not support multiple inheritance
when i say multiple inheritance what it
means that you will not have a scenario
where a child will be extending from two
base classes java does not support it it
does support it with with the help of
interfaces but i will talk about
interfaces in the coming sessions but
here just understand this that you
cannot use multiple inheritance with
classes in java a child cannot have two
parent or two base classes in java java
will not allow that it is also called
the diamond problem because the child
class does not know whether to follow
the route of base 1 plus or the base 2
class if if it is extending from 2
different base 1 and base 2 classes so a
class can only extend from one class in
java we can find a workaround of it by
using the concept of interfaces but
that's something which will be coming
later another thing to understand is
that when you create an abstract class
here these variables you can declare
declare these variables as well and
these variables will be accessible by
all the child classes as you access them
let's get started with polymorphism so
polymorphism is a very generic concept
which means that a particular object can
take multiple form let's not even call
it as object let's make it more generic
a particular entity can take multiple
forms if any entity in java exhibits
that kind of behavior then we say that
polymorphism is in action that entity
can be a class or an object or even a
method and in today's session we are
going to talk about that type of
polymorphism which is exhibited by
methods so we will see how a particular
method in java can take many different
forms containing different logics but
still having the same name and that
concept is called method overloading so
whenever you hear the word that you need
to overload a particular method or this
is method overloading happening
technically or conceptually it's
basically polymorphism in action and
polymorphism is being applied on a
method here and that phenomena we call
as method overloading so in today's
session we are going to have a look at
how we can implement method overloading
in java so the basic idea of method
overloading is that the name of the
method should remain the same so you see
in this particular class which i have
created to demonstrate the method
overloading so this is the class name
and the method name which i am going to
overload is called multiply and that is
probably the first thing which you need
to remember to implement over method
overloading correctly that the method
name is going to remain the same the
type of the return of the method may
change here you see it's returning in
here in the first instance in the second
instance also it is returning int but in
the third instance it is returning
double so the return type of an
overloaded method can change
another another thing which which can be
varied between same method being defined
again and again is that the number of
arguments and the type of arguments the
first multiply method takes two
arguments of integer type the second
multiply method takes three arguments of
integer type and the third multiply
method takes two arguments of double
type so by using method overloading you
can vary the number of arguments and
also the type of arguments so the basic
idea is that you declare you define the
method using the same name but you do a
variation in the arguments or the return
types and that's how you technically
implement method overloading in this
case in this particular case the
multiply is the method being overloaded
and in the first case it is accepting
two integer arguments and returning the
result of multiplication of those
arguments in the second case the same
method name multiply here the same
visibility public and the same return
type but this time three different types
of integer values can be accepted and
this method multiply method is going to
return the multiplication of three
integer numbers in the third case at
line 15 i again use the same multiply
name the method name but this time the
return type becomes double and this
method accepts two double arguments and
returns the result of the multiplication
of these double values so the method
name is same but the arguments vary and
also the return type may also vary
that's the basic premise of how you
implement method overloading so whenever
you want to implement it keep the method
name same vary the
arguments and the return types and after
that i'm just created a public static
void main method here i have initialized
the class here this particular class
itself method overloading demo and then
i am calling the multiply method on the
object and based on the number of
arguments i supply the corresponding
method will get invoked that is
something with java will take care
automatically that whatever type and the
number of arguments you supply in the
call in the invocation based on the
number and the type of the arguments
java will try to find a matching method
in the overloaded methods if it is able
to find a method it's going to get
invoked if it is not able to find the
method you will get an error in fact you
will get a compile error itself while
you invoke a method which for which the
definition is not available for example
if i try to just copy this
and make an invalid invalid method
invocation let's provide four arguments
and if i do that here itself i will get
the error because java is not able to
find a multiply method
in this particular class which is
accepting four integer arguments so you
will get the compilation error itself
before you can even run the program but
the basic idea is that you use
overloading with multiple different
types and the number of variables so i'm
calling multiply three times let's run
this particular program and observe the
output
so let me just bring this output down
yep so first i call demo.multiply and
pass two integer values 10 and 20.
when this happens this particular method
gets invoked and it is it returns a
result of 10 into 20 which is 200. in
the second invocation i'm calling again
the multiply method but this time with
three arguments three integer arguments
specifically and this call is going to
match this particular method signature
and it is going to execute whatever is
written inside this particular method
which is the multiplication of the three
arguments being supplied so 10 into 20
into 30 which is 6 000 the third case
let's go back here at line 25 the third
case of invocation of the multiply
method is accepting two decimal based
arguments 10.5 and 20.5 so java is going
to look at the class and trying to find
a method which can accept decibel values
and there it is this is the method
signature which is going to match the
invocation java is going to do this
matching automatically for you and here
whatever logic you have written inside
this particular method we will get
executed so 10.5 into 20.5 returns 215
and that's the output you get so this is
how you can use method overloading in
java this is a rather fairly simple
example but you can make it as complex
as you want but a word of caution do not
use it too extensively in fact lot of
expert programmers do not recommend
using method overloading because it
becomes very confusing use it only when
you do not have any other way out use it
only where this is the only way to write
correct form of methods with the right
readability otherwise generally there
would be other ways to avoid method
overloading by writing concrete purpose
friendly method names themself maybe you
don't need to use the multiply name
again again we can call it as multiply
two numbers multiply three numbers
multiply doubles so that the method name
itself is more explicit and
understandable rather than juggling
around different signatures of the same
method especially it becomes more
confusing if you are creating an
interface which is to be consumed by a
third-party developers or third-party
application so try to use it with
caution that's what i'm trying to stress
here let's get started with method
overriding in java so in the previous
session we discussed about method
overloading concept now in this session
we'll focus on another interesting
concept by which you can have the same
signature of the method again and again
be used in your code but in a different
way and this concept is called method
overriding method overriding basically
is used together with the concept of
inheritance you won't you will not be
able to use the concept of method
overriding without using the concept of
inheritance remember when we talked
about inheritance i spoke about the
subclass and the parent class concept
sometimes we also call the parent class
as superclass so the basic idea is that
if a super class defines a method
remember i'm using the word define here
if the super class uses the
defines a particular method and then the
subclass again tries to define the
method with the exact same signature
this phenomena is called method
overriding now when you do method method
overriding there are some rules to
follow and i'm showing you a tabular
structure here a table basically which
will show you what is possible and what
is not possible when it comes to method
overriding so let's try to understand
this table so if you try to define a
method with the same signature as a
superclass method the rules follow as
per this table let's go with the first
one if you have an instance method
defined in the super class instance
method is the normal method which you
define in your in your classes so if you
have defined an instance method in your
super class and if you define a method
in the subclass with the exact same
signature then that concept is called
method overriding and it will be a
successful override override also let me
also explain what override means here
override means that once you try to
initialize the sub class object you will
be able to invoke its own overridden
method definition if you call that
particular method the sub classes own
instance method is going to get invoked
rather than the super classes instance
method we'll look at that when we look
at the example as well but that's the
normal scenario when where your
superclass defines an instance method
and subclass also defines the an
instance method with the exact same
method signature that concept is called
method overriding what if your super
class defines a static method static
method is is basically a method which
belongs to the class but not to the
object instance method is called
instance method a normal method is
called instance method because it
belongs to the object you can call the
method on the object but static methods
are called by class so you say class
name dot static method name but when you
when you call instance methods you just
call object name dot instance method
name so that is the basic difference the
static methods belong to the class once
you have defined a static method the
same static method will be available to
all the objects of the class but
instance method are unique to each
object so that was a short tour of what
static methods mean so if you define a
static method in the super class and
then if you try to define an instance
method with the same signature in the
subclass you will get a compilation
error it will not be allowed it's not
allowed in java to override a static
method from super class that's what it
says next one if your super class has a
normal instance method and then the
subclass tries to use the same signature
but creates a static method out of it
then again you will get a compilation
error so that the overriding of an
instance method to a static method is
not allowed and the last concept is
again a very interesting concept and a
very popular interview question about
method hiding so if the super class
defines a static method and the subclass
also defines the static method with the
exact same signature then the super
classes static method gets hidden it
basically hides the super class method
so that's the basic idea behind over
method overriding so if you see
technically it's a form of polymorphism
because the same method is having
multiple definitions but when we looked
at the previous example the multiple
definitions were in the same class here
the multiple definitions are in
different classes and those classes are
having a parent-child relationship that
was about the theory of it let's go to
an example of it to understand it better
and i've used again the same construct
of bicycle and mountain bike which we
have been using in this in this series
just to maintain continuity so i have a
parent class called bicycle here which
has two
properties gear and speed it has a
constructor nothing unusual there and
then it has defined three methods set
gear apply break and speed up set gear
is just setting the new value as the
gear value apply break is going to
decrement the speed by the value you
supply and speed up is going to
increment the speed by the value you
supply simple this is exactly what we
have seen before now mountain bike tries
to extend bicycle so mountain bike
becomes a child class it defines a
variable called seat height defines a
constructor called super here nothing
unusual so far also defines a setter for
height
center for the seat height not exactly
following the setter construct but this
is just to set the height but here
things just get interesting let me just
bring this down a bit yeah so here it is
overriding all the three methods of the
base class and by overriding it is
providing its own implementation of the
same methods let's compare them here
when it overrides the gear and whatever
value you supply it adds 2 to the plus 2
to that value and then sets that value
as the gear value but in case of base
class it was just setting the new value
as the gear value so for instance for
instance if you supplied one here the
gear value becomes one but here if you
supplied one the gear value becomes
three similarly when you apply break on
the mountain bike class whatever value
you supply will be subtracted from the
current speed and 10 would be subtracted
even more so if the speed is let's say
50 and your decrement you supply the
decrement value as 10 so it will be 50
minus 10 minus 10 equal to 30 but in
case of bicycle if the speed was 50 and
you supply 10 then it would be just 50
minus 10 40. so there is
and there is extra 10 being subtracted
from the speed when you apply break in
case of a mountain bike similarly for
speed up its increment of 10 in addition
to what's what value you supply so again
if the speed was 10 and you supplied 10
here in the argument so 10 plus 10 plus
10 30 will become the new speed in case
of mountain bike but in case of bicycle
if you supply 10 and if the current
speed was also 10 then it becomes 10
plus 10 only 20. so that's the
difference so the basic idea i hope you
get the basic idea here is that you
override the methods and your own class
provide its own implementation of those
methods that's the basic premise of
method overriding all good so far and
you do not have a an
obligation to override all of the
methods because here we have the
concrete implementation of the methods
so here in case of mountain bike you can
skip overriding one of the methods if
you like to this is also fine there will
be no compilation error because speed up
has a concrete implementation in the
bicycle class as well so it's up to you
how much you want to override
so let's move to the main class now
so in the main class we have created the
public static void main method here and
let's look at what is happening inside
the class first we initialize the
bicycle class so bicycle class reference
and bicycle class object nothing unusual
here we supply the gear value and the
speed value then we print the gear and
the speed value we apply brake on the
bicycle and then we observe the new
speed of the bicycle after applying the
brakes let me comment out the rest of
the code and let's observe the output
for only this part of the code which we
just walked through for this section so
if i run this as a java application and
if i show you what i'm getting what i'm
getting here so bicycle gear is one
which is what you supplied in the
constructor bicycle speed is 10 which is
again what you supplied in the
constructor then you applied brake and
when you apply brake this logic gets
executed and you supplied one here so
current speed was 10 so 10 minus 1
becomes 9 and the new speed becomes 9
which is what you are printing here so
far so good let's move on to the next
section let me comment out the previous
section now and let me uncomment this
section so here i have a bicycle
reference but the object is of mountain
bike remember this concept this is this
is called dynamic object binding concept
or dynamic binding concept again this
might be asked in your interviews so
here i'm initializing the mountain bike
with the reference of bicycle remember
whatever is written on the right hand
side will govern the variables and the
methods usage we'll we'll we'll we'll
see how that works out what i just said
so i am supplying three values here 50
50 and 3 in the mountain bike
if i go here in the mountain bike
constructor so the start height start
speed and gear are the three values
which is supplied as 50 50 and 3 then i
am accessing the gear and the speed now
remember gear and speed are declared in
the bicycle class but they are
accessible in the child class due to the
inheritance phenomena which we have
already covered so if i print only this
part i should get the expected values
mountain bike gear is three which are
which is what i have supplied here and
mountain bike speed is 50 which is which
is what i have supplied here
then i apply the brakes now let's move
on to this section i apply the brake
supply the value as one and then i want
to see what would be the new speed after
applying the brakes so let's see what
happens when we run this particular code
so if i run this code after applying the
brakes the speed becomes 39 before
applying the brakes the speed was 50. so
what happened here is 50 minus 1
basically this this logic is getting
executed here 50 minus
1 minus 10 which becomes 39 that's why
you get the value as 39 as the new speed
similarly if you want to call another
method as speed up speed up method was
also defined here where i'm saying speed
plus the argument supplied plus 10. so
the current speed is 39 right now then
i'm speeding it up by 10 so by this
logic 39 plus 10 plus 10 which will
become 59 and then i'm printing the new
speed after speeding up so let's see
what happens so if i go to run as java
application and if i observe all the
outputs the speed was 50 initially after
applying the brakes the speed became 39
and after speeding up the speed became
59 so this was a quick demo to show you
the power of method overriding and how
you can override the behavior which is
defined in the base class let's get
started with exception handling in java
using try and catch blocks so in the
previous session we had a look at the
scenarios where an exception can occur
how do we see that there's a runtime
exception or there's a checked exception
or there's an unchecked exception or
there is a custom exception
now
we did not talk about how to handle
those exceptions and now we are going to
focus on the handling part
so whenever you have to handle those
exceptions
the way java provides for that is using
the try catch block
so try catch block is basically a bunch
of syntax which you have to follow to
handle different types of exceptions in
your programming code
and the syntax of the try catch block is
pretty straightforward
you
write try and you put curly braces
and then you write whatever code
which might
throw an exception you don't know that
but it's always safer to enclose your
code in a try catch block so that you
know that if an exception occurs in the
try block
then you can handle it in the catch
block
so it's a it's always considered a
better practice to enclose your
application code in a try catch block so
that you can handle the exceptions
so you put this try block
and write write all the suspicious or
non suspicious code which may or may not
throw an exception inside the try block
once you have done the dry block part
then comes the catch block part
so let me go to the catch block
so this is how the syntax look like once
you have written the dry block then you
write catch
and you put braces
and you write the exception type
which this block of code might throw
or the exception type which you are
interested in catching
you might not be interested in catching
all the different exceptions but only a
few ones based on your business
requirements
so whatever exception type you want to
catch
you are going to catch it like this
and if an exception occurs in the try
code
let's say you have specified an
arithmetic exception here and if
any line of code in the try block throws
an arithmetic exception
then this catch block is going to catch
that exception and then inside these
curly braces you can decide what to do
with that exception
whether you want to lock that exception
or whether you want to re-throw that
exception whether you want to
embed some error code or get an error
code out of it or convert that exception
into a business or custom exception of
your own choice so it's up to you what
you want to do with that but catch block
will be able to catch that arithmetic
exception
similarly you can specify as many
exception types to be caught as you want
and keep adding more and more catch
blocks
remember that these catch blocks work in
a in a sequential fashion
so if an exception occurs here it will
first go to this particular block to
match the exception type
if it didn't match then only it will
move to the second type
if it did match the first type it is not
going to execute the second type so that
is how the try catch block work
you can see an example here that if the
code here is throwing an index out of
bond exception then it is going to be
caught here
and we are just printing the index out
of one exceptions message
if it is throwing an io exception then i
can do this so you can keep adding
different checked and unchecked
exceptions in the catch block
you can also catch more than one type of
exception with one exception handler so
rather than writing these multiple catch
blocks individually you can combine
these exceptions together if your
logic of processing
both of these exceptions is the same
remember if the logic of processing
these two exceptions is the same
logic means whatever you write inside
these curly braces
so if that code is going to be the same
for both of these exceptions then why
bother writing two catch blocks
just write one catch block like this
use the pipe operator to separate
different types of exceptions and write
the common code which is going to be
applied if your try block is going to
through an i o exception or an sql
exception
so that depends upon you
that's the second piece
the third piece of the try block is the
final block so we talked about the try
block we talked about the catch block
now there's a finally block as well
remember this is finally and not final
the finally block is used
together with a try catch block
when you want to perform some cleanup
operations
imagine you are opening up a file
handler
in the try block you are doing something
with it and then you want to just close
the file handler irrespective of the
fact if there was an exception in the
try block or not because even if there
was an exception the file handler
resource is going to remain open and is
going to consume memory in your
application you might you don't want to
do that similarly if you opened a
database connection inside your try
block
irrespective of the fact of what happens
in the try block you always would like
to close the database connection and you
can write that closing code in the
finally block that's the purpose of the
finally block that you can write the
code
inside the finally block which is
supposed to be always executed
irrespective of the fact whether an
exception occurs or doesn't occur
so now we have built a good
understanding of what is the try catch
what is what is the try block catch
block and the final block now if you
just put it all together
this is how it is going to look like
that you write the try block you do
something inside the try block
then you write the catch blocks
after that you write the final block
you can write the finely block without
the catch block as well remember that if
you do not have any exception to catch
but you have some resources to close or
free up after executing the try block
you can skip the catch block and just
right try finally that is also possible
with that understanding let's switch to
the ide and let's look at some example
so i have a writer helper class
which is having a method called write
list i have a try block here
and this try block is basically
initializing an error list
adding an item to the error list
and then i'm accessing list dot get one
remember when i added this particular
value let me make it tend to make it
more understandable
when i added 10 to this particular list
this goes to the index 0 position
and here i'm trying to access index 1
position
which does not have anything
so in such case it might throw an error
because there's nothing at least not get
one so this is my method
where i put the try block code and then
because
i don't want to end up in a position
where i get an index out of bond
exception index out of bonds exception
comes if you are trying to access an
index
which is illegal which is does not
having any value so i'm putting a catch
block and catching the index out of
bound exception
and just printing the message of the
exception
and then for just for simplicity i'm
showing a final block as well though i
do not have any resource to close here
but this is just to show you how this
looks like in the code
this is just to show you that i'm
putting i'm printing assist out here
this is what my method is and if i go to
the main class the try catch demo class
i'm creating an object of the
writerhelper class and calling the
writelist method which we just walked
through
let's run this program and see what
happens
okay so first i get this statement
saying entering try statement so if i go
here
i call this method
the execution goes inside the try block
and i get the cis out which says
entering try statement
then i try to access the second
element in the list because the position
is 1 this is going to index 0 and i'm
trying to access index 1. there is
nothing at index 1 so i get an error
saying index out of bounds exception
index one
out of bounds for length one
because the total length of the list
currently is one because there's just
one element and that one element is
sitting at zero and not one
so i get the exception
which is the index outer bound exception
but the index outer bound exception is
caught by my catch block and the system
dot error dot println is something which
gets executed
and i get this particular
line this particular line
from
this
line number 17
and then irrespective of the fact
whether an exception occurred or not my
final block always gets executed
let's fix this and see if the final
block gets executed even if there is no
exception so now i'm accessing get 0 and
let's see what happens
yep i access the element 10 no exception
but the final block still gets executed
so this is to assert our understanding
that the final block will always be
executed irrespective of the fact
whether there was an exception or there
wasn't
now you can also nest different try
blocks if you want to
let's look at an example where i have
multiple try blocks so you can initial
you can write a try within a try within
a try if you want and you can go as deep
as you want but remember the more
indentations the more hierarchy you
create
the program is going to get more and
more complex so always remember
to have that kind of trade-off
so i write multiple try blocks i
initialize an array i print
added 10 obviously array 10 does not
exist because this array has just four
elements so this is bound to throw an
index out of bound exception and i'm
catching that exception immediately in
the catch block this is the exception
printing assist out and just re-throwing
the exception you can also read through
the exception by just using the throw
keyword remember this throw is different
from the throws keyword which comes in
the method signature this is just to
throw any exception from your code
so this is array index outer bond
exception for this try block
then i have another array index outer
bound exception for this try block
which starts from here block two and
then i have another catch block for the
block one try block
so you can see it is already getting a
bit complicated where i have multiple
hierarchies but you can do that
so this is what is happening in this
particular program now let's try to run
this and see what happens and try to
decipher the output
okay so at first i get this particular
line which says
array index out of bounds exception in
block 3.
what happens here is that this line gets
executed
it throws an array index out of bounds
exception
at line 13 that array index out of
bounds exception is caught which was
generated from this line
and then we go inside the catch block we
execute this is out this is what you see
here the same sis out and then we
re-throw the exception
if we read through the exception
the exception goes to the
enclosing try block the enclosing try
block is this one
there was an exception re-thrown from
this try block and now it has gone to
this try block
and now
this try block block 2 will try to see
if it can catch this
array index out of bound exception
yes we can catch it so it can so so the
block 2 again has a catch block which
catches the array index out of bound and
it prints assists out here which says
exception in block 2
which we see here
and it again rethrows the exception and
if it rethrows the exception so now the
block two
now the block two is re-throwing the
exception so this whole code
is now re-throwing the exception
if this block two is re-throwing the
exception it goes to block one just
going one hierarchy up
and then it sees if it can handle the
exception in the catch block
of this block one so yes the block one
try block also had a catch exception
which said array index out of bound e4
and here it just had a cis out
so if i just bring back the output
yes we do get this a particular
exception printed here which says array
index out of bounds exception in block
one this is what you see here
and this is where the exception just
stops going propagated because i'm not
re-throwing the exception from this
particular catch block so that's where
the exception ends
the reason you see a hyperlink here is
because the text
the text which i have printed here
exactly matches with the name of the
exception so java is pretty smart in
that case if you use the exact same name
exception it will link it to the
matching class name in java which is
pretty cool
i also have a redundant cache block here
which does not have a try block this is
just to show you that you can write a
catch block without a try block but it
doesn't make sense it is of no use so i
can just remove this particular catch
block and the program still will compile
fine
so this was a quick demo to show you how
you can use try catch and finally blocks
and when would you use the final block
and if you want you can use a nested
hierarchy of try blocks and you can
rethrow
the exception from within the catch
block only to be caught in the outside
or the outer or the enclosing block
let's get started with hash set in java
if you remember i covered in the
collections framework session that has
set is part of the set interface
hierarchy and sets have a property that
they keep the collections element unique
if you try to add duplicate elements to
the a set it will not accept that and it
will still maintain the uniqueness
property of the collection hash set
provides some additional features to the
set which is that in this case the
elements would be accessed in a random
fashion they will not be accessed in a
fixed sequence rather they will be
accessed in a random fashion hence the
name hash set so if you read about this
particular class in the documentation it
will basically cover all the things
which i just described it also accepts
null elements if you want to insert null
but why would you try to insert null
that's the first question
which you should ask it again provides
similar kind of utility methods to the
list interface collection hierarchy we
covered like some utility methods to add
the elements to remove the elements to
check the size of the collection and to
check if an element exists in the
collection or not etc etc and we will
cover some of these methods in the demo
this is again not synchronized so this
is not a thread safe collection which
you should know so let's look at a
demonstration of hash set and how do we
actually create a hash set how do we
operate upon a hash set using different
utility methods
so as you can see i have created a class
here which is called hash set demo there
is a public static void main method and
then at line number 10 you will see that
i have created the hash set and again it
starts with a concrete class here which
says hash set and you can obviously
write it as set as well which will also
work fine so we write the set type as
string so this particular set is going
to hold only and only string objects and
nothing else and this set is basically a
type of hash set again this is not
mandatory so you can remove that it will
still not complain and the program will
run fine if you want to specify a size
please do that if you do not want to
specify the size nothing goes wrong and
it will be initialized with the default
memory footprint but remember doing this
wastes a bit of memory so if you're
running this program on a machine which
is really tight on memory always put
some kind of initialization size based
on your knowledge of how many elements
are going to be stored in this
collection so after that at line number
12 we start adding elements to this
collection and for adding the elements
the method which is provided by the hash
set class is add so you use the add
method to add new elements so at line
number 12 line number 13 14 and 15 i use
the method again and again to add some
elements
if you observe the line number 14 and
the line number 15 these two lines are
adding the same element so i'm trying to
add c
twice to this particular hash set and we
will observe the output to see what
happens if we try to add duplicate
elements in the hash set because if you
remember the sets are supposed to be
unique they should not be storing
duplicate elements that's the property
of sets so that's what i demonstrate by
by adding duplicate elements to see how
it behaves and let's do that let me
comment the rest of the code for a while
and let's run just this part of the code
where i add c twice and i print the hash
set and let's see what happens
so i go to run as and i click on java
application and i only see three
elements even though i added four i only
see three and c has been added only once
not twice
now you might be wondering whether the c
is
the c added at line 14 or the c added at
line 15. so
to understand that we need to understand
how hash sets add method works
so this add method is basically
returning a boolean value if the element
is added successfully this ad is going
to return true and if the element could
not be added successfully this add
method is going to return false so let's
do that let's store the result of these
add methods let's call this r1 and let's
call this one as r2
okay and now we will try to print r1 and
r2 and see what happens
so if we write system dot out dot
println and i say r1 and then i just
copy this
after line 16
and write r2 and now we will observe the
output of these to see which
when
we did the add at 14 and when we did the
added 16 which actually resulted in c
getting added did c get overwritten or
did c did not add twice what happens
so we see that uh when we do the add at
line 14 we get true so it means that
this ad was successful and c was added
here and when i did the add again at
line 16 this returned a false it means
the hash set rejected this add operation
so this c was not added so the actual c
was never overwritten the original c was
maintained and when you try to add a
duplicate value with the same value a
duplicate element with the same value
hashtag is going to reject that
so that actually proves that the set
will maintain the uh the uniqueness
property and it will reject all the
duplicates subsequently that was about
the ad
property now let's understand another
interesting property of the contains
method contains method of the set class
is used to find if an element exists in
the set or not so you can just use the
hash set variable name dot contains and
just type the actual element and this is
going to return true or false based on
whether this element is present in the
hash set or not present in the hash set
if it is present then this contains
method is going to return true otherwise
it is going to return false
so let's run this method and observe the
output at line 21.
so it says list we are writing this
particular string which says does list
contain c or not and it returns true
because yes my hash set does contain c
now coming to line 23 i use another
method of the hash set which is the
remove operation which you can use to
remove an element from the set and then
i'm again doing assist out and i'm
asking
the to print the set this should be set
and not list
so then i'm checking if uh what happens
to my hash set if i call the remove
method and i'm just printing the
modified hash set at line 24 so let's
see what happens with the effect of
remove operation okay so after removing
a this is what remains in my hash set
and a has been successfully dropped if i
call the remove method and then i try to
just iterate over the hash set to show
you how does this iteration work it
again works on exactly the same way it
has been working for the list
implementations that on the rhs of this
column you write the collection name so
hash set and on the lhs of this colon
you write the representation of the
element so this hash set is going to
contain string and this is just a
placeholder it can be anything this is
just a temporary variable to store the
current value at the current step of the
hash set iteration and i'm printing all
the items one by one
so if i run this
i'm able to print b and c because that's
all which is remaining in this hash set
so this was a very quick demo to show
you the functionalities of the hash set
how does hash set maintains uniqueness
how do you remove elements how do you
add elements how do you check for an
element's existence using contains
there's also a method to get the element
of the hash set if you want to so these
are all the different properties and
methods available in the hash set and do
check check out the api documentation of
the hash set to learn about more methods
so that's all i wanted to cover in this
particular session where we focused only
on hash set and in the next session we
are we'll be discussing about presets
and we will also see an example of how
do we implement presets in java let's
get started with three sets in java so
in the previous session we talked about
about hash set which is one of the
implementation of the set hierarchy and
today we will be focusing on preset and
if you remember when we talked about
this collection framework i discussed
briefly about preset that the main
reason you will use tree set is
basically when you want to maintain
natural ordering of the elements if
you're adding your custom elements then
you need to tell java how to compare and
sort and order the elements but that's
for another day when we'll cover about
the detailed comparable and comparator
interfaces for now what you can
understand that whenever you have to
maintain the natural order of the
elements automatically then you should
use preset along with that the set
property still holds true that this tree
set cannot have duplicate elements
we should also know that tree set is not
synchronized so it is not a thread safe
collection so be remember be aware that
whenever you are trying to use preset in
a multi-threaded environment you need to
write more wiring code around it so that
preset works as expected okay that was
about the brief theory about the reset
you can read about
about it in detail in this tree set
documentation class and with that let's
switch to a demonstration of the tree
set class
so i have prepared a class here which is
called reset demo as you can see it has
a public static void main method and at
line number eight i'm initializing that
reset again it's again the standard
representation of initializing a
collection which we have been using
throughout the different examples of the
collections so preset of string so this
particular preset is going to hold only
and only string elements if you try to
add another element it is going to
through a compilation error and the on
the rhs i'm just saying new reset and
again this is not mandatory so i can
remove that and it will still work you
can specify the size whenever you know
about the scope of the collection you
should always specify the size for this
demonstration it's a lightweight program
so it's fine after that from line number
10 till line number 13 i'm again going
to add some elements and again if you
see i'm adding elements in random order
i'm adding b and then i'm adding adding
a then i am adding c twice just to show
you the uniqueness property of the tree
set does it still hold true or not we
will be able to figure that out from
this particular example and we will also
see
if i'm adding b before a will it be
printed in a fashion called bac or will
it be printed in a fashion called abc we
should also know that so let's try to
run this program and understand the
output
so if we look at the output we see a
before b
but here when we added the elements we
saw b before a we added b first and then
we added a and then we added c twice and
as per the uniqueness property of this
set the second
addition statement at line number 13
returned false and set rejected this
edition because it could see that c was
already present in this particular
collection so c is added only once but
what's interesting is that b is added
first but b is added b is printed after
a so the natural order of the elements
in this collection is automatically
maintained by tree set so what under the
hood reset does here that it looks at
the type which is a predefined type in
java string is a predefined class in
java so it will use its own sorting
algorithm to sort the strings based on
their natural order of sequence and in
the natural order of sequence a will
always come before b and b will always
come before c so it will automatically
apply that sorting and will present the
result to you if you are using a custom
class here let's say your own student
class or your own customer class or your
own account class in that case that
account class or student class or
customer class needs to tell java how to
sort elements and for that you need to
write comparable and comparator
implementations which we will cover in
detail in the future sessions but for
now you you must understand that
whatever the type of class you are
specifying here should
tell java how to sort the elements
either java should know it automatically
if it's a predefined class like string
or integer or float or double then java
would automatically know by default how
to sort the elements but if you are
creating a custom class of yours in the
tree set and specifying that as the
preset type then you should also tell
java how to sort the customers whether
you want to sort them based on your
first name whether you want to sort them
based on their age their salary java
doesn't know that so you need you need
to tell java about that if you're trying
to use a custom class as the type entry
set in this particular example i'm using
string here and it will apply the
natural ordering
let's put c here in the very beginning
to see what happens
and i can comment this as we have
already maintained and verified that c
is only printed once and added once so
i'm adding c b a and let's run this
program
i still get abc because again the
natural order is implemented contrary to
this when we talked about hash set
remember i told that hash set is a
random access
element collection list so if you run
the hash set if you try to print the
hash set again and again and again you
might see a different order sometimes if
i use a hash set here sometimes it will
print abc sometimes it will print bac
sometimes it might print cab any kind of
sequence any kind of random sequence it
will pick automatically that's the
property of hash set but in case of tree
set no matter how many times you run it
you will always get the same order based
on the sorting implementation available
in the class type so that's all i wanted
to cover about preset please read about
read about its java documentation in the
api docs to understand what all other
methods and utilities tree set provides
but it's pretty much similar to what we
saw in the hash set example like remove
or get etc etc and contains etc so all
this all similar methods are available
in the tree set class as well and that's
all we'll focus on on this particular
session and in the next session we're
going to talk about an interesting
framework called maps let's get started
with maps in java
so first of all before we understand
this particular diagram and the classes
in this map framework let's understand
why do we need map
so
there would be instances when you would
write a java program or any kind of
program there would be always be
instances where you would need to store
a key value kind of arrangement a very
simple example can be that you want to
maintain a company database and you want
to just bring the whole mapping of the
employee id to the employee name into
the java program
how do you do that you need a key value
sort of arrangement where you can store
the employee id as the keys
and each of the employee id key
would correspond to an employee name
which will be called the value so you
need a key and value
arrangement in the java program to store
that kind of information and use that
kind of information in your program and
that's where map comes into picture
whenever you have to store a key value
arrangement remember you would always
think about maps maps should be the
right collection or the right data
structure to be used if you want to
store any key value arrangement in your
program so that's about map and here you
can see a nice framework representation
of map and this is going to be a
theoretical lecture where we will
understand how this map framework works
what is the property and what are the
different implementation classes and
then in the future sessions we will
again look at some examples of the most
popular map implementation classes which
are used in the java world
so again uh the orange oval are
interfaces the blue boxes or the light
blue boxes are the abstract classes and
the purple boxes are the concrete
classes so map is an interface which
will provide this kind of a blueprint
that every class underneath it would be
working on a key value arrangement when
we talk about this key value arrangement
so we have these keys and we have the
values
so the keys here
are supposed to be unique the values can
contain duplicates
remember this is a very important
concept then in map the keys will be
unique and the values can have duplicate
and because we want to maintain the
uniqueness in the keys part that's why
the keys are technically stored as a set
because we know that set cannot contain
duplicate sets are by designed made to
be storing only unique elements so map
uses the set class to store its keys and
to store the values it generally uses a
list class so you can see map is
basically reusing the classes from the
collections framework sets for storing
the keys and lists for storing the
values that's the basic anatomy and
basic idea of how map is working now you
see some classes here called abstract
map and sorted map and again similar to
the set hierarchy whenever you see the
sorted word and if you look at the
concrete class which is called pre-map
this is going to provide you some sort
of an order sorting order automatically
and then you have the hash map class and
this class is going to be providing a
random access this will not maintain the
insertion order this will not provide
you a natural sorting order this is just
to store elements in random order and
the element here a single element here
is basically consisting of two parts
which is key and value always remember
that you also have hash table here hash
table is basically a synchronized
representation this is a thread safe
hash map and tree map are non thread
safe so multiple threads if you try to
work in a multi-threading program with
these hashmap and premap you are going
to get very unpredictable results but if
you use hash table then it is inherently
thread safe so it will only allow one
thread to be to access the hash table at
a particular time
you will also you will also be thinking
then then it's always better to use hash
table right because
you will never get into those weird
errors and you don't have to migrate
your program uh to a multi-threaded
environment whenever you are trying to
use hash tables yes that is true but
hash tables are slower for the same
reason because only one thread can
can access it at a time and that's why
hash tables are slower and hashmap and
treemap are way way faster because they
allowed multiple access at the same time
so you have to always
be mindful of what kind of collection
type you are using there are some
external ways as well to make these hash
maps and tree maps and hash set and
preset and
array list and link list as synchronized
as well and we will talk about that in a
future session but for now you can
understand that hash map entry map are
non-thread safe and hash table
are thread safe there's another class
which is
which is coming out from the hash map
class which is called linked hash map
and linked hash map as the name shows it
will basically carry two properties it
will carry the property of hash map
where the elements are stored or
displayed or accessed in random order
and at the same time it is also
providing the linked property of the
linked list where the sequence is
maintained so you can see you can
actually get the insertion order if you
use a linked hash map the way in which
you insert the elements would always be
the way in which the elements will be
accessed so you are getting sort of a
ordering property but the order is the
insertion order it's not the natural
sort order it's the insertion order
that's why the name linked hash map
because it brings the linked list part
of the link property inside the hash map
where the elements would be presented to
you in the order they are inserted when
you call the add method so that's what
we covered here we covered about map
interface we covered about hash map
class which is going to store the values
and the access will be random the value
means the element means a key and value
we sometime also call this as an element
you will see that representation
sometimes some some people also call it
as i table element it's all the same
thing but it's a key and value
arrangement pre-map also stores the key
value arrangement but it will provide
you a sorted representation and here the
sorting will happen on the keys
not on the values the sorting will be
happening the natural order of salt
which will be maintained by the tree map
is only applicable to the keys here
similarly link hash map it will insert
the elements but when you try to access
it it will maintain the insertion order
no matter how many times you access it
it will only be presented to you in the
order the elements were inserted and
hash table is very similar to hash map
with the difference that hash table is
thread safe multiple threads cannot
manipulate the hash table at a time it
will only let a single thread access
itself at a time so that's the property
of hash table the most popular classes
are generally these ones hash map tree
map and linked hash map very rarely you
will also see hash table but since we
have some
ways to
get these synchronized so generally you
would not see much of the hash table
implementation let's get started with
hash maps in java and now we are looking
at the api documentation of the hash map
class you can see the k comma v here
these are the types of the key and the
value which the hash map will accept you
can see k is basically the type of keys
and v is basically the type of mapped
values
uh like i explained it's basically keys
are stored in a set fashion and values
are stored in a list collection fashion
this is not by default synchronized so
if you want a thread safe collection
then you would have to do something else
which i will cover in the future
sessions
this is a very brief overview of what
hash map is but let's look at the
example to understand better and then i
will be able to explain it in bit more
detail so now we are looking at an
example which is basically a class which
is called hash map demo i have a main
method here and then at line number 10
i am initializing the map
and as you can see that on the lhs we
see the concrete class hash map and i
can do this
and this will still work provided you
have the import here i had the import
here so it will work fine and i'm saying
that this map is going to contain a key
value arrangement where the keys are the
string type
and the values are of the type integer
and it's ultimately a hash map here i i
don't need to again provide the generics
because i have already provided the
generics here
the name of the map is just simply a map
and again you can specify a size or you
can skip the size based on the memory
requirements and the program
requirements
now coming to the point where you want
to add elements to the map
now since this is a key value
arrangement here the name of the method
through which you are going to add
elements is put so you call map.put and
then you provide the key comma you
provide the value
that's the syntax for adding an element
or we technically call that element an
entry this key value together is called
entry so if you have to add an entry to
the map you have to write it in this way
where key comma value is the convention
so i'm adding three elements or three
entries here which is
a comma 10 b comma 20 and c comma 30 abc
are basically the keys and 10 20 and 30
are the corresponding values of these
keys respectively
after that i'm showcasing another
utility method of this particular class
which you can use to find the size of
the map so you can just call map dot
size and it will print the size of the
map
after that i'm printing the actual map
the whole map and then i'm using some
more methods but again let's comment
this code and let's understand this code
one by one so that there is no confusion
so to start with i'm going to add some
elements some entries and i'm going to
print the size of the map and the map
itself let's run this program
so here
you can see the size of the map is
printed as three because i've added
three entries
and then when i call
map inside the
system.out.println method i get the
whole map printed here and this is how
the map will look like when it is
printed we can see key equal to value
syntax here where a equal to 10
b equal to 20 and c equal to 30 are the
key value representations or the entries
here separated by comma enclosed by the
curly braces
that's how our map looks like so far so
good the next thing which i am going to
showcase to you is the contains method
and since the map has this set which is
the keys basically that's why map
provides a method called contains key
basically you can check if a particular
key is present in the map or not and if
you know the key is present then it's
very easy to get the value from the key
map will provide a method also where you
can supply the key and get the value so
knowing the key is the most important
part and that's why map provides a
method called contains key so you can
call this method specify the key which
you want to check for the presence in
the map it is going to check whether a
is present in this maps key set or not
if the a is available in this keys we
can see a is available then this
condition is going to hold true and then
like i said if you want to fetch the
value then you can call the get method
providing the key you can fetch the
value from the key that's the that's the
core idea which you should remember so i
call map.get specify the key and this is
going to spit out the value which is
being pointed by this particular key in
this case a is pointing to 10. when i
say pointing it's not pointer remember
it's just a reference so map dot get of
a is going to get the actual value which
this key is pointing to which is 10 and
then i am printing this integer a which
is the actual value pointed by this
particular key so let's run this program
and see if this works
so we get these two outputs from the
above and then this is the output which
is coming from the if block so it
checked whether the map is containing a
key with the name a yes it was able to
find that and then we asked the java
program to fetch the value corresponding
to this particular key so we just called
map dot get off a and it fetched 10 and
it printed 10 here that's why you see 10
here okay so that's how you can
basically use the contains key method
and the get method now what if you want
to iterate over all the keys what if you
what if you have to use
the
all the keys and you have to make some
pattern or make some observation about
all the keys in your map you can do that
by iterating over the key set and for
that map provides a method called key
set so you just called map.keyset and
this is going to fetch all the keys
in a set representation and will be
provided to you so here when i call
map.keyset this is basically giving me a
set which is containing all the keys and
then i'm iterating over the keys one by
one you would be familiar with this
syntax by now which is the enhanced for
loop syntax and inside this i'm printing
the key which is the current temporary
variable holding the current key and the
value pointed by that particular key at
that particular step and i'm again using
the same method get which is which i
showed you
here
same method so you provide the key and
you will get the value so i'm going to
get all the keys hydrate over the keys
and then print the key and the value
let's see how this looks like
so till this we were good and here you
will see the output which is coming out
from this particular for loop from this
particular for loop line 25 to line 27
where i'm iterating over the key set
printing the key and value one by one so
this is how to show you if you just have
access to the key set you can still
hydrate over the whole map but what if
you know everything you have access to
the key set you have access to the
values and if you was if you just want
to iterate over it then you can use this
particular
way and instead of map dot key set
you're going to use map dot entry set if
you remember map treats each key value
arrangement as a single entry entry is
the keyword here so map dot entry set is
going to give me all the entries in the
map
and then
each entry is basically of type entry
class
this is the representation of each entry
and we know how this representation
formed entry is the class basically
which is coming out of this map
collection hierarchy and then let me
just save this and then string is the
key and integer is the value held by
each entry inside the map so that's what
we are going to do we are going to pick
up all the entries in the map and going
to iterate over the entries one by one
by writing this enhanced for loop and
entry is the temporary variable which is
going to hold each entry one by one at
each step and then it's very simple you
call entry.getkey you will get the key
and you call dot get value and you will
get the value so it's much much simpler
than this one where you had to do map
dot get to understand it it's very
implicit get key is going to get you the
key and get value is going to get you
the value so you just need to call
map.entry set hydrate over the entry set
and get each entries key and value and
print them or do whatever your program
requires to be done that's how you will
use it so let's run this one as well to
verify if this works okay so this is the
output which is coming from the last
loop this loop basically you can see key
i did not put any space that's why you
see key a key b and key c together let
me put a space here and put a hyphen so
that the output looks better and let me
rerun this yep this is much better so
you can see the key a value 10 tb value
20 and key c value 30. this is coming
from this particular for loop which i
just showed you so this is all i wanted
to cover in this particular session we
went deeper into the hash map
representation and we saw a bunch of
methods contains key key set entry set
get put etc and we showed how we can use
the hash map for different purposes in
the program in the next session we'll go
deeper into the tree map concept and
we'll also look at a demo of tree map
and we'll understand how it works let's
get started with tree maps in java now
if you remember in the last lecture we
talked about hash maps in java and we
also had a look at an example where we
saw how a hash map works and how we can
use a hash map we also had a look at
different utility methods of the hashmap
as well now in today's lecture we are
going to focus on tree maps which is an
another type of map as we discussed when
we were discussing about the map
framework and the main property of a
tree map is that when you enter elements
into a map they will naturally be sorted
or naturally be ordered now when i say
naturally ordered what it means that if
you put the
keys as let's say integer then the tree
map will automatically sort all the map
entries in an integer sorted fashion
where you'll see the natural number
sorting behavior like 1 2 3 and so on
similarly if you
store alphabets or strings then they
then those will be sorted in a natural
sorting alphabetical order starting from
a to z so these are the uh these are the
data types which the java is already
aware of on how to sort them like
integers doubles floats strings etc but
there can be a case where you have your
custom key this particular
key is your own custom class if that is
the behavior or if that is the scenario
then in that case you will have to
provide an implementation to java to
know how to sort those elements because
java doesn't know for example a student
class or an account class java doesn't
know how to sort that so if you have
that kind of scenario then in those
cases you will have to provide your own
sorting implementation and we will cover
about what kind of sorting
implementation you can provide in those
kind of scenarios in the upcoming
lectures for now we will look at have a
look at an example of treemap where you
can see that i have created a class
which is called tree map demo and i have
initialized a tree map with the keys as
integer and the values as string so this
means that each entry of the map will
have key as the integer value and the
value of that particular entry will be
of string type so basically an integer
to string mapping is what each entry of
this tree map is going to store so
nothing different here you would have
already seen this kind of uh this kind
of initialization for any kind of map
and after that at line 11 i use the
standard put method of the map and i i
started storing the values so at line 11
i'm saying store 3 and a so 3 is the key
and string a remember this is not a
character this is a string because i
have specified string here if you
specify a character here and if you try
to store a string this is going to throw
an error and you need to fix that so i
store 3 as the key and a as string as
the value similarly at line 12 i store 2
as the key and
b as the value and at line c i store 1
as the key and c as the value so these
integers are the keys and the string are
the values
and if i just put them and if i just try
to print them what happens
what kind of order can we expect
let's try to analyze that so i right
click on this i go to run as
and i go to run as java application
it will run the program because i have a
static void main method and now you see
that the map is printed in a different
fashion
than the way it was added
we added the map elements in this
sequence that we added 3a first 2b
second and 1c as the third element
but when we started printing them we saw
1c printed first 2b printed second and
3c 3a printed third so what this denotes
that this tree map because the key was
integer here it automatically
sorted these keys into a natural order
sorting and it provided when i tried to
access the map it provided the access in
that sorted sequence only no matter how
many times you run this particular
program it is always going to return the
map in the same format in the same
sequence the sequence of representation
of the elements is not going to change
and you can basically do the similar
behavior for example if i just
change this to string and integer let's
do it like this
and if i again swap the elements here as
well i say a comma 3 and i say b comma 2
and here i can say c comma 1. if i do
this i just switch the keys in values
position now the string is the key and
the integer is the value and let me just
put these two
before a so that
we can demonstrate the behavior of the
tree map properly so i'm inserting b2
first and c one second and a three third
and i just save this file and now let's
run this file and let's see how the
output comes so now you can see that
since the key is now string it has
applied it has automatically applied the
natural sorting ordering of strings
which is starting from a going till z
and that's why you see a entry as the
first entry b entry as a second entry
and the c entry as the third entry again
no matter how many times you run it or
you iterate over it you try to access it
you will always get the sequence in the
same fashion so this is a basic overview
of how tree maps work now you can and i
would strongly recommend you to go and
read about all the other methods which
are available in the tree map which you
can use for example how can you remove
elements how can you uh how can you
iterate the elements of the tree map etc
in fact the iteration is is going to be
exactly the same way as we have seen in
the case of hash maps because iteration
behavior doesn't change but to uh if you
want to see what all different kinds of
methods pre-map support it supports a
lot of different methods we can't cover
all of them in this short tutorial but i
would strongly recommend you to go and
read the javadocs api of the tree map to
get familiar with those methods so that
you know what kind of functionalities
pre-map can provide in this we are going
to talk about the maven here
now we will be talking about that how
exactly we can make use of maven here in
performing various kind of operations
whether it's a build compilation with
this kind of stuff there so let's talk
about it why exactly we use maven here
now me1 is something which uh is a kind
of a build tool which is there for most
of the job-based projects here so this
tool also helps us in building up the
source code by downloading some couple
of dependencies these dependencies are
something which is being configured by
the developers which a developer feels
that the project is dependent on and he
requires those dependencies to be
downloaded so uh this tool is
specifically used to build and manage
any kind of a job-based project whatever
the complexity of the topic or the
project is there so this tool will be
able to handle that particular
requirement or that project so it
simplifies the uh day-to-day work of a
java developer and helps them in their
projects for performing daily to daily
activities
right now uh maven also helps us in
getting the uh specific jar files for
each and every project so if you are
going you can pretty much make a jar
file bar file or er file any kind of a
package mechanism you can follow for
your maven day so to download the
dependencies we don't have to actually
go to the official website of each and
every software you can easily get the
dependencies of each and every third
party binaries on the mvnrepository.com
this is a website which is present on
which if you visit you will be able to
download the dependencies which is
required by your project or by your
specific uh
project over here so it totally depends
on how exactly you want to download and
you want to get together a specific
repository over here so
mvnrepository.com is the one if you
visit you will be able to download and
go through all the jar files dependent
jar files as independences which you
require for your current project
right so now what exactly is a maven all
about so let's see on that part
so
maven is a popular open source build
tool which is uh developed by the apache
group and the primary uh ownership of
this tool is to build publish and deploy
several projects at once movement is
written in java and it can be used to
build projects written in c shaft scala
ruby etc so apart from java these are
the different programming languages or
the tools which is supported by the
maven here for performing the build
activity so the tool is uh used for
build and management of any kind of a
job-based project it simplifies the
day-to-day uh work of a java developer
and helps them to automate most of the
compilation or build perspective tasks
on the projects
right now maven is a kind of a bomb
based project so it also known as an
project object model and it focuses on
of simplification and standardization of
the building process in the process it
take cares of all the followings here
bills dependencies reports
distribution releases mailing list so
all these things are being taken care as
in this particular process here and
ultimately it's an availability inside
the maven that how the overall build
process needs to be automated and
standardized here so all these
particular mechanisms is can be followed
as such over here so that we can have a
good
standards and the simplifications
implemented as such here now what
exactly is a maven repository all about
so maven repository is uh something
which
is a
kind of a directory or it's kind of a
location where we have all the jar files
packaged all together in a single
location so depending on the software
which you want to download the dependent
java files can be downloaded from there
so the metadata refers to the palm files
relevant to each project here this
metadata is what allows maven to
download the dependencies now there are
three type of repositories from where we
can download the dependencies the first
one is the local repository second one
is the remote repository and the third
one is the central repository so these
are the primary three type of
repositories which is available there
for a specific maven over here
so whatever repository you want to
follow you want to access you can pretty
much access it and you can go with that
right
now the local repository will be primary
present onto your pc that's the way that
how it's present there and the
particular remote repository something
which you can store on any remote
machine or remote server and the central
repository is something which you can
have it onto the internet so usually the
central repositories is something in
which we can actually host our different
kind of dependencies and the jar files
over there
so local repository on the machine of
the developer where the project material
is saved so all the particular
dependencies jar file will be available
on your local machine remote machine is
the location where you can actually
store all your particular dependencies
from where you can download these
dependencies whenever you require it so
this and repositories work similar to
the central repository whenever anything
is needed from the remote repository
it's first downloaded if into your local
repository and then it will be utilized
so if you feel that the dependency is
something which is not there in the
local it will be first downloaded from
the remote repository and then it will
be utilized or will be referenced onto
the local machine there
and central repository is refers to the
maven community repository there where
you will be able to see each and every
dependency present on that repository so
maven downloads the repositories from
here in the local repository whenever
they're needed or whenever required all
these dependencies are cached locally
from where it will be referenced in the
next or you know whenever we want to
refer that we will be able to do that
particular reference easily on that part
so this is the way that how the three uh
particular repositories or movement
repositories really helps us for
performing various kind of automations
as such here
right now what are the basic concepts of
maven here so some of the couple of
basic concepts which is present in maven
is like for the first time we have the
project object model so project bomb
reference to the xml file which has all
the information regarding the project
how this particular project should be
built up how the different build process
should be automated there it also has a
description of the project details
regarding the versioning versioning
information is also stored as such in
this xml file in this
particular form reference file as such
over here
the xml file is which is there in the
project home directory so maven is uh
something which search for the palm file
in the current directory if it's able to
find that particular pom file so it will
execute or it will proceed with the
build step otherwise they it will hold
there itself so this spawn file is very
important because it will act as a kind
of a build script and primarily the
maven tool will be able to process each
and everything which is configured as
such in this
specific xml file there and according to
that only it will function or it will
proceed further
right now second thing is the
dependencies and repositories so
dependencies are usually refers to the
java files so the java libraries which
we need in our into our particular
project so while uh working on the
project we may be having the dependency
on couple of dependencies so these
dependencies we have to actually
download or we have to actually refer
and once these are a particular
information or these details are
referred so what will happen that uh we
need to download these specific
dependencies from the particular maven
repositories so if the dependencies are
not present in your local repository
then maven
will try to download it from the central
repository and cache it into your local
repository but first of all it will look
on into the local repository and if it
is not present in local then it will go
to the remote or the central repository
then we have build life cycles and phase
and goals there so build life cycles
consist of the sequence of build phases
and each field phase consists of
sequence of goals here now each goal is
responsible for performing a specific
task when a phase is uh running all the
goals related to that phase and its
plugins are also used to following the
compilation preparing the artifacts
downloading the dependencies all
different things being done by the
plugins here
then we have the build profile so build
profiles refers to a set of
configuration values now generally we
have the generic build process for all
the environments all the particular code
base there but sometimes we do have some
kind of a differences there so that is
where we can go for the profiles because
a specific profile can have its own
configuration and whatever it's required
for the build process we can have
different different configurations
stored inside the maven build script
here
then with different build profiles are
added to the pom files and which enables
the different uh build as such here so
depending on these profiles we can
actually decide that how we need to
proceed with the build process and how
the different kind of build automations
needs to be performed here
then a build profile helps in
customizing the build for the different
environments so that also we can perform
as such while performing or while
working on the different components and
the different management here so a build
profile is something which you can
configure you can utilize and depending
on that build profile we will be
deciding whether to proceed further or
how to decide on that particular factor
so these are something which we need to
take care or we need to work according
to see which we can decide that how the
specific configurations and specific
automation needs to be performed here
now
usually when we go for the uh maven
there so we have to use some couple of
maven plugins now the goal of
using these specific plugins is to
automate some of the basic stuff like
compilation creating the var file
creating the java file so when we are
using the plugins we don't have to
configure the steps or write the steps
that how these uh specific plugin should
be installed or should be referenced
it's ultimately the internal
configurations which we are looking
forward or which we are using while
working on these specific plugins so you
can download some couple of plugins
using which we will be able to decide
that how a specific goals needs to be
achieved here so maven has its own
standard plugins that can be utilized so
if uh you know want to go for a custom
one so you can do that but pretty much
you can go for the default one and uh
you can pretty much have some specific
goals executed with the help of these
build plugins
now next thing is the maven architecture
so uh in maven what happens that uh
let's talk about the basic architecture
of maven here so
the maven executable when it's deployed
so it usually uh reads the palm.xml file
which is the build script here now once
the specific found xml file is being
read out so it will process the
components it will uh you know download
or it will process the dependencies
plugins life cycles phases and goals and
even the build profiles and uh if any
kind of interaction is required so it
will try to connect to the central
repository or remote repository and
according to that it will provide the
information and provide the details as
such so minimum repository is something
which is very important because it's
ultimately trying to connect to the
maven repository and try to achieve the
various kind of automation here so it's
very important because ultimately it's
trying to help us to go for the
complete end-to-end build automation
when we'll go for a specific palm based
build automation
so movement is going to read the
palm.xml file then download the
dependencies defined into the power xml
file and that dependencies are cached
locally from the remote or the central
repository now then uh create and
generate a remote report according to
the requirement and execute the life
cycles phases goals plugins etcetera so
it will process the power xml file then
and whatever the plugins and goals or
the life cycles which is configured
there step by step each of them will be
executed into a sequence here now let's
talk about the overall build life cycle
of the maven here so what happens that
uh the maven build life cycle is
something which is a kind of a
collection of different steps there and
this is something which is followed to
perform a build automation for a
specific project so they are pretty much
three steps which is being done so first
one is the default so it handles the
project deployment there second handles
the project cleaning which is a clean
there and then we have site so it
handles the creation of the project
sites documentation there
so these are the three built-in
particular life cycles which is
available there at the beaver level
which you can utilize to perform a
various kind of particular steps
execution for your project
all right so the build cycle has the
different build phases or stages there
because when we are performing a build a
variety of things needs to be performed
over here so the first one is the
compile then test compile is there so
compilation is there for the source file
and test compile is there for the test
cases test will execute the test cases
package will package the bundle then we
have the integration test to run the
integration test cases then we have the
verify then install goal is there and
the last one is the deploy which is
there to deploy the artifacts to the
artifact tree so all these things are
the different phases and the stages
which is being followed as per a
specific build here so during this
builds these are the different phases
and these stages which we normally
follow for performing the build
automation
now what is the exactly advantage of a
specific uh maven here so that is
something which we need to talk about
that how the
particular automation needs to be done
or how we can actually go for the
configurations where we feel that yes we
want to perform or we want to
take certain benefits out of the
implementation of maven here so for that
what happens that uh we have to see that
the various kind of uh benefits the
first one is that apache uh maven helps
manage all the processes there such as
building documentation releasing and
distribution in project management here
so the tool uh simplifies the process of
project building it increases the
performance of the project and the
building process all together and the
task of downloading jar files and other
dependencies is also done automatically
we don't have to indulge in any kind of
download part as such manually over here
right and even provides easy access to
all the required information so may 1
makes it easy for a specific developer
to build a project in the different
environments so we don't have to worry
about the environment we don't have to
worry about the infrastructure nothing
is required everything is available
there inside this package and you know
depending on the particular you can
write the source code on one machine and
you can pretty much do the build on
another machine and this is the reason
how the build automation really happens
on the first place because the developer
is writing the source code in one
location and the same code is deployed
onto the uh particular or built onto
this jenkins or any kind of build tool
there
right in maven you can easily add new
dependencies so you must write the
particular dependencies in the form file
so if you feel that you want to download
some particular dependencies so all you
have to do is that you have to put that
dependency into the a specific one.xml
file there and depending on that the
execution will be really performed and
executed as a chair
right so let's talk about the demo now
so let's see that how exactly we can go
for this demo and we can perform the
various kind of automations
so this is the virtual machine which we
have here on which the maven is already
installed so we can run like mvn
so maven will be available as in 3.6.3
here now i'm going to run a particular
command called uh mvn archetype generate
here
let me create a directory here
our temp directory
and to perform this activity over there
so mvn
archetype
generate now once we run that so what
will happen that it will uh download
some of the buy entries there because uh
ultimately what we are trying to do is
that we are trying to generate a new
project like a maven project so a couple
of uh particular plugins will be
downloaded by the maven executable so
that it can achieve that particular
execution so we just have to wait for
downloading all these values now here
it's trying to give us a particular
attributes like it's asking the
different attributes over here so what
exactly we want to configure so if you
want to configure you can provide that
details otherwise you can perform or
whatever the setup you want to perform
now here it's asking for the version so
uh which kind of version we want to
follow so i'm going to follow like five
here so i'll press five
then a group id which is there so um
it's basically a kind of a group
mechanism so i can say like com
dot simply learn so that's the value
which i'm providing here artifate id i
can make it like a
sample project or something like that i
can do
so that will be the artifact uh
id which is there so
version i am keeping the same only so
and uh yeah so package same here
so i just want to create so i'll just
provide the value called yes and enter
so with this what will happen that a
sample project will be created here
right so whatever the artifact id you
provided so according to that the
project is created in this directory
so you have to go into this directory
and see that what exactly the files are
created there so you have the power.xml
file now this form.xml file when i open
so you can see here that there are some
attributes like you can have the values
uh related to what version group id you
want to follow so this is a group id
this is the artifact id so this is jar
file by default you can change it
according to your requirement then this
is the version and if you feel that you
want to do the changes to the name that
also you can perform here so by default
the junit dependency is added but if you
want to keep on adding your own custom
dependencies you will be able to do that
now in this case if you run like mvn
clean install so it will be considered
as in particular maven project a
pawn.xml file is already there present
in the local directory so according to
that the execution of the steps will be
performed and according to that you will
be able to get some desired values here
so ultimately in the target directory
you will be able to see that some couple
of jar file or a specific jar file is
generated here so you can see that in
the target directory this jar file or
this artifact is generated here so this
is a way that how we can actually go for
a generic one like a new particular
project and later on you can depending
on your uh understanding you can keep on
adding or you can keep on modifying the
dependencies and that's how you can get
the final result there
so that's it for this demo in which we
have find out that how exactly we can go
for a particular project preparation
with the help of mvn executable let's
get started with jenkins jenkins in my
opinion is one of the most popular
continuous integration servers of recent
times what began as a hobby project by a
developer working for sun microsystems
way back in early or mid 2000s has
gradually and eventually evolved into a
very very powerful and robust automation
servers it has a wider option since it
is released under mit license and is
almost free to use
jenkins has a vast developer community
that supports it by writing all kinds of
plugins plugins is the heart and soul of
jenkins because using plugins one can
connect jenkins to anything and
everything under the sun
with that introduction let's get into
what all will be covered as a part of
this tutorial i will get into some of
the prerequisites required for
installing jenkins post which i will go
ahead and install jenkins on a windows
box there are few first time
configuration that needs to be done and
i will be covering those as well so once
i have jenkins installed and configured
properly i will get into the user
administrative part i create few users
and i will use some plugins for setting
up various kinds of access permissions
for these users i will also put in some
freestyle jobs freestyle job is nothing
but a very very simple job and i will
also show you the powerfulness of
jenkins by scheduling this particular
job to run based upon time schedule i
will also connect jenkins with github
github is our source code where source
code repository where i've got some
repositories put up there so using
jenkins i will connect to github pull up
a repository that is existing on github
onto the jenkins box and run few
commands to build this particular
repository that is pulled from github
sending out emails is a very very
important configurations of jenkins or
any other continuous integration server
for that matter whenever there is any
notifications that has to be sent out as
a part of either a build going bad or
built being good or built being
propagated to some environment and all
these scenarios you would need the
containers integration servers to be
sending out notifications so i will get
into a little bit details of how to
configure jenkins for sending out emails
i will also get into a scenario where i
would have a web application a maven
based java web application which will be
pulled from a github repository and i
will deploy it onto a tomcat server the
tomcat server will be locally running on
my system eventually i will get into one
other very very important topic which is
the master slave configuration it's a
very very important and pretty
interesting topic where distributed
builds is achieved using a master slave
configuration so i will bring up a slave
i will connect the slave with the master
and i will also put in a job and kind of
delegate that particular job to the
slave configuration finally i will let
you know how to use some plugins to
backup your jenkins so jenkins has got a
lot of useful information set up on it
in terms of the build environments in
terms of workspace all this can be very
very easily backed up using a plugin so
this is what i'm going to be covering as
a part of this tutorial jenkins is a web
application that is written in java and
there are various ways in which you can
use and install jenkins i have listed
popular three mechanisms in which
jenkins is usually installed on any
system the topmost one is as a windows
or a linux based services so if at all
you have windows like the way i have and
i'm going to use this mechanism for this
demo so i would download a msi installer
that is specific to jenkins and install
this service so whenever installed as a
service it goes ahead and nicely
installs all that is required for my
jenkins and i have a service that can be
started or stopped based upon my need
any flavor of linux as well one other
way of running jenkins is downloading
this generic warf file and as long as
you have jdk installed you can launch
this war file by the command opening up
a command prompt or shell prompt if it
layer on linux box specifying java
hyphen jar and the name of this war file
it typically brings up your web
application and you know you can
continue with your installation the only
thing being if at all you want to stop
using jenkins you just go ahead and
close this prompt you either do a
control c and then bring down this
prompt and your jenkins server would be
down other older versions of jenkins
were run popularly using this way in
which you already have a java based web
server running up and running so you
kind of drop in this war file into the
root folder or the httpd root folder of
your web server so jenkins would explode
and kind of bring up your application
all user credentials or user
administration is all taken care of by
the apache or the tomcat server or the
web server on which jenkins is running
this was a very older way of running but
still some people use it because if they
don't want to maintain two servers if
they already have a java web server
which it's being nicely maintained and
backed up jenkins can run attached to it
all right so either ways it doesn't
matter however you're going to bring up
your jenkins instance the way we're
going to operate jenkins is all going to
be very very same or similar one with
subtle changes in terms of user
administration if at all you're
launching it through any other web
server which will take care of the user
administration otherwise all the
commands or all the configuration all
the way in which i'm going to run this
demo it is going to be same across any
of these installations all right so the
prerequisites for running jenkins as i
mentioned earlier jenkins is nothing but
a simple web application that is written
in java so all that it needs is java
preferably jdk 1.7 or 1.8 2gb ram is the
recommended ram for running jenkins and
also like any other open source tool
sets when you install jdk ensure that
you set in the environment variable java
home to point to the right directory
this is something very specific to jdk
but for any other open source tools that
you've installed there's always a
preferred environment variable that you
got to set in which is specific to that
particular tool that you're going to use
this is a generic thing that is there
for you know for any other open source
projects because the way open source
projects discover themselves is using
this environment variables so as a
general practice or a good practice
always set these environment variables
accordingly so i already have jdk 1.8
installed on my system but in case you
do not what i would recommend is just
navigate on your browser to the oracle
home page and just type in or search for
install
jdk 1.8
and navigate to the oracle home page
you will have to
accept the license agreement and there
are a bunch of installers that is okay
that you can pick up based upon the
operating system on which you're running
so
i have this windows 64 installer that is
already installed and running on my
system so i will not get into the
details of downloading this or
installing it let me show you once i
install this what i've done with regard
to my path
so
if you get into those environment
variables
all right so i've just set in a java
home variable
if you see this c column program files
java jdk 1.8 this is where my my java is
located see program files c program
files java
okay so this is the home directory of my
jdk so that is what i've been i've set
it up here in my environment variable
so if you see here this is my java home
all right one other thing to do is
ensure that in case you want to run java
or java c from a command prompt ensure
that you also add that path into this
path variable so if you see this
somewhere i will see yes there you go c
colon program files java jdk 1.8 pin so
with these two i'll ensure that my java
installation is nice and you know good
enough so to check that to double check
that or to verify that let me just open
up a simple command prompt
and if i type in java iphone version
all right
and java c
iphone version
so the compiler is on the path java is
on the path and if at all i do this
even the environment variable specific
to my java is
installed correctly so i'm good to go
ahead with my jenkins installation
now that i have my prerequisites
all set for installing jenkins let me
just go ahead and download jenkins
so let me open up a browser and say
download
jenkins
all right lts is nothing but the long
term support these are all stable
versions weeklies i would not recommend
that you try these unless until you have
a real need for that
long term support is good enough and as
i mentioned there are so many flavors of
jenkins that is available for download
you also have a docker container
wherein you know you can launch jenkins
as a container but i'll not get into
details of that in this tutorial
all right so what i want is
yes this is the war file which is a
generic war file that i was talking to
you earlier and this is the windows msi
installer so go ahead and download this
msi installer i already have that
downloaded so let me just open that up
all right so this is my downloaded
jenkins instance
or other installer this is a pretty
maybe a few months old but this is good
enough for me
before you start jenkins installation
just be aware of one fact that there is
a variable called jenkins home this is
where jenkins would store all this
configuration data jobs project
workspace and all that specific to
jenkins so by default if at all you
don't set this to any particular
directory if at all you install an msi
installer all your installation gets
into sql and program files 86 and
jenkins folder if at all you run a war
file depending upon the user id with
which you're running a war file the
jenkins folder there's a dot jenkins
folder that gets created inside the user
home directory so in case you have any
need wherein you want to backup your
jenkins or you want jenkins
installations to get into some specific
directories go ahead and set this
jenkins home variable accordingly before
you even begin your installation for now
i don't need to do any of these things
so i've already downloaded the installer
let me just go ahead with the default
installation
all right so this is my jenkins msi
installer i would just i don't want to
make any changes into the jenkins
configuration c colon program files is
good for me yeah this is where all my
destination folder and all the
configuration specific to it goes i'm
happy with this i don't want to change
this
i would just say go ahead and click
installation
okay so what typically happens once the
jenkins installation gets through is
it'll start installing itself and there
are some small checks that needs to be
done
so and by default jenkins launches on
the port 8080 so let me just open up
localhost 8080.
there's a small checking that will be
done as a part of the installation
process wherein i need to type in the
hash key all right so there's a very
very simple hash key that gets stored
out here so i'll have to just copy this
path
if at all you're running as a war file
you would see that in your logs
all right so this is a simple hash key
that gets created every time when you do
a jenkins station so as a part of the
installation it just asks you to do this
so if that is not great it will
about it but this looks good so it's
going ahead
all right one important part during the
installation so you would need to
install some recommended plugins
what happens is the plugins are all
related to each other so it's like the
typical rpm kind of a problem where you
try to install some plugin and it's got
a dependency which is not installed and
you get into all those issues in order
to get rid of that what jenkins
recommends there's a bunch of plugins
that is already recommended so just go
ahead and blindly click that
install recommended plugin so if you see
there is
a whole lot of plugins which are bare
essential plug-ins that is required for
jenkins in order to run properly so
jenkins as a part of the installation
would get all these plugins and then
install it for you
this is a good combination to kind of
begin with and mind you at this moment
jenkins needs
lots of bandwidth in terms of network so
in case your you know your network is
not so good few of these plugins would
kind of fail
and these plugins are all you know on
available on openly or mirrored sites
and sometimes some of them may be down
so do not worry in case some of these
plugins kind of fail to install you'll
get an option to kind of retry
installing them but just ensure that you
know at least most or 1995 of all these
plugins are installed without any
problems let me pause the video here for
a minute and then get back once all
these plugins are installed
my plugin installation is all good there
was no failures in any of my plugins so
after that i get to create this first
admin user again this is one important
point that you got to remember
keen given any username and password but
ensure that you kind of remember that
because it's very hard to get back your
username and password in case you forget
it all right so i'm going to create a
very very simple username and password
something that i can remember
i will
that's my name and
an email id is kind of optional but it
doesn't allow me to go ahead in case i
don't so i just given an admin and i got
a password i've got i remember my
password this is my full name
all right i say save and finish
all right that kind of completed my
jenkins installation
it was not that tough was it
now that i have my jenkins installed
correctly let me quickly walk you
through some bare minimal configurations
that is required these are kind of a
first time configuration that is
required so and also let me warn you the
ui is little hard for many people to
wrap their head around it specifically
the windows guys
but if at all you're a java guy you know
how painful it is to write ui in java
you will kind of appreciate you know all
the effort that has gone into the ui
bottom line you are a little hard to you
know wrap your head around it but once
you start using it possibly you'll start
liking it
all right so let me get into something
called as managed in cans
this can be viewed like a
main menu for all jenkins configuration
so i'll get into some of those important
ones
something called as configure system
configure system this is where you kind
of put in the configuration for your
complete jenkins instance
few things to kind of look out for this
is a home directory this is a java home
where all the configurations all the
workspace anything and everything
regarding jenkins is stored out here
system message you want to put in some
message on the system you just type in
whatever you want and is possibly show
up somewhere up here on the menu number
of executors very very important
configuration this just lets jenkin know
at any point in time how many jobs or
how many threads can be run you can kind
of visualize it like a thread that can
be run on this particular instance as a
thumb rule if at all you're on a single
core system number of executors two
should be good enough
in case at any point in time there are
multiple jobs that kind of get triggered
at the same time in case the number of
executors are less compared to the
number of jobs that have that woken up
no need to panic because they will all
get queued up and eventually jenkins
will get to running those jobs just bear
in mind that whenever a new job kind of
you know gets triggered the cpu usage
and the memory usage in terms of the
disk right is very high on the jenkins
instance
so that's something that you got to kind
of keep in mind all right but number of
executors 2 for my system is kind of
good label for my jenkins i don't want
any of these things usage how do you
want to use your jenkins this is good
for me because i only have a primary uh
server that is running so i want to use
this node as much as possible quite
pretty each of these options have got
some pair minimal
help kind of a thing that is that is out
here by clicking on these question marks
you will get to know as to what are
these particular configurations
all right so this all look good what i
want to show you here is there's
something regarding the docker
timestamps git plugin svn email
notifications
i don't want that what i want the yes i
want this smtp server configuration
remember i mentioned earlier that i
would want jenkins to be sending out
some emails
and what i've done here is i've just
configured
the smtp details of my personal email id
in case you are in a in organization you
would have some sort of an email ids
that is set up for a jenkins server so
you can specify the smtp server details
of your company so that you know you can
authorize jenkins to kind of send out
emails but in case you want to try it
out like me i have configured my
personal email id which is on my gmail
for sending out notifications so the
smtp server would be
smtp.gmail.com i'm using the smtp
authentication i have provided my email
id and my password i'm using the smtp
port which is 465 and i'm you know reply
to address is the same as mine i can
just send out an email
and see if at all this configuration
works again gmail would not allow you to
allow anybody to send out notifications
on your behalf so you'll have to lower
the security level of your gmail id so
that you can allow a programmatically
somebody to send out email notifications
on your behalf so i've done already that
i'm just trying to see if i can send a
test email with the configuration that
i've set in
yes
all right so the email configuration
looks good
so this is how you configure your uh you
know your gmail account in case you want
to do that if not put in your
organization smtp server details which
are for the valid username and password
and it should all be set
all right so no other configurations
that i'm going to change here all of
these look good
all right so i come back to managing
cans okay one other thing that i want to
kind of go over is the global tool
configuration
imagine this scenario look at it this
way jenkins is a is a continuous
integration server it doesn't know
what kind of a code base it's going to
pull in what kind of a tool says that is
required or what is the code that is
going to pull in and how is it going to
build so you will have to put in all the
tools that is required for building the
appropriate kind of code that you're
going to pull in from you know your
source code repositories so just to give
you an example in case your source code
is a java source code and assuming that
you know because in this demo this is my
laptop and i've put in all the
configurations jdk everything on my
laptop because i'm a developer i'm
working on the laptop but my continuous
integration server would be you know a
separate server
without anything being installed on it
so in case i want jenkins to you know
run a java code i would need to install
jdk on it i need to specify the jdk
location of this out here this way
okay since i already have the jdk
installed and i've already put in the
java home directory or rather the
environment variable correctly i don't
need to do it git if at all i want the
jenkins server to use git git is a you
know command bash or the command prompt
for for running git and connecting to
any other git server so you would need
git to be you know installed on that
particular system and set the path
accordingly
gradle and maven if at all you have some
mavens as well you want to do this any
other tool that you're going to install
on your system
which is your continuous integration
server you will have to come in here and
configure something
in case you don't configure it when
jenkins runs it will not be able to
find these tools for building your task
and it'll crib about it
that's good i don't want to save
anything
manage jenkins let me see what else is
required yes configure global security
all right the security is enabled and if
you see by default it's the security
access control is set to jenkins own
user database so what does this mean you
know jenkins by default it uses
file system where it stores all the user
names which hashes up these user names
and kind of stores them
so as of now it jenkins is configured to
use its own database assuming that you
are running in an organization you would
probably want to have a you know some
sort of an ad or an ldap server using
which you would want to control access
to your jenkins repository rather
jenkins tool
so you would specify your ldap server
details the root dn
password or the manager dn and the
manager password and all these details
in case you want to connect your jenkins
instance with your
ldap or ad or any of the authentication
servers that you have in your
organization
but for now since i don't have any of
these things i'm going to use this own
database that's good enough
all right so i will set up some
authorization methods and stuff like
that once i put in few jobs so for now
let me not get into any of these details
of this just be aware that jenkins can
be connected for authorization to an
ldap server or you can have jenkins
managing its own servers which is
happening as of now so i'm going to save
all this stuff
that's good for me so enough of all
these configurations let me put in a
very very simple job
all right so job new item you know a
little difficult to kind of figure out
but then that's the new item so i'll
just say you know first job this is good
for me i just give a name for my job i
would say it's a freestyle project
that's good enough for me i don't want
to choose any of that so unless until
you choose any of this this particular
button would not become active so choose
the freestyle project and say okay
at a very high level you would see
general source code management build
triggers build environment build and
post build in case you install more and
more plugins you will see a lot more
options but for now this is what you
would see so what am i doing at the
moment i'm just putting up a very very
simple job and the job could be anything
and everything so i don't want to put in
a very complicated job for now for the
demo let me just put in a very very
simple job i'll give a description
this is an optional thing this is my
first
jenkins job
all right i don't want to choose any of
these again there are some helps
available here
i don't want to choose any of this i
don't want to connect it into any source
code for now
i don't want any triggers for now i'll
come back to this in a while build the
environment i don't want any build
environment as a part of this build step
you know i just want to you know run few
things so that i kind of complete this
particular job so since i'm on a windows
box i would say execute windows batch
command
all right so what do you want to do i
will let me just echo something echo
hello
this is my first jenkins job
and possibly i would want the date and
the time stamp
pertaining to the job i mean the date
and time in which this job was run all
right very very simple command that says
you know this is my first job it just
puts out something along with the date
and the time
all right i don't want to do anything
else i want to keep this job as simple
as this so let me
save this job
all right so once i save this job you
know the job names comes up here and
then i need to build this job and you
would see some building stray out here
nothing is there as of now because i've
just put in a job i have not run it yet
all right so let me try to build it now
you see a build number you will see a
date and a timestamp so if i click on
this you will see a console output if i
go here
okay as simple as that
and where is all the job details that is
getting into if you see this
if i navigate to this particular
directory
all right so this is the directory what
i was mentioning earlier regarding
jenkins home so all the job related
stuff that is specific to this
particular jenkins installation is all
here
all the plugins that is installed the
details of each of those plugins can be
found here
all right so the workspace is where all
the jobs that i've created whichever i'm
running
you know there will be individual
folders specific to the jobs that has
been put up here all right so one job
one quick run
that's what it looks like pretty simple
okay let me do one thing let me put up a
second job
i would say second job
i would say freestyle project
all right this is my second job
i just want to demonstrate the
powerfulness of the automation server
and how simple it is to automate a job
that is put up on jenkins
which will be triggered automatically
remember what i said earlier about
jenkins because at the core of jenkins
is a very very powerful automation
server
all right so what i'm going to do i will
just keep everything else the same i'm
going to put in the build script pretty
much similar to
second job
that
gets triggered
automatically
every
minute all right let me do that
percentage date
and i'll put in the time
all right so i just put in another job
called second job and it pretty much
does the same thing as what i was doing
earlier in terms of printing the date
and the time but this time i'm just
going to demonstrate the powerfulness of
the automation server that is there if
you see here
there's a build trigger
so a build can be triggered using
various triggers that is there so we'll
get into this github triggering or hook
or a web hook kind of a triggering later
on but for now what i want to do i want
to ensure that this job that i'm going
to put in would be automatically
triggered on its own let's say every
minute i want this job to be run on its
own
so
build periodically is my setting
if you see here there's a bunch of
help that is available for me so for
those of you who have written cron jobs
on linux boxes you'll find it very very
simple but for others don't panic let me
just put up a very very simple regular
expression for scheduling this job every
minute
all right so that's
one
two
three
four
five
all right come up come up come up all
right so five stars is all that i'm
going to put in and jenkins got a little
worried and is asking me do you really
mean every minute oh yeah i want to do
this every minute let me save this and
how do i check whether it gets triggered
every minute or not i just don't do
anything i'll just wait for a minute
and if at all everything goes well
jenkins would automatically trigger my
second job in a minutes time from now
this time around i'm not going to
trigger anything look there you see
it's automatically got trigger
if i go in here
yep second job that gets triggered
automatically you know it was triggered
at 42
1642 which is 442 my time that looks
good
and if everything goes well every one
minute onwards this jog would be
automatically triggered
now that i have
my jenkins up and running a few jobs
that has been put up here on my jenkins
instance i would need a way of
controlling access to my jenkins server
this is wherein i would use a plugin
called role based access plugin and
create few rules the rules are something
like a global rule and a project rule
project specific growth i can have
different roles and i can have users who
have signed up or the users who might
create kind of assigned to these roles
so that each of these users fall into
some category this is my way of kind of
controlling access to my jenkins
instance and
ensuring that people don't do something
unwarranted all right so first things
first let me go ahead and install a
plugin
for doing that so i get into manage
jenkins and manage plug-in
a little bit of a confusing screen in my
opinion there's updates available
installed in advance as of now we don't
have the role-based plug-in so let me go
to available it'll take some time for it
to get refreshed all right now these are
the available plugins these are the
install plugins
all right so let me come back to
available and i would want to search for
my role based access plugin so i would
just search for role and hit enter
okay role based authorization strategy
enables user authorization using a role
based strategy roles can be defined
globally or for particular jobs or nodes
and stuff like that so exactly this is
the plugin that i want
i would want to install it without a
restart
right looks good so far
yes
go back to the top of the page yes
remember jenkins is running on a java
using a java instance so typically many
things would work the same way unless
and until you want to restart jenkins
once in a while but as a good practice
whenever you do some sort of big
installations or big patches on your
jenkins instance just ensure that you
kind of restart it otherwise there would
be a difference in terms of what is
installed on the system and what is
there on the file system you will need
to flush out few of those settings later
on but for now these are all very small
plugins so this would run without any
problems but otherwise if at all there
are some plugins which would need a
restart you know kindly go ahead and
restart your jenkins instance but for
now i don't need that it looks good i've
installed the plugin so where do i see
my plugin i installed the plugin that is
specific to the
user control or the
access control so let me go into
yes
global security
and
i would see this role-based strategy
showing up now
all right so this comes in because of my
installation of my role based plugin so
this is what i would want to enable
because i already have my own database
setup and for the authorization part in
the sense that who can do what i'm going
to install i mean i've already installed
a role based strategy uh plugin and i'm
going to enable that strategy all right
i would say save
okay
now i've installed the role based access
plugin i would need to just set it up
and check that you know i would go ahead
and create some roles and ensure that i
assign users as per these roles all
right so let me go to
manage jenkins
configure
all right let me see where is this
configure configure global security is
that where i create my rules
nope not here
yes manage and assign roles
okay again you would see these options
only after you install these plugins so
for now i've just enabled the plugin i
have enabled role-based access control
and i would go ahead and create some
rules for this particular jenkins
instance so i would say first
manage rules
so i would need to create some roles
here and the rules are at a very high
level these are global rules and there
are some project rules and there are
some slave rules i'll not get into
details of all of this at a very very
high level which is a global role let me
just create a role a role can be kind of
visualized like a group so i would
create a role called developer typically
the jenkins instance or the ca instance
are kind of owned up or controlled by qa
guys so qa guys would need to provide
some sort of you know limited access to
developers so that's why i'm creating a
role called developer
and i'm adding this role at a global
role level so i would say add this here
and you would see this developer role
that is there and each of these options
if you hover over it you would see some
sort of a
help on what what are these you know
permissions specific to so what i want
is like you know it sounds a little you
know different but i would want to give
very very little permissions for the
developer so from an administration
perspective i would just want him to
have a read
kind of a role credentials again i would
just want to view kind of a rule i don't
want him to create any agents and all
that stuff that looks good for me
for a job i would want him to just
possibly
read i don't want him to build i don't
want him to cancel any jobs i don't want
him to configure any job i don't even
want him to create any job i would just
want him to read few things i would not
give him possibly a role to the
workspace as well i mean i don't want
him to have access to the workspace i
would just want him to
read a job
now check you know i have read only
access to the job run
um no i don't want him to give him any
any particular
access which will allow him to run any
jobs
view configure
yeah possibly create yeah
delete i don't want to read yes
definitely and this is the specific role
so what i'm doing i'm just creating a
global role called developer and i'm
giving him very very limited roles in
the sense that i don't want this
developer to be able to run any agents
nor create jobs or build jobs or cancel
jobs or configure jobs at the max i
would just want him to read a job that
is already put up there okay
so i would save
now i created a rule
i still don't have any users that is
there on the system so let me go ahead
and create some user on the system
that's not here how sick configure
managing cans manage users
okay let me create a new user
i would call this user as yeah developer
one sounds good
some password
some password that i can remember
okay his name is developer1
d at
d.com or something like that
okay so this is the admin with with
which i kind of configured or brought up
the system and developer one is a user
that i have configured so still have not
set any rules for this particular user
yet so i would go to manage and gains
i would say
manage and assign roles i would say
assign roles
okay so if you see what i'm going to do
now is assign a role that is specific to
that particular i will find the
particular user and assign him the
developer role that i have already
configured
the role shows up here i would need to
find my user whoever created and then
assign him to that particular rule so if
you remember the user that i created was
developer1 i would add this particular
user and now this particular user what
kind of a role i want him to have
because this is the global rule that had
created so developer i would assign this
developer one to this particular global
rule
and i would go ahead and save my changes
now let me check the permissions of this
particular user by logging out of my
admin account and logging back as
developer one
if you remember this role was created
with very less privileges
so
there you go i have jenkins but i don't
see a new item i can't trigger a new job
i can't do anything i see these jobs
however i don't think so i'll be able to
start this job i don't have the
permission set for that the maximum i
can do is look at the job see what was
there as a part of the console output
and stuff like that so this is a limited
role that was created and i added this
developer to that particular role which
was a developer role
so that the developers don't get to
configure any of the jobs because the
jenkins instance is owned by a qa person
he doesn't want to give developer any
administrative rights so the rights that
he set out by creating a developer role
and anybody who is tagged any user who
is tagged as a part of this developer
role would get the same kind of
permissions and these permissions can be
you know fine grain it can be a project
specific permissions as well but for now
i just demonstrated the high level
permission that i had set in
let me quickly log out of this user and
get back
as the admin user because i need to
continue with my demo with the developer
role that was created i have very very
less privileges one of the reasons for
jenkins being so popular as i mentioned
earlier is the bunch of plugins that is
provided by users or community users who
don't charge any money for these plugins
but it's got plugins for connecting
anything and everything so if you can
navigate to or if you can find jenkins
plugins
you would see index of over so many
plugins that is there all of these are
wonderful plugins whatever connectors
that you would need if you want to
connect jenkins to an aws instance or
you want to connect jenkins to a docker
instance or any of those containers you
would have a plugin you can go and
search up if i want to connect jenkins
to bitbucket
bitbucket is one of the git servers
there's so many plugins that is
available okay so
bottom line jenkins without plugins is
nothing so plugins is the heart of
jenkins for you to connect or for in
order to connect jenkins with any of the
containers or any of the other tool sets
you would need the plugins if you want
to connect or you want to build a
repository which has got java and maven
you would need to install maven and jdk
on your jenkins instance if at all
you're looking for a net build or a
microsoft build you would need to have
ms build installed on your on your
jenkins instance and the plugins that
will trigger ms build if at all you want
to listen to some server side web hooks
from github you will need github
specific plugins if you want to connect
jenkins to aws you need those plugins if
you want to connect to a docker instance
that is running anywhere in the world as
long as you have the url which is
publicly reachable you just have a
docker plug-in that is installed on your
jenkins instance sonar cube is one of
the popular static code analyzers so you
can connect a jenkins build you can
build a job on jenkins and push it to
sonar cube and get sonar cube to run
analysis on that and get back the
results in jenkins all of these works
very well because of the plugins now
with that let me connect our jenkins
instance to github i already have very
very simple java repository up on my
github instance so let me connect
jenkins to this particular github
instance and pull out a job that is put
up there all right so this is my very
very simple
you know repository that is there called
hello java and this is what is there in
the repo there is a hello hello.java
application that is here or a simple
class file that is there it's got just
one line of system dot out so this is
already present on github.com at this
place and this would be the url for this
repository
if i pick up the https url this is my
steepest url so what i would do is i
would connect my jenkins instance to go
to github provide my credentials and
pull out this repository which is on the
cloudhostedgithub.com
and get it to my jenkins instance and
then build this particular java file i'm
keeping the source code very very simple
it's just a java file how do i build my
java file how do i compile my java file
i just say java c and the name of my
class file which is hello.java and
however run my java file i would say
java and hello
okay so remember i don't need to install
any plugins now because
what it needs is a git plugin so if you
remember when we were doing the
installation there was a bunch of
recommended plugins so git is already
installed on my system so i don't need
to install it again so let me put up a
new job here it says git job let it be a
freestyle project that's good for me i
would say
okay right so the source code management
remember in the earlier examples we did
not use any source code because we were
just putting up some echo kind of uh
jobs we did not need any integration
with any of the source code systems so
now let me connect this so i'm going to
put up a source code and git would show
up because the plugin is already there
svn perforce any of those additional
source code management tools if at all
you would need just install those
plugins and jenkins connects wonderfully
well to all these particular source
control tools okay so i would copy the
https url from here i would say this is
the url that i'm supposed to
go and grab my source code from but all
right that sounds good but what is the
username and password so i'll have to
specify a username
and password all right so i would say
the username this is my username and
this is my https credential for my job
okay so this is my username and this is
my password i just save this i say add
and then i would say you know use this
credentials to go to github and then on
my behalf pull out a repository all
right if at all at this stage if there's
any error in terms of not able to
jenkins not able to find git or the git
dot exe or if my credentials are wrong
somewhere down here you would see a red
message saying that you know something
is not right you can just go ahead and
kind of fix that for now this looks good
for me i'm going to grab this
url what am i going to do
this step would pull the source code
from the github and then what would be
there as a part of my build step
because this repository just has a java
file correct hello.java so in order to
for me to build this i would just say
execute windows batch command and i
would say java c
hello dot
java that is the way i would build my
java code and if i have to run it i
would just say java
hello
pretty simple two steps and this would
run after the repository contents are
fetched from github
so java c java that sounds good i would
say save this
and let me try to run this
okay if you see
there's a lot of you know it executes
kit on your behalf it goes out here it
provides my credentials and says you
know it pulls all my repository and by
default it will pull up the master
branch that is there on my repository
and it kind of builds this whole thing
java c hello java and it runs this
project java hello and there you see
this is the output that is there and if
at all you want to look at the contents
of the repository if you can go here
this is my
workspace
of my system hang on this is not right
okay git job if you see here this is my
hello.java this is the same program that
was there on my github repository
okay so this is a program that was there
on the github repository all right so
this was the same program that was here
and jenkins on our behalf went over all
the way to github pulled this repository
from there and then you know it brought
it down to my local system on my jenkins
instance it compiled it and it ran this
particular application
okay now that i've integrated jenkins
successfully with github for a simple
java application let me build a little
bit on top of it what i will do is i
have a maven based web application that
is up there as a repository in my
github so this is the repository that
i'm talking about it's called amv and
web app it's got it's a maven based
repository as you would know maven is a
very very simple java based uh build
tool that will allow you to run various
targets and it will compile it will
based upon the goals that you specify it
can compile it can run some tests and
you can you can build a war file and
even deploy it into some other server
for now what we're going to use maven is
just for building and creating a package
out of this particular web application
it contains a bunch of things and what
is important is just the index.jsp it
just contains an html file that is there
as a part of this web application so
from a perspective of requirements now
since i'm going to connect jenkins with
this particular repository git we
already have that set we only need two
other things one is maven because
jenkins will use maven so in order to
use maven jenkins would have to have a
maven installation that is there on the
jenkins box and in this case the jenkins
box is this laptop
and after i have my maven installed i
also need a tomcat server tomcat is a
very very simple uh web server that you
can freely download i'll let you know
how to quickly uh download and install
the tomcat all right so download maven
first
and the various ways in which you can
kind of download this maven there is zip
files
binary zip files and archive files so
what i've done is i've just already
downloaded maven and if you see i've
unzipped it here so this is the folder
with which i have unzipped my maven
so as you know maven again is is one
open source build tool so you'll have to
set in a few configurations and set up
the path so mvn hyphen iphone version if
i specify this after i set in my path my
one should work and if at all i echo m2
home which is nothing but the variable
environment variable specific to my
onenote it is already set here so once
you unzip mav1 just set this m2 home
variable to the directory where you
unzip your mi1 also just set the path to
this particular directory slash bin
because that is where your maven
executables are all found
all right so that's with maven and you
know since i've set the path and the
environment variable maven is running
perfectly fine on my system i just
verified it okay next one is a tomcat
server
download apache tomcat
server 8.5 is what i have on my system
so i'm just going to show you where to
download this from
this is where you download tomcat server
and
i already have the server downloaded
again this doesn't need any installation
i just unzip it here and it kind of has
a bin and configuration i have made some
subtle changes in the configuration
first and foremost tomcat server also by
default runs on port 8080. since we
already have our jenkins server running
on port 8080 we cannot let tomcat run on
the same port there will be a port clash
so what i've done i have configured
tomcat to use a different port so if i
go to this configuration file here there
is a server.xml
let me open this up here
all right okay so this is the port by
default it will be 8080 i've just
modified it to 8081. so i've changed the
port on which my tomcat server would run
all right so that's one chain second
change when jenkins kind of tries to get
into my tomcat and deploy something for
someone he would need some
authentications so that he'll be alloyed
deployment by tomcat so for that i need
to create a user on tomcat and provide
this user credentials to my jenkins
instance
so i would go to
tomcatusers.xml file here
i've already created
a username called deployer and the
password is deployer and i've added a
role called manager hyphen script
manager hyphen script will allow
programmatic access to the tomcat server
so this is the role that is there so
using this credentials i will enable or
i'll empower jenkins to get into my
tomcat server and deploy my application
all right only these two things that is
required
let me just start my tomcat server first
so i get into my bin folder i open a
command prompt here and there's a
startup.bat
it's pretty fast it just takes a few
seconds yes there you go tomcat server
is up and running now this is running on
port 8081 so let me just check if that
looks good
so localhost
8081.
okay my tomcat server is operating that
sounds good the user is already
configured on this that's also fine so
what i'll do as a part of my first job
my one is also installed on my system so
i'm good to use maven as a part of my
jenkins so i will put up a simple job
now
i will say job
mbn
web app i call this
freestyle job that's good
okay so this will be a git repository
what is the url of my git repository is
this guy
https url
okay
that's this url i will use the
credentials the old credentials that are
set up will work well because it's the
same git user that i'm kind of
connecting into
all right so now the change happens here
where after i get this since i said this
is a simple maven repository i will have
some maven targets to run
so the simple target first is
let me run maven package this creates a
war file
okay so mvn package is the target
package is the target so when whenever i
run this package it kind of creates it
it builds it it tests it and then
creates a package so this is all that is
required maybe let me try to save this
and let me first run this and see if it
connects well if there's any problem
with my war file or the war file gets
created properly
okay
wonderful so it built a war file and if
you see it all shows you
what is the location where this war file
was generated
so this will be the workspace if you see
this this war file was successfully
built now i need to grab this particular
war file and then i would need to deploy
it into tomcat server
again i would need a small plugin to do
this because i need to connect tomcat
with my jenkins server let me go ahead
and
install the plugin for the container
deployment
so i will go to manage plugins
available
type in container
container container
deploy to container okay so let's put
this the plugin that i would need i will
install it without a restart
right seems to be very fast
nope sorry it's still installing
okay
it installed the plugin so if at all you
see this
if you go to my workspace
okay in the target folder
i would see this web application war
file that is already built
so i would need to configure this plugin
to pull up this war file and deploy it
onto the tomcat server for deploying
onto the tomcat server i will use the
credentials of the user that i've
created
okay so let me go to configure this
particular project again
and um
okay all this is good
so the package is good i'm gonna just
create a package that's all fine
now
add a post build step so after the war
file is built as a part of this package
directive let me use this
deployment to container now this will
show up after you install the plugin so
deploy this one to the container
now what is that you're supposed to
specify you're supposed to specify
the what is the location
okay so this is a global uh you know
configuration that is there that will
allow you to
from the root folder it will pick up the
war file that is there so star star
forward slash star dot war that's good
for me
okay what is the context path context
path is nothing but just the name of an
application that you know under which it
will get deployed into the tomcat server
i will just say mvn web app
that's the name of my thing now i need
to specify what kind of a container that
i'm talking about
all right so the deployment would be for
the stomcat 8.5 is what i need
okay because the server that we have is
a tomcat 8.5 server that i have so this
would be the url so the credentials yes
i need to add a credential for this
particular server so if you remember i
had created a credential
for my web application so let me just
find that
my tomcat server yes configuration of
this
okay so deployer and deployer username
is deployer password is deployer
okay so let me use that credential
i would say i would say add a new
credential jenkins credential the
username is deployer and the password is
deployer
so i would use this deployer credentials
for that and what is the url of my
tomcat instance
so this is the url of my tomcat instance
so take the war file that is find found
in this particular
folder
and then you know context path is same
in web use the deployer deployment
credentials and get into this localhost
which is there
8081 this is the tomcat server that is
running on my system and then go ahead
and deploy it
okay so that is all that is required so
i would say just save this
and let me run it now
okay it builds successfully built the
war file it is trying to deploy it and
uh looks like
a deployment went ahead perfectly well
so
the context path was mvn web app so if i
type in this
all right if at all i go ahead into my
tomcat server there would be a web apps
folder
you would see the
you know the date timestamp so this is
the file that get got recently copied
and this is the explorer version of our
application
so the application was built the source
code of this application was pulled from
the github server it was built locally
on the jenkins test and then it was
pushed into a tomcat server which is
running on a different port which is
808.1 now for this demo i'm running
everything locally on my system but
assuming that you know this particular
tomcat instance was running on some
other server with some other different
ip address all that you got to go and
change is the url of the server
so this would be the server in case you
you already have that uh you know if you
have a tomcat which is running on some
other machine that's all fine with a
different ipa that's all good enough
the whole bundle or the war file that
was built as a part of this jenkins job
gets transferred onto the other server
and gets deployed that's the beauty of
jenkins and automatic deployments or
other deployments using jenkins and
maven
distributed build or master slave
configuration in jenkins as you would
have seen you know we just have one
instance of jenkins server up and
running all the time and also i told you
that whenever any job that kind of you
know gets started on the jenkins server
it is little heavy on in terms of disk
space and the cpu utilization so which
kind of you know if at all you're in an
organization wherein you're heavily
reliant on the jenkins server you don't
want your jenkins server to go down so
that's where you kind of start
distributing the load that is there on
the jenkins server so you primarily have
a server which is just a placeholder or
like a master who will take in all kind
of jobs and what he will do is based
upon trigger that has happened to the
job or whichever job needs to be built
he if at all he can delegate these jobs
onto some other machines or some other
slaves you know that's a wonderful thing
to have okay use case one use case two
assuming that you know if you have a
jenkins server that is running on a
windows box or on a linux one and if at
all you have a need where you need to
build based upon operating systems you
have multiple build configurations to
support maybe you need to build a
windows you know windows based dotnet
kind of a projects where you would need
a windows machine to build this
particular project you also have a
requirement where you want to build
linux linux based systems you also have
a mac you you support some sort of an
apps or something that is built on mac
os you would need to build you know mac
based system as well so how are you
going to support all these needs so
that's where in a beautiful concept of
master slave or you know primary and
delegations or agent and master comes
into play so typically you would have
one jenkins server who will just you
know configure with all the proper
authorizations users configurations and
everything is set up on this jenkins
server his job is just delegations he
will listen to some sort of triggers or
based upon the job that is coming in he
will if there is a way nice way of
delegating these jobs to somebody else
and you know taking back the results he
can control a lot of other systems and
these systems may not have a complete or
there's no need to put in a complete
jenkins installation all that you got to
do is have a very very simple runner or
a slave that is a simple jar file that
is run as a low priority thread or a
process within these systems so with
that you can have a wonderful
distributed build server that can be set
up and in case one of the servers goes
down your master would know that what
went down and kind of delegate the task
to somebody else so this is the kind of
distributed build or the master slave
configuration so what i'll do in this
exercise or in this demo is i will set
up a simple slave but since i don't have
too many machines to kind of play around
what i'll do is i will set up a slave in
in one other folder within my hard drive
so i've got the c drive and d drive
my jenkins is on my c drive so what i do
is i would just use my e drive and set
up a very very simple slave out there
i'll just show you how to provision a
slave and how to connect to a slave and
how to delegate a job to that slave let
me go back to my jenkins uh master and
uh configure him to you know talk to an
agent
so there are various ways in which this
client and server talk to each other
what i'm going to choose is something
called as jnlp java network launch
protocol so using this i would ensure
that you know the client and server talk
to each other so for that i need to
ensure that i kind of enable this jnlp
port so let me try to find out where is
that let me try this
okay yes agents and by default this jlp
agent's thing would be disabled so if
you see here there's a small help on
this
so i'm going to use this jnlp which is
nothing but java network launch protocol
and you know i'll configure
the master and server to talk to each
other using jlp so for that i need to
enable this guide so i enable this guy
instead of making the by default the
configuration was disabled so i make him
random i make him you know enabled and i
say save this configuration
all right so now i've configured or has
made a setting for the master
so that the jlp uh port is kind of
opened up so let me go ahead and you
know create an agent so i'll go to
manage nodes so if you see here there's
only one master here so let me provision
a new node here so this is the way you
know in which you bring up a new node
you have to configure it on the server
jenkins would put in some sort of
security around this particular
agent and let you know how to launch
this particular agent so that he can
connect your jenkins master so i would
say new node i would give a name for my
node i would say windows
node because both of these are windows
only so that's fine i just give an
identifier saying that windows note i
would say this is a permanent agent i'll
say okay
so if you see the name let me just copy
this name here with the description
number of executors since it's a slave
node and both of these are running on my
system i'll keep the number of executors
as one
that's fine remote root directory now
this is where let me just clarify this
since i have both my
my master is running on my c drive c
drive program files 86
or not 86
c colon program files
it is indeed 86
all right jenkins so this is where my
master is running so i don't want the c
drive what i'll do is i'll use something
called as a drive i have another drive
in my system but please visualize this
like you know you're running this on a
separate system altogether so i create a
folder here called jenkins node and this
is where i'm going to place my or i'm
going to provision my slave
and i'm going to run it from here so
this is the directory in which i'm going
to provision my slave node so i'm going
to copy this here and that is the remote
root directory of your particular agent
or slave so i just copied here the label
you know probably this is fine for me
and usage
how do you want to use this guy
so i would don't want him to run all
kinds of jobs i will only build jobs
with label expressions that match this
particular node and so this is the label
of this node so in order for somebody to
kind of delegate any task to them they
will have to specify this particular
label
so imagine this way if i have a bunch of
windows mesh system i name it as windows
star
anything that says from windows i can
give a regular expression and say that
anything that matches windows run this
particular task there if i have some mac
machines i name all these mac agents as
a mac star or something like that and i
can delegate all tasks you know saying
that start with whatever starts with mac
and this node run the mac jobs there
so you identify a node using the label
and then delegate the task there
all right so launch method you know we
will use java web start because we're
going to
we're going to use jnlp protocol okay
that sounds good directory i think
nothing else is required availability
yes we'll keep this agent yep online as
much as possible that sounds good all
right let me save this
all right i'm just provisioning this
particular node now
so if i click on this node i get a bunch
of commands along with an agent.jar
so this is the agent.jar that has to be
taken down to the other machine or the
slave node and from there i need to run
this along with a small security
credential so let me copy this whole
[Music]
text here in my notepad
notepad plus plus is good for me
okay i copy this whole
path there i also want to download this
alien.jar
i would say yes
and this agent.jar is the one that is
configured by our server so all the
details that is required for launching
this agent.jar is found in this uh sorry
for launching this agent is found as
agent.jar so typically i need to
take this jar file onto the other system
and then
kind of run it from there so
i have this alien.jar i copy this or i
cut this i come back to my folder my
jenkins node i paste it here
okay so now with this provision
agent.jar and i need to use this whole
command ctrl a control c and then launch
this particular agent so let me
bring up a command prompt right here
and then launched it so i'm saying in
the same folder where there is agent.jar
i'm going to launch this a particular
agent java hyphen jar agent.jar jnlp
this is the url of my server in case the
server and client are in different
locations or different ips you have to
specify the ip address all this any way
would show up
and then the secret and you know the
root folder of your jenkins or the slave
node
okay
so
something ran and then you know it says
it's connected very well it seems to
connect very well so let me come back to
my
jenkins instance
and see you know if you told me you see
earlier this was not connected let me
refresh this guy
okay now these two guys are connected
provision a jenkins node and then i
copied all the credentials of the
slave.jar along with the launch code and
then took it to the other system and
kind of
ran it from there since i don't have
another system i've just got a separate
directory in another folder another
drive and i'm launching the agent from
here as long as this particular agent is
up and running or this command prompt is
up and running the agent would be
connected so once i close this the
connection goes down
all right so successfully you've
launched this particular agent now this
would be the home directory of this
jenkins node or the jenkins slave so any
task that i'm going to delegate to this
particular slave would all be run here
it will create a workspace right here
all right so good
so let me just come back and let me kind
of put up a new task here i will say
that you know delegate job is good i say
freestyle project i'm going to create a
very very simple job here
i don't want it to connect to gate or
anything like that let me just create a
very very simple
echo
relegated to the
slave related to i don't like the word
slave delegated to
agent
put this way
all right so delegated to agent sounds
good now how am i going to ensure that
this particular job
runs on the agent or on the slave that
i've configured
right you see this if at all you
remember how we provisioned our
particular slave we give a label
right so now i'm going to put in a job
that will only match this particular
label
so i'm going to say that whatever
matches this windows label run this job
on that particular node so we have only
one node that's matching this in a
windows node so this job will be
delegated out there so i save this
and let me build this
this is again a very very simple job
there's nothing in this i just want to
demonstrate how to kind of delegate it
to an agent so if you see this
it ran successfully
and uh where is the workspace
the workspace is right inside our
jenkins node it created a new workspace
delegated job it put in here so my old
order my primary master
job is in sql
program files under jenkins and this is
the slave job that was successfully run
very very simple but very very powerful
concept of master slave configuration or
distributed build in jenkins
okay approaching the final section where
we've done all this hard work in
bringing up our jenkins server
configuring it putting up some jobs on
it creating users and all this stuff now
we don't want this configuration to kind
of go away we want a very nice way of
ensuring that we backup all this
configuration and in case there is any
failure hardware crash or a machine
crash we would want to kind of restore
from the existing configuration that we
kind of backed up
so one quick way to do that would be or
one dirty way to do that would be just
you know take a complete backup of us
colon program files colon jenkins
directory because that's where our whole
jenkins configuration is present but we
don't want to do that let's use some
plugins for taking up a backup so let me
go to manage jenkins
and click on available
and let me search for some back there
are a bunch of backup plugins so i would
recommend one of these plugins that i
specifically use
so this is the backup plugin so let me
go ahead and install this plugin
all right so we went ahead and installed
this plugin
so let me come back to my
manage plugins
so this plugin is there
so
hang on backup manager so you will see
this option once you install this plugin
so first time i can you know do a setup
i would say backup this particular i'll
give a folder uh this folder is
pertaining to the folder where i want
jiggings to backup some data and i would
say the format should be zip format is
good enough let me give a name
or a template or a file name for my
you know backup this is good i want it
in verbose mode i don't want to shut on
my jenkins or should i shut it down no
okay one thing that you got to remember
is that whenever a backup happens if
there are too many jobs that is running
on the server
it can kind of slow down your jenkins
instance because it's it's in the
process of copying few of those things
and the files are being changed at that
moment it's little bit problematic for
jenkins so typically you back up your
servers only when there is very less
load or typically try to you know bring
it to a shutdown kind of a state and
then take a backup
all right so i'm going to back up all
these things you know i don't want to
exclude anything else i want the history
i want the maven artifacts
possibly i don't want this guy i would
just say save
and then i would say
back him up
so this would run a bunch of you know
steps and all the files that is required
as a part of this is pretty fast but
then if at all you have too many things
up on your server for now we didn't have
too many things up on our server but in
case you had too many things to kind of
backup this may take a while so let me
just pause this
recording and get back to you once the
backup is complete so there you go the
backup was successful
created a backup of all the workspace
the configurations the users and you
know all that so all this is kind of
hidden down in this particular
zip file so at any instance if at all i
kind of crash my system for some
instance or say hard disk failure and i
bring up a new instance of jenkins i can
kind of use the backup plugin for
restoring this particular
configurations
so how do i do that i just come back to
my manager cairns
come back to
backup manager and i will say restore
her that's an or
jenkins configuration today's topic is
learn html in 10 minutes
first we'll go through a quick
introduction to basic web architecture
to understand how the internet works
then we'll understand what exactly html
is
after that we'll have a look at what css
then we'll go through javascript
and in the end we'll create a simple web
page using html and css to gain a better
understanding of the html tags
so without further ado let's begin
now what exactly is the basic web
architecture now web architecture is
made up of three essential elements
that's the website that is the front end
of a web application that is visible to
the user
then there is the server which
constitutes the back end of a web
application and holds and manages all
the data and finally there's the ip
address that is the address assigned to
a website in order to be accessible on
the internet
first up let's have a look at what
website is
so your browser starts by loading the
main html file and then the css and
javascript
the user interacts with the website and
is not concerned with the backend of an
application now secondly we have
the server once you've developed your
website you will have to host it on your
server to make it accessible on the
internet
server along with the database contains
all the data of your website and
facilitates user interaction
lastly there's ipaddress which is the
third element of the web architecture
now website is hosted on an ip address
we put a domain name over that ip
address the same way we put names over
people's phone numbers
when you type a domain name in the
browser it will give you the server call
the server will then send over the
website to you
next what is html
html is the most widely used markup
language for developing and structuring
web pages on the internet
it defines the structure of websites and
formats these web pages
so what exactly is css then
now css is a simple design language used
for making web pages look more beautiful
and presentable
it can be attached to any html element
to style it or even position it
according to the developer's choice
then you must be wondering what exactly
is javascript
now javascript is a powerful interpreted
language targeted for web development it
is used for making web pages interactive
and bringing the web pages to life
so now let's create your first website
now html short for hyper text markup
language is the coding standard for
documents designed for web browsers
consisting of a series of elements or
tags and which can be used to structure
a web page right so these elements can
include headings paragraphs
div containers tables and more html tags
are nested meaning there are opening and
closing tags with the content in between
those tags
so now let's write a simple html code
that will help you understand the basics
of the language so for this i'm using
the text editor that is visual studio
code you can go ahead and download this
text editor from their official website
so here i've created a simple.html file
in my vs code and i've added the initial
html files
now let me explain to you one by one
now doc type is not so much of a tag but
it is more of an instruction
now this indicates the browser that the
document type to be served to the user
is in fact an html document
now this doctype instruction should
always be included at the very top of
your html page
next up you have the html tag that is
used to contain all the web pages html
code
right so it contains an opening and
closing tag with contents in between
them
the html tag can also have attributes
now for example there's the lang
attribute allowing you to specify the
spoken language of the contents of the
page followed by the html tag there's
the head tag now this is the first
section of the code that contains all of
the information about the web pages
properties links and more it could have
pages title description additional meta
tags and css code so here i've used the
title tag and let's give a title say
html
in 10 minutes
all right
you can also add css to the head tag by
using the style tag and change the
display styles of html elements that are
being used
the next section is the body tag now the
body tag contains all the displayable
contents of your web page including
headings paragraphs div containers
tables and more
now the html header tags are used to add
headings to a web page there are several
types of headings available for
developers to add to a web page right so
first up let's have a look at them i'm
going to create a simple h1 heading tag
and the message i'm displaying is
this is
the first heading
all right
after this i'm going to add a paragraph
tag which creates padding in the top and
bottom of the element to help separate
the text between each paragraph
right so i'm gonna add a p tag
and save
this is the paragraph tag
[Music]
after this let me add a simple h2 tag
which is
another heading tag and say this is the
second heading
now you can also add line breaks which
are helpful from time to time if you
want to provide a single line break in
your content you can do so by adding the
br tag
so here let me just add one for
better understanding
now the html div tag defines a division
or a section in an html document that is
used as a container for other html
elements
now these elements can include content
areas sidebars page bars page headers
footers etc
this tag is used to apply styles to html
elements that cannot be added otherwise
you can also make use of the html image
tag to add images to a web page now
these images in a webpage are a very
common site and they can make the
website look more attractive so for that
we can use the image tag so let's say
img
within which i mentioned the source
[Music]
i'm adding the html logo so let me just
mention that here
and then i'm going to provide width for
it and then a specific height
all right so when you save the file
and when you look at the browser
you can see that
the first heading is displayed then your
paragraph tag is displayed followed by
the second heading and then the image
now let me show you how you can add
styles for some of these uh headings and
paragraph tags so here in back in my
first heading tag let me just say styles
and let me change the font
of the content that is being displayed
and i'm going to change it to career new
and for my paragraph tag let me display
the content in italics so i'll say font
style and make it italics
so let me save this and when i look at
the browser
you can see that the font has changed
and so has the font style here
so now we've covered a few important
html tags used to develop a web page now
there are many other tags available for
almost everything you'd want to add to a
web page now all of these are available
on the internet for you and you can use
them on your website welcome to this
crash course video on css this video
will help you understand all the
concepts of css and provide lots of
hands-on examples
we'll start with understanding selectors
box model grid layout flexbox
differences between grid layout and
flexbox and some more basic topics
then building on these basics will make
a navbar learn how to create animation
and transitions and finally we'll move
on to css advanced functions
so let's begin
in this video you will learn what are
css selectors and what are their
different types
so let's start with discussing the
agenda for this tutorial
so in this tutorial we will learn what
are css selected and what are their
different types we will also look at an
example to how to work with css
selectors
so
what are css selectors
css selectors allow you to select and
style html elements selectors are used
to find elements based on their id
classes types attributes value of
attributes and much more let's discuss
the most common selectors there are
several different types of css selectors
the most common of them are css element
selectors css id selector css class
selector css universal selector and css
group selectors
so what is the css element selector
the element selector selects element
based on the element name
this is a css selector it means it will
select all the p elements on the page it
will style all the p elements to the
central aligned having blue color
this is a css selector
it is set to p
this means it will select all the p
elements on the page it will style all
the p elements to be center aligned
having blue color
let's look at what it looks on a page
so as you can see all the elements are
centrally aligned with the text color
blue
css id selector
the id selector uses the id attribute of
an html element to find the specific
element
an id should be unique within the page
so you should use the id selector to
find a single unique element
to find an element within a specific id
use a hash character followed by the id
of the element
so
here we have used the hash paragon so
all the rules will be applied to the
html element with id equal to para1 so
this is an id selector
it will be applied to all the html
element with id is equal to para1
as you can see it is applied to the
element
having the id parameter and all the
other elements are defaultly styled
css class selector the class selector
finds the element with a specific class
set by the html class attribute to
select an html with a specific class use
a period character followed by the name
of the class
so this style will be applied to all the
elements having the class name class1
this is a class selector it is denoted
by a period symbol
all the elements having a class name
class 1 will be styled with centrally
aligned and color blue
as you can see the element having the
class name class 1 is styled and all the
other elements are set to default
css universal selector
the universal selector selects all the
elements on a page the universe is
selected is assigned by a star character
the universal selector selects all the
elements on a style sheet
as you can see it is denoted by a star
mark all the elements inside our page
will be centrally aligned and the color
will be set to blue
as you can see all the elements are
centrally aligned and the colors are set
to blue
css group selector
in style sheets there are often elements
using the same style to minimize the
code you can group selectors to group
the selectors separate each selectors
with a comma here we have group
selectors for h1 h2 and p
so style is applied to h1 h2 and p
elements only
it is better to group the selectors to
minimize the code
here we have group selectors p h2 and s3
so style will be applied to only
elements having p h2 and s3
as you can see so all the elements of
ph2 and s3 are centrally aligned and
color to red in this video we will
discuss what is the box model and its
various properties
we will also do an example to understand
the box model better
so let's get started
every element that can be displayed on a
web webpage is comprised of one or more
rectangular boxes
css box model typically describes how
these rectangular boxes are laid out on
a web page
these boxes can have different
properties and can interact with each
other in different phase but every box
has a content area and optional
surrounding padding border and margin
areas
the following diagram demonstrates how
the content padding border and margin
css properties determine how much space
an element can take on a web page
the content area consists of content
like text images or other media it is
bounded by the content edge and its
dimensions are given by the content box
width and height
the border area is the area between the
box padding and margin
its dimensions are given by the width
and height of the border
the margin area consists of spaces
between the border and the margin
the dimensions of the margin area are
the margin box width and margin box
height
it is useful to separate the element
from its neighbors
the padding area is the area
that includes the elements padding this
area is actually the space around the
content area and within the border box
its dimensions are given by the width of
the padding box and the height of the
padding box
now let's jump to an example to
understand the box model better
so we are on the sublime text later to
get started i have created a box themed
simply background color pink the font
size is 30 pixel and we have set the
border to zero solid green
let's see how it looks on our page
so as you can see we have a box named
simply learn with background going all
the way to the end i have also removed
all the padding and margins from the
page so that the boxes are pushed just
at the corner of the page
as you can see
let's start by adding a padding of 20
pixel to the box
if you save the file you can see the box
increased by 20 pixels from all the
sides
padding occurs inside the background of
an element it goes around the content of
the element
most of the buttons inside the css is
designed using padding so that the
background of the button becomes wider
than the actual text
the next thing you can do is change the
border of the element if we change this
border size to 15 pixel we will get a
nice solid background of color green
the border goes around the padding of
our element so we have the 20 pixel of
padding around our content and 15 pixels
of water around the padding which is
round the content
now let's see the working of the margin
if add 30 pixel of margin to our element
you can see the spacing on the outside
of our border
so let's add the 30 pixel margin and
refresh
you can see the spacing on outside of
the border
margin is used to space two elements
apart from each other
now let's change these values to see the
difference
let's make the margin 40 pixels
we'll make the padding 30 pixels
and let's keep the border 20 pixels and
make it color
red
this is 40 pixels
let's observe the changes
so as you can see our border now has a
red background the padding is 30 pixel
the margin is 40 pixels let's inspect
the elements to understand it better
by clicking on inspect you can see the
different
styles
here in the computer tab you can see the
box model
this is a content area
this is the padding area this is the
border and this is the margin area
we have the margin of 40 pixels around
the
border so you can when you click on this
area you can see the margin
gets highlighted
the border area gets highlighted of 20
pixels this is the padding and this is
the content
you can change the size of the content
by adding the height and width
so let's try adding height and width
we'll give the height 50 pixels and
we'll give the width also 50 pixels
just save the file
now when you refresh you can see the
content area of 15 to 50. in this
tutorial
we will discuss everything needed for
you to get started working with grid
layouts
we will start by discussing what is a
grid layout
then we will move on to the features of
the grid system and some basic
terminologies which will help you
understand the grid system better
in end we will work on an example to
understand a grid system
so let's get started
what is a grid
a grid is the setup intersecting
horizontal and vertical lines defining
the rows and columns
and what is the grid layout
so css gridload is the most powerful
layout system available in css it is a
two-dimensional system
meaning it can handle both columns and
rows unlike flexbox which is largely a
one-dimensional system
you work with grid layout by applying
the css rules to both the parent element
which became the grid container and the
elements children which become the grid
items
the css grid allowed excess at dividing
a page into major regions or defining
the relationship in terms of size
position and layer between parts of a
control build html primitives
you can see this is the basic layout of
a grid system
like tables grid layout enables an
author to align elements into columns
and rows
however many more regular layouts are
either possible or easier with css grid
than they were with tables for example a
grid container's child element could
position themselves so they actually
overlap and layer similar to the css
positioned elements
so here are the features of the css grid
layout
they are fixed and have flexible track
sizes
you can create a grid with fixed track
sizes using pixels
for example
this sets the grid to the specified
pixel which fits to the layout you
desire
you can also create a grid using
flexible sizes with percentages with the
new fr unit designed for this purpose
you can place the items into a precise
location using the grid
line numbers names or by targeting an
area of the grid
the grid also contains an algorithm to
control the placement of items
not given an explicit position on the
grid
you can define an explicit grid with a
grid layout
the grid layer specification is flexible
enough to add additional rows and
columns when needed
features such as adding as many columns
that will fit into a container are
included
it also gives you control of overlapping
content
more than one item can be placed into a
grid cell or area and they can partially
overlap each other
this layering may then be controlled
with the z-index property
so
here are the basic terminologies you
should know to work with the grid system
better
the grid line is the dividing line that
make up the structure of the grid
they can either be vertical or
horizontal and reside on either side of
rows and columns
a grid column is spaced between two
adjacent vertical grid lines
the size of a grid column is determined
by the grid template columns property
on the other hand a grid row is a space
between
two adjacent horizontal grid lines
its size is determined by the grid
template rows property
the grid cell is the single unit of a
css grid
and in grid design a gutter is basically
the width of the space between columns a
gutter margin is this white space formed
by the adjoining inside margins of two
facing pages in a book or a space
between columns on a page
so
with this
let's now move on to the hands-on demo
and see how the grid system works in
actual world so we are in the sublime
text editor open with a project with
some basic background styles and nothing
inside the body
you can see this is a basic background
style we have pre-applied just to have a
good look of the
box model
we'll start by creating a container and
wrapping our grid items in it
so let's create a grid and give it a
class named grid container
and inside of it we'll put our different
grid items
so we'll just create different grid
items and give them a class grid item
followed by a class number they belong
to
so that we can easily distribute between
them
just copy paste this
five times
so we'll have the five elements on our
page
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
so you can see we have the different
grid items on the screen so that is easy
for us to visualize
we have not applied any styles to them
other than the visual styles
so we'll go back to our code
let's go back to the css styling sheet
so to create the grid we will open a
style sheet we need to display grid on
our grid container so we'll select our
grid container and set the display to
grid
if we save now
you will see nothing changes this is
because the grid itself doesn't define
any rows and columns for us to work with
it just they give the alignment properly
therefore by default it looks just
exactly the same
to make the grid look actually great we
what you need to do is define columns
and rows for a grid
so to do this you will use a set grid
template and set the column if you want
to set the size of the column
we'll set the size to 100 pixel 950
pixels
now
if you refresh you have the 100 pixel
column on the left and a 150 pixel
column on the right
and then the grid captures our next row
but what if we want our box to flexible
size themselves according to the items
inside of them
here
we'll use a fraction in it instead of a
150 pixel column we want one fraction of
our size and instead of 100 pixels we
want the two fractions of our size
so we'll just replace with two fractions
and this with one fraction
now if you save the file
and go back to the page
you will see that the items on our left
here in our first column are twice as
large as the item on the second column
and that's because of the fr units we
have defined
you can see the difference in the sizes
the item one is the twice of the size of
the item two
another thing you can do is with columns
is use repeat
suppose you want four columns of a size
hundred pixel wide you can just write
repeat command and inside of it how many
times you want to repeat the size
so we'll just delete this
and use the repeat
we'll set the number of times you want
to repeat and the size of the
columns
now if you save the file you will see we
have a four columns of 100 pixel wide
we can do the same things for row
just set the grid template
rows and define the size you want
now you can see we have the symmetric
size all around our container
if you don't know how large your grid is
going to be you can use the grid auto
rows and this will determine the size of
all the rows that is added after the
template rows
suppose we want all our rows to be 100
pixels
so we'll just delete the grid template
rows
and set the grid auto rows to 100 pixels
now you can see all the rows are now 100
pixel tall
let's change our colon back to 100 pixel
and 150 pixels
so that it will be easier for us further
we'll just delete this grid auto rows
now we'll talk about the spacing of the
rows and columns apart from each other
we can do this with the help of the grid
grab property grilled row gap will give
some spaces between the rows similarly
the grid column will give you the spaces
between the columns
now you can see the gaps between the
rows and columns
now we want the same value for both the
columns you can use the grid grab
property and mention the space
we'll just delete these two
and instead of it we will use just the
grid gap
and set the
size to 20
pixels now you can see the evenly spaces
between the rows and the columns
this is all you need to know about the
sizing of the different columns and rows
now let's talk about the positioning
items within its grid cells
so for horizontal positioning we could
use the justify items and we can set
that to center
so that centers each item within the
cell
by default it is set to stretch
you can also set it to start
or end
or space around
we will leave this to center
to vertically position the content we
could use the align items
the
items also accept the same values
we can set it to center
we can also set this one to start or end
just will keep this to center as well
you can also align the entire grid
within the container
so let's get rid of these to just
demonstrate them
in a proper manner
we can use the justify content and that
will align the content horizontally
within the container
we can also set this to start or to end
just set this back to center
to align the content vertically we could
use the align content and the align
content also accepts the same value we
can set it to center
or start
if you inspect the elements
you can see they are aligned centrally
between the container
we will just close this
okay so this is everything you need to
know to get started with the grid layout
grid works very similar to the flexbox
but it allows it too much in terms of
laying your elements because of its 2d
nature in this video we will learn
what is a flexbox and how it is useful
in designing the layout of the website
we will also try to understand the
different properties of flexbox with the
help of an example
so let's get started
what is a flexbox
flexbox
also called flexible box model is
basically a layout mode or model that
provides an easy and clean way to
arrange the items within a container
if you are using a css for a while you
must have used the old block model where
you assign width in terms of percentage
or fixed width
and then use the float to arrange the
items on the page
suppose for example you want to arrange
three boxes in a row
then you have to enter everything
manually from weight height and to
padding flexbox can do all these things
with ease
some of the concepts of flexible box
model is the ability to alter the item
width and height to best fit the
containers available in the free space
flex model is the direction agnostic
which is different from the box model
which is vertically biased and the
inline which is horizontally biased
flexbox works for both
flexbox is more effective in small scale
layouts
so here are the main properties of the
flex
okay
so let's jump to some code and learn how
these flex properties work
okay so we are in the sublime text
editor
to get started let's add a div inside
our body here and we'll give a class of
flexbox container since this will be the
container where all our flexbox item
will reside
then inside this container we will add
another div and give it a class flexbox
item and one more class flexbox item 1
which will help us to understand which
items we are referring to when we style
our elements individually
let's just save the file and see how it
looks on a page
now if you save the file you can see we
have the box because i have already
applied some of the styles to these
flexbox items
let's just see the styling
so you can see we have the item styled
just a basic styling so that we get the
box on our page
now let's just copy these and add two
more flexbox items and you will see we
have two more boxes on our page
just copy and paste them below
give them the class name flexbox item 2
and flexbox item 3.
just save the file
now you can see we have three boxes on
the page
now to create a flex container
we will add display flex to our flex
container and this is how we create a
flex
box container
so here we will just add
display
flex
just save the file
now you can see all the items are in the
same height and they are all in the same
row
you will also notice that if we shrink
our browser the items adjust themselves
accordingly to fit within the browser
now if you want to style the elements on
the main axis we will use the property
justify content inside of flexbox
container
let's
make it a center
save the file
now you can see that all the elements
are in the center of the page
another thing we can do is if we want
our layout to have a spaces between the
elements
we will set the justify content to space
between
you can see all the items are now evenly
spaced
if you want to lay out your items on the
cross axis we will use the align items
property
the default value for this is stretch
if we want to keep the size of our items
we will use the center and then all our
items will be centered vertically
before flexbox aligning the items
vertically inside the container was
nearly impossible
with flexbox you can do it easily
now you can see the items are aligned
vertically inside the container
now let's just delete everything and
we'll just keep the display flex
now if you want to have a column layout
instead we will use the flex direction
and change it to column flex direction
column now if you refresh the page you
will see all the items are shown up in a
column
now you can start talking about the
different properties that can be applied
to our different flexbox items as a
postal flexbox container items the
flexbox container is only for laying out
and spacing between your items as well
as the positioning of your item inside
the container
the actual flexbox item properties are
used to override those item properties
or to apply different sizing to these
elements now if we want our first item
that it does not shrink when we shrink
our browser we'll set the flex shrink to
zero to our first item
so we'll set the flex
shrink to zero
now if you go back to the page
and try to shrink this
you'll see the first item remains the
same it does not shrink
now
in the same way you can set the items to
grow in proportion with the web browser
suppose we want our flexbox item to to
grow with the as the page grow and cover
all the empty spaces
so we'll set this flex grow to one
now
you will see the all the empty spaces
are taken by the second item
let's say we want the second box to be
the center of the container instead of
stretching to full height
we can use the align self property and
set it to center
now you will see that the alliances
property overrides the align content
property of the container
you can see it is centrally aligned
so this is all you need to understand
and get started to work with the
flexboxes
i hope you guys enjoyed this video and
learned something new about the flexbox
and how you can use the textbox to
create the dynamic layout for your site
in this video we are going to discuss
one of the most important topics of the
web development which is css display so
without wasting any time let's get
started
so what is the display property
the css display property controls the
layout of the element on the page
the default value of the display
property is block or inline
let's jump back to our sublime text
later to see the various display
properties by using an example to get
started i have a really simple example
setup
as you can see inside my html i have the
two paragraph tags
and
i have a formatting
with a background color of sand color
and font size 30 pixels
as you can see this looks like something
like this on the page
the very first property we are going to
discuss is the display block property
the drop display values make an element
a block element
the block elements start a new line and
span the entire width of the viewport by
default like how p elements behave
there are also line breaks before and
after these elements
the default value of the
p element is a display block
so
here
this looks something like this
what display blocks does is it means
that it is going to take the entire bit
given to it
this is going to force a new line above
and new line below it so you cannot have
something next to here now if we change
here this to
[Music]
the next property we are going to
discuss is inline
the inline display value turns any
element into an inline element these
elements will appear on the same line
without breaks
now if we change here this to display
inline now all the p tags will behave as
an inline element
now if we go back to our page and
refresh
you can see now this is an inline
element
the inline element takes the minimum
amount of space possible
as you can see here the cyanide takes
the minimum amount of space to fit all
the content inside of this
p so this is what an inline element does
also all the inline elements are on the
same line
they share the space together because
they take the minimum amount of space
possible
there are no line breaks in these
elements and they try to fit as closely
as possible
now one of the demerits here is we
cannot change the height and width of
the inline element
if you change here height
to 200 pixels
and width 200 pixels and save
just go back and refresh
you'll see nothing happens this is
because in the inline display property
you cannot change the height and width
of the element
the next property we are going to
discuss is the inline block value
the inline block value is a hybrid of
inline and block element elements
assigned display inline block appears on
the same line with the other inline
elements
a characteristics of inline elements
however inline block elements are also
like block elements in that you can
change the width and height of the css
now if here we try to change the height
and width
of the element
just change this to inline block
now if you go back to the page and
refresh
you will see the height and width
property works this is one of the major
difference between the inline block and
the inline l inline display property
the last name type of display we are
going to discuss is the display none and
this is a really straightforward display
property
you just delete this
and change the display to display none
now if you save the file and go back and
refresh
you'll see both the element disappears
the display nun removes the targeted
elements and all its child elements from
the page
this causes accompanying elements to
behave as if this element does not exist
in this video we will discuss everything
you need to know about css positioning
by the time this video is over you'll be
able to position the elements in css
like a pro
so let's get started
first let's cover the theoretical part
here we will discuss what is the asus
position property and its different
types
after that we will jump to practical
example to learn how to work with these
properties so let's get started
so what is css position property
the css position property allows you to
define the position of an element on a
web page
the top right bottom and the left css
position properties
are used to determine the final location
of the element
there are four values that you can use
to set the position of an element on a
webpage
they are static fixed relative and
absolute
using one of the four values above you
can specify how an element should be
positioned
you can also use the top bottom left and
right properties to further define the
elements position on a page
so let's discuss each of the properties
individually
css static position
this is a by default position for html
elements
it always positions an element according
to the normal flow of the page
it is not affected by the top bottom
left and right properties
it is important to note that having a
static position is the same as not
setting the position property at all
the next is css fixed position
the fixed positioning property helps to
put the text fixed on the browser
the fixed test is positioned relative to
the browser's
window and does not move even when you
scroll the window
the next is css relative position
the relative position property is used
to set the element relative to its
normal position
the relatively positioned element
behaves the same way as a static element
except that it is now subject to the
values of the four other css properties
we'll discuss each of them with more
detail in examples
now there is css absolute position
the absolute positioning is used to
position an element related to the first
parent element
that has a position other than static
if no such element is found the
containing block is html
with absolute positioning you can place
an element anywhere on the page
now let's move on to the example to
understand each of the properties better
to demonstrate the properties i have the
simple example set up
currently we have three elements with
just basic coloring style
we have not applied any position style
to them
now let's click on this
element 2 and inspect it
just go to the computed
and type here position to see the
position of this element
so you can see that currently the
position is static
static is the default value of all the
elements of the page in starting
the next position we'll see is the
relative position
it works almost in a similar manner to
static
if you go here and change the position
to relative
you can see nothing changes
relative act is the same as static but
the only difference is that the relative
allows you to change the top left right
and bottom of this element let me show
you an example
now if we change here to
left
20 pixel
and refresh
you will notice the elements move itself
to a 20 pixel from the left
let's set the top to 10 pixel as well
you can see the element has moved 10
pixels from the top and even overflows
the element below
this is because relative position when
applied with the top right left and
bottom actually takes that element out
of the document flow
let's just reset it
next property we are going to discuss is
absolute position and this property gets
well along with the top right left and
bottom
so let's make this position to absolute
and you can see the changes made due to
this by just
saving
the absolute value completely removes
the element from the document flow
this is useful when you want a
particular element to be a specific
position but you don't want to disturb
the other element's positioning
absolute position positions the element
inside the some parent container that it
can reference
now just
let's shift the top to 10 pixels
you can see the movement of this element
[Music]
the absolute position always position
the element inside some parent container
that it can reference to
now if you change the
here body position to relative now the
this navbar will position the element
according to this body so if you go here
and refresh this you can see that this 2
is in relation to with this container
and this is where relative is very
useful
next is fixed positioning which is very
similar to absolute positioning with
some differences
so let's change this to fixed
and just save this
now you can see it completely ignores
this relative positioning and goes
entirely at the top
this is because fixed position elements
are always fixed based on the entire
html element
it has nothing to do with the parent
elements
one unique feature of the fixed element
is they stay in the same place when you
scroll
let's make the height here
to 200 vertical height
now if you scroll down you will see that
the element two will stay on the same
position
see
the two elements stick to the same
position
but absolute does not work that way when
you change this here to absolute
you can see it does not stay
at the top now
this is one major difference between
absolute and fixed
so that's it you can see the working
with the css position super easy in this
video
we'll discuss the differences between
both the layouts and we'll discuss which
one you should use
i will also show you both the layouts in
a practical example without diving too
deep
so let's first understand the theory
css grid allows developers to construct
custom grids with more flexibility and
control than ever before
it is for two dimensional positioning we
got rows and columns here
whereas flexbox is for one dimensional
layout it is useful in allocating and
aligning the spaces among the items in a
grid container the flexbox layout
pattern makes it easier to design and
flexible and effective layouts
the grid is used for creating more
complex and organized layouts on your
pages
whereas the flex items is used to design
the responsive pages without using too
much of positioning or float in our css
code to work with the css grid layout
you have to add display grid property to
your element
whereas to create the flex container you
have to use the displayflex property
so this is the main difference between
the layout of the
grid and flexbox
here in the grid layout you can see that
there are rows and columns with all the
header menu main right and the footer
included whereas the flexbox is only for
one dimensional positioning
now let's move on to the example to see
the working of the both the layouts so
here is an example of the web page that
does not have any function other than
some basic styling
here on the page we have a header which
is blue in color
this is a sidebar with a red background
and this is the main content and this
black color is the footer of the page
here you can see this all these items
are stacked on top of the each other
in the code you can see um this is the
footer part of the page uh this is the
main content of the page this is for the
sidebar and this is for the header area
of the page
for the styling part we have used some
basic styling just so as to understand
the example better
now
we can turn the body into a grid by
setting the display property to the grid
so here under the body we'll set the
display to grid
just save the file and refresh
you can see nothing changes
because by default the css grid starts
creating rows automatically and adds the
content in these rows that's why it
didn't change
we can change it by adding the grid
template column property in our body in
our case we'll need two columns one for
sidebar and other for the main content
let's set the side area to 30
and we'll keep the main area to auto to
cover the remaining spaces
now if you save the file and reload you
can see the elements are broken into the
files we created
we will also define the rows for our
header and we will use the grid template
rows
we'll set the grid template rows for the
header to 60 pixels
for the sidebar and for the main content
we'll set it to auto
and also for the footer we will keep it
60 pixels
now if you save the file and reload you
can see the elements adjusted in a 2d
manner just as we wanted
this shows the power of the grid and the
flexibility it provides to the developer
however
we can see that the items are not
positioned properly in the header
and the
footer this is where the flexbox comes
into play as discussed earlier textbox
is about positioning elements in a
one-dimensional area
so what we'll do is we'll go back to our
navigation list class here
and will add display as flex
now if you save the file and reload
you can see these are sitting next to
each other
by default the display sets them into
the rows
now we want the contents to be in the
center of the main axis
so we will use the justify content and
set it to center
you can see the items are now in the
center of the main axis
to center them vertically we'll use the
align items and set it to center as well
this will position them in the center
across the axis
for this to work we have to specify the
height so we'll set it to 100 percent
so now you can see the items are aligned
centrally both on the main axis and the
cross axis
let's now add some spacing between these
items
so to give some spacing between we add a
margin to navigation item class
we'll set the margin to 0 for top and
bottom and 10 pixel to left and right
if we save the file and refresh
you can see we have the spaces between
the items
in this video you will learn how to set
a background image on a web page you
will also learn some of the basic
properties of the background that are
used to set the image
so let's start by discussing the agenda
for this tutorial
in this tutorial we'll discuss what is
css background image after that we'll
discuss some of the basic properties of
the background image in the end we'll
add a background image to our webpage by
adding the code to our text editor
so let's begin by discussing about the
background property of the css
the background image property specifies
an image to use as a background of an
element
the background is defined in the body
element of the html code
to add a background image on an html
element use the html style attribute and
the css background image property and
mention the path of the image inside the
url attribute
there are several properties of the
background that are used to define the
image on a page
some of the common ones are background
image background repeat and background
position
by default the image is repeated so it
covers the entire element
let's switch to the text editor and see
how we can add the background image to
our page so we are on the sublime text
editor let's start by opening a style
tag
the background image is always set on
the body tag
so type body and open the curly braces
the background image is always set on
the body tag so open the body type with
curly braces and start typing background
image
use the url value of the background
image to set the path of the image
make sure the image is in the same
folder as of the html file here we have
our file nature 3.jpg
so mention the path inside the double
quotes
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a web page
as you can see we have the image on the
web page let's format this image a
little bit
we'll start by setting the background
size so type background size
and there are three
values to the background size first one
is auto
it will set the image as it is
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a page
as you can see the size of the image is
as same of the original size
the color value will set the image size
that will be fit to the webpage
as you can see the image is set to the
whole web page
we can also set the image size to manual
let's say we want the image size of bit
500 pixels so
now as you can see the width of the
image is 500 pixels next we will set the
background repeat property
there are three values to background
repeat first is no repeat with no repeat
value the images will not be repeated on
a page
now as you can see the images are not
repeated
second is repeat text it will set the
images to be repeated on the x-axis
as you can see the images are now
repeated on the x-axis
similarly repeat the images on the
y-axis
as you can see the images are now
repeated to the y-axis and there is a
default value repeat which will repeat
the images on the web page
so
let's keep it to cover so let's keep the
background size to cover
and set the background repeat to no
repeat
let's save the file and look it on our
webpage
now as you can see the image is fully
fit to the webpage
let's add a text above our image to see
how it looks like
so i'll add a paragraph tag
and type some random text here
let's set the text color to red and
align it to center
i'll type p and open the curly braces
i'll set the color to red
and i'll set the text align to center
let's save the file and see how it looks
on a page
as you can see we have a text above our
image which is centrally aligned and the
text color is red
in this tutorial we will learn how we
can add colors to our page using
different methods we will start with
discussing colors and then see the hex
value and rgb format of the colors in
the end we'll do an example to
understand how we can add colors to our
page
css uses the color values to specify the
colors on a page
they can be specified using predefined
color names hex or rgb format they are
nearly 140 standard color names
hexadecimal is a sixth grade
representation of a color the first two
digits are represents a red value the
next two are green value and the last is
the blue value
all the other colors can be created
using the combination of these three
colors
there are several websites available
where you can know the hex value of the
different shades of color
as you can see the black color is
signified by hashtag and the six zeroes
the red is hashtag ff and the four zeros
followed by it
the rgb color value is specified using
the rgb property this property takes
three values one for red green and blue
the value can be the integer between
zero to two twenty five or a percentage
as you can see the black color is
signified by zero zero zero the red by
two fifty five zero zero the blue by
zero zero two fifty five and the green
by 0 to 55 0.
now let's move to an example to
understand how we can add the colors to
our page
in this example we will see how we can
add colors in different ways to our html
so we are on the sublime text editor as
you can see we have the standard wall of
it ready with an h2 and a paragraph on
our page open the style tag and make the
font size of the paragraph to 25 pixels
so it is clearly visible
let's start by adding colors to our text
just by color names html supports nearly
140 standard color names
we'll make the color of the paragraph
green for that
just type color and set the color to
green
as you can see our paragraph is changed
to green
let's try one more
this time we will add the color red
just refresh
as you can see the color is not changed
to red
there are nearly 140 html standard
colors that are supported by the web
browser
you can also add colors using the rgb
format there are many websites available
to know the rgb or hex value of the
desired color one such is html codes.com
as you can see in the htmlpose.com we
have the hex value and rgb value of the
desired color
let's try one
we'll add this color with rgb value 171
229 and 27 to our paragraph so for that
just type rgb and the color code you
want
as you can see the color is not changed
to our rgb value let's try one more
this time we'll use this rgb value to
our text
you can see the color is changed to our
desired value
in this way you can use the rgb format
to change the colors
the next way is using the hex values
excel decimal is the sixth
representation of a color the first two
digits are red next one two are green
and the last are the blue value
let's see how you use the hex values
as you can see the hex value for this
color is hash 31787f
we'll use this value to our text
to add the hex value you have to use the
hashtag followed by the color port
you can see that color is changed to a
hex value let's try one more
you can see the hex value for this color
is hash f14a07
just copy the desired value to your file
you can see the color changes
you can also add color borders to our
heading
do that just mention the border style
along with the color code
we'll add the border color red to our h2
now you can see we have the border
around our h2
i hope you have understand how to use
the color values to your webpage there
are mainly three ways by which you can
add the colors to a webpage they are hex
rgb values and the color names
in this video we will discuss what are
keyframes and how you can use them to
add animations to your page
we are going to discuss what are
keyframes and will try to understand the
syntax of the keyframes so let's get
started
the keyframes are used to specify the
animation code in the page they are used
to change the animation from one pattern
to another
keep in mind that the keyframes do not
have any selectors on them
they are not tested inside anything
they are on the root of the css page you
write at the red keyframes and the name
you can name it anything you want we are
going to use that name later on to call
the selector
in this case we are looking at from and
two from implies the initial state and
to the ending state
here in this example the element will
start from 0 pixel and will go all the
way to 100 pixel so what we are going to
do right now is we are going to jump to
the keyframes and work out some examples
to understand the working of the
keyframes better so we are on the
sublime text later and this is a simple
setup
we have created one html element named
box and we have a css body of padding 50
pixel and the box element has an inline
block
background red with height with 200
pixel
and also i have an animation stack
declared on the box
currently it's doing nothing because it
is calling keyframes called my frames
but we have not yet created any keyframe
we will discuss what this animation line
means at later stage but right now i
need those lines to be able to expose
you to the functioning of the keyframes
you can see we have a box on our page
with the color red
and padding 50 pixels around it
we are going to write add the keyframes
and i am going to use the name my frames
then we will write prompt condition to
have the starting state and lets just
keep the height 200 pixel
and then we want it to grow and we will
set it to increase till 500 pixels so
let's just create our keyframes
this is a from condition
we will set it to 200 pixels
and we want it to grow till 500 pixels
just save the file
now as you can see our box is going all
the way to 500 pixel and when the
animation is done it resets back to 200
pixel and starts again because the
animation is looping you can also put
multiple style declaration for example i
am going to write background pink in the
two condition
just save the file
you can see that the animation is
starting at
red and ending at pink
now instead of saying from and do we can
also say from zero percent to hundred
percent
this is as same as doing from and two
but what it enables you to do is you can
add something in the middle of here say
30 and we will make the color any
different
so in the place of prob we'll write zero
percent
and we'll replace true with hundred
let's just add one more condition in
between say 40
so at 40 percent we want the color to
change to say something uh
green
let's save the file and see how it looks
on the page
so as you can see it starts with red it
turns to green in the middle and then
all the way converts to pink
as you can see there are lots of
interesting things you can do with the
keyframes all of the things that i am
showing you today are just like how this
works
to really get a great understanding of
how it works you just have to open an
editor and start experimenting on it
okay so now let's go back to our code
and learn about animation property
so here we have the animation name my
frames
the animation name should be as same as
keyframes name to work it properly
the animation duration specifies for how
long we want our animation to last in
this case two seconds
let's just change this to say
10 seconds
just save the file
now as you can see the
animation is going at a slower speed
just to cover the 10 seconds update
let's just reset it to 2 seconds
the timing function used to mention the
transition there are some keywords such
as easy and linear easy now and some
more the animation delay is interesting
to understand it means how long we are
going to wait once the animation is
triggered before the visual starts
happening
let's change it to 3 seconds
as you can see the animation starts
after the 3 seconds
iteration count specifies how many times
the animation should happen here we have
set it to infinite
which means animation will keep on going
let's change it to something say 5.
as you can see after the count of five
the animation stops
we'll set it back to infinite
animation running state can be paused or
the running state
in this video we are going to break down
everything there is to know about the
css animation
css animations make it possible to
animate transitions from one css style
configuration to another
animations consist of two components a
style describing the css animation and a
set of keyframes that indicates the
start and end states of the animation
style as well as possible intermediate
now to understand this better i have an
example so let's get started now
so we are on our sublime text editor now
to get started i have a very basic
example with html and css
i have a parent element here
and inside this parent element i have a
div class child
so when you go back to the page it will
look something like this
this pink color is the parent element
and the small box with the red color is
a child element
whenever you hover over the element the
child elements move from left side to
the right side of the parent
we want to talk about animation in case
there are two different ways to animate
one is the css translation property
which works well with only simple
animation
if you want to learn about css
translation property you can refer to
the last video on css translation
there is a full-fledged animation
property which is used for more complex
animation
i am going to show you how you can make
this simple transition into animation
for this example we will make this child
element move all around the box using
animation so let's go back to our code
so just like the translation property we
have the several properties in the css
animation as well this consists of like
timing function fill-in mode and several
other functions in the css animation
so to convert the transition into
animation all we need to do is write the
word animation and you write the
animation where you want it to happen
in our case here is our hover so we
write the animation here and as you
write you will notice that you have more
properties in animation than transition
in general you will write everything in
this animation keyword because it is
easier
you can write it separately as well like
animation delay duration animation name
but
we will use the shorthand property of
the animation
so we'll select the animation
and the first thing the animation needs
is the animation name
so we will give some name to this
animation
say
example
this is just like transition we can
specify our duration
in our case we will use one second
so we have given that
name of the animation
will give the duration we can define a
timing function which will be ease out
this is all the code we need for our
animation
this line is same as writing this
individually
like animation name
[Music]
animation duration one second
and animation timing function
which will be ease out
now let's say ease in
so for the better understanding let's
just remove the shorthand property and
use it individual properties
now just save the file
let's understand briefly what each of
these properties
do
the animation duration property defines
how long time an animation should take
to compete if the animation duration
property is not specified no animation
will occur because the default value is
0 second
the animation timing function property
specifies the speed curve of the
animation
now comes the keyframes keyframes are
used to define the animation name
we come down here and write at the right
keyframes
followed by the name of the animation
the keyframes has to be put outside any
selector
keyframes essentially determine what our
animation looks like between the values
0 and 100
so at our animation
we want to have this translate
so
we'll write 100
and we'll write
transform
translate x
and save the file
now when you save and go back to the
page
you will notice the smooth transition of
the animation
when you hover over
one thing you will notice that as soon
as the animation is over the box goes
back to the original place
the reason for this is all the process
happens inside this keyframe
this one
as soon as the animation is done the
default state kicks in
if we want this to stop in the transform
state like box should be here is on the
right side
we have to specify it in the animation
property we'll set the animation field
mode to forwards so here
we'll set the animation field mode to
forwards
just save
and then when you go back to the
page and refresh
you see the box stops on the right side
and doesn't go back to the original
state
now that you have a basic understanding
of the animation and its different
properties let's work around our main
aim to move this child element all over
the parent element from this to this
side to this side to the side so
here at the keyframes we'll just delete
this
and we'll start with zero percent
so here at the zero percent
we'll set the transform and translate x
to
zero
after that added 33
we want
this box to move down so we'll work on
translate y
so
we'll translate the y two hundred
percent
at sixty six percent
we want both the x axis and y axis to
to move from here to this side
so
we'll set
translate x to hundred percent
and translate
y two hundred percent
and finally at hundred percent
we want to translate x
back to hundred percent on the upward
side
so when you save and refresh
you'll see we have achieved our target
the child elements move all over inside
the parent element
to watch it little bit more slowly let's
change the time here to 3 seconds
when you go back and refresh
you can see the box move little bit
slower
so
with the animation property we can go a
step further we can tell our animation
how many times to repeat the order of
the animation
among other things
so the animation iteration count
property specifies the number of times
an animation should be played
let's set it to 3
so here
we'll set the animation iteration ground
to 3.
the animation direction property defines
whether an animation should be played
forwards backwards or in alternate
cycles
so for the animation direction we set it
to alternate
now if you save and go back
that's one
two
and three after the three count the
animation will stop and you must have
noticed that the box were moving on the
alternate rounds
let's go back to see it again
this is the first cycle now it moves alt
on the other direction
and now on the other direction
so this is for animation you can see
animation property is as
same as a transition property with some
more functions and sub properties you
can add more complex animations to the
page with the help of this animation
property
the css transition property is the
simplest way to add the animation to our
website
and in this video we are going to see
how to use it
so animation is a good way to catch
attention on the page and if done
properly it increases the user
experience the most basic way to animate
something is by transition
according to the mdn definition
transition animals to define the
transition between two states of an
element basically when the state of an
element changes such as over focus or
anything else we can change the css
property through a transition
there are handful of transition
properties let's discuss what they are
and how they work
so
we are on our port pen
i have a box that changes the color on
the hover
the first property that we are going to
start is with the transition duration
property
the transition duration property
specifies how many seconds or
milliseconds a transition effect takes
to complete
so here i can write transition duration
and i can write here a number
take note that here
we can enter time in milliseconds or
seconds i will suggest you to use the
millisecond since javascript does not
accept time in second
so i will enter here 500 milliseconds
now
when you go here and hover over this box
you'll see the color changes from pink
to green in about 500
milliseconds let's
change this to say two seconds
and see the difference
now if you hover this box
you see it takes two seconds to change
the color from pin to green
[Music]
the next one we are going to look is a
transition property the transition
property sets the css properties to
which a transition effect should be
applied
suppose we want to rotate this box when
hovered over
so first we'll specify the transform
property here and we'll set it to rotate
45 degrees
now here we will specify the transition
property and set it to transform
now if you hover over this box you see
it takes about 500 milliseconds for the
box to return to 45 degrees while the
color changes instantly
suppose we set it here to two seconds
and save
now you will notice the box will take to
about 2 seconds to rotate 245 degrees
while the color will change instantly
you can see the difference here
now the next property is transition
timing function
the transition timing function property
specifies the speed curve of the
transition effect
the default value is ease
ease means it specifies the transition
effect with a slot start and then fast
and then ends slowly
suppose here
we set the transition
timing function
to eve
there are four major values for this
timing function they are is linear ease
in and ease out
let's see one by one in detail
so
the linear function specify the
transition effect with the same speed
from start to end
so if we change here to linear
you will see that it rotates with the
same speed from start to end
now if we change this to ezen
the easiest specify the transition
effect with a slow start so now if you
hover over this
you see the box rotates the slow start
and then increases the speed at the end
the ease out specify the transition
effect with a slow end
so if you set it to ease out
you'll see at the end the speed
decreases
the last property we are going to
discuss is a transition delay the
transition delay property specifies when
the transition effect will start
the transition delay value is defined in
milliseconds or in seconds
let's set the transition
delay to two seconds
and just remove this
now if you hover over this box you will
see it will take two seconds to rotate
the box to 45 degrees
so you can see after the two seconds the
transition property takes place
now if we change here
to background
you see the box will rotate instantly
while the color will changes from pink
to green after two seconds
so
this is a transition property
is it as simple as it can be
in this video you will learn how to add
interactive hover effects to your
element
we will do an example where we'll create
hover effects to our buttons so in this
tutorial we will discuss what is the css
hover effects and then we will do an
example to understand it better
so what is the css over effect
a css hover effect is a style technique
where the user interacts with an element
to the pointing device but it is not
necessarily activates it
it is triggered when the user hovers
over an element with a pointing device
now let's jump to an example
in this example we will create the hover
effect which will look something like
this
we have different hover effects for all
the buttons
so let's get started and see how you can
make this all by yourself
so we are on the sublime text later
create two new files index.html and
style.css where we will write our html
and css code respectively
start by linking the css file with the
html file
now we will add four anchor tags we will
specify the class name for each of them
so that we can style them separately
later
put all the anchor tag inside the div
tag and name the class
middle
we'll name the class btn btn1 btn btn2
btm btmc and btn btn4
just copy paste it four times
save the file and let's see how it looks
on a page right now
as you can see we have the pro text on
our page
with this we are done with our html part
now let's shift to css and design the
text and add the hover effects
so in css we'll start by setting the
margin and padding to zero we also add
the background body color
as you can see the margin and padding is
now zero and we have a good background
color
now we will design the buttons and give
them proper formatting we will start
with the class middle
set the position to absolute
the top property affects the vertical
position of a positioned element the
left property affects the horizontal
position of a coefficient element the
transform property applies a 2d or 3d
transformation to an element this
property allows you to rotate scale and
move the elements
as you can see the elements are now in
place
now let's format the buttons
set the position to relative
display block
will keep the color as white
font size 25 pixels
we will use the font family as monty
thread
keep the text decoration to none
we will set the border to true pixel and
solid
we keep the text transformation repeat
we'll keep the text transformation as
upper case
transition allows you to change the
property values smoothly over a given
duration
the before selector is used to insert
something before the content of each
selected element
keep the position to absolute
we'll keep the transition as all 0.6
second and eve
let's save the file and see how it looks
on a page
now as you can see all the elements are
in place with proper background and text
we have the padding and border properly
formatted and now we can add the hover
effects to this button
now we'll add the hover effects to the
first button
as you can see we have the hover effect
on our first button ready
in a similar manner we can add the
effects to the second and third button
as well
we'll just copy and paste this above
code below and make changes to this code
we'll set the width to 100 here
and height to zero
we'll change it to height hundred
percent
just save the file and
refresh the page
as you can see both the buttons have the
whole effects now
now it's time to add the hover effect to
our third button
i will add the hover effect to the
button third
just save the file and go to the page
as you can see all the three buttons are
ready
now it's time to add the hover effect to
the close button
we'll set the color to hash ff
this will change the text color to red
when we hover over the fourth button
set the position to absolute
keep the weight as two hundred percent
we'll set the background to hash
dcd159 we'll keep the z-index as -1
keep the transition to 0.8 seconds
you
set the height to 180
percent of the page
now to add the over effect
write the following code
just save the file
refresh
now you can see we have all the hover
effects on our 4 button
as you know the asset animations is a
powerful concept that is used to make
your web page engaging and attracting
visitors to your website
they make the user experience smooth and
entertaining so in this video
we are going to learn how to create some
cool css effects using just html and css
so without further wasting any time
let's jump to our sublime text editor so
we are on our sublime text later
for our example purpose i have used one
image from an unsplash.com and we have
created a simple class div clock
container for it
now
let's go and style these images to get a
3d effect so first let's design the body
part
we'll set the margin and padding to 0
pixels
we'll set the width to 100
and we'll set the height to 100 vertical
heights
we'll keep the display as flex
and we'll align the items in the center
and we'll justify the content in the
center as well
now we'll design our container class
so for the container class we'll set the
position to relative
we'll set the width to 360 pixels
and we'll keep the height to 640 pixels
we'll set the margin top
to 150 pixels
and we'll keep the
background to white
we'll use the rgba format
we'll use the transform property to
apply a 2d or 3d transformation to an
element
so
we'll use that transform and we'll
use it its properties will keep this to
degrees
we'll set this q to
say 25 degrees
and we'll scale it to 0.8
let's discuss more about these
properties
so
the translator defines a 2d or 3d
translation the scale defines the 2d or
3d scale transformation
and the skew property is used to skew
transformation along the x or y axis
now let's design the images
we'll keep the position to absolute
we'll set the width to 100 percent
and will keep the transition time
to 0.5 seconds
let's go back to our page and see how it
looks up to this point
so as you can see we have the images
aligned as we want
on a flat side
now we'll create the 3d transformation
when we hover over it
so let's go back to our css file
so for the 3d effect we are going to use
the edge child property
the n-style selector allows you to take
a single argument that describes the
pattern for the matching element indices
in a list of siblings
we design the eat image separately so
for the fourth image
we'll use the transform property and
we'll translate it to 160 pixels and
minus 160 pixels
let's copy this code
four times
okay we have to set the opacity as well
so we'll set the opacity here
to 1.
the opacity property sets the
transparency of the element
just change the number of the nth child
elements so here we'll keep it to 120
pixels
minus 120 pixel will set the opacity
to 0.8
for the second element let's keep the
translate to 80 pixels
minus 80 pixels and we'll set the
opacity
to say 0.6
and for the last image
will translate it to 40 pixels
and minus 40 pixels and we'll keep the
opacity
to say 0.4
so now when you save the file and you
will go back to the page
let's see how it looks
so if you refresh and hover over it now
you can see the image has a 3d over
effect over it
there are four layers to the image and
we have
designed the opacity according to the
image layer
so this is a 3d image hover
the next property we are going to
discuss is a 3d perspective image
so for this let's use a new set of
images
so we'll go back to the unsplash.com
again
and let's select one image
this one looks beautiful
so let's copy the image address
and mention it
under the image tag
just save
[Music]
now when you go back to the page
you'll see you have your image here
now let's add the 3d perspective image
design over it
so under css file let's first design all
the elements
let's keep the margin and padding to
zero
let's keep the
width of the container elements 200
pixels
or say 100
let's keep the minimum height
to save 100 vertical heights
and we'll use a background color of hash
let's design the image as well before
going back to the page
so we'll set the perspective to save
4000 pixels
the perspective property is used to
determine the distance between the z
plane and the user in order to give a 3d
positioned element some perspective
let's keep the width of the image 70
we keep the position to absolute
keep the left margin to 50
and drop to 50 as well
we'll use the transform property
and use that translate value of it to
minus 50 percent and plus 50 percent
we'll use the transform style property
and set the value to preserve 3d
the preset 3d indicates that the
children of the element should be
positioned in the 3d space
so just save the file and let's go back
to the page to see how it looks up to
this point
so as you can see we have the required
background image and we have the image
in a required position
now it's time to style our image
so use the transform property
and we'll rotate
we'll use the rotate x property of it
we'll keep it to 70 degrees
let's discuss this property translate 3d
the translate 3d css function deposits
an element in the 3d splits
it results in the transform function
data type
the transformation is characterized by
three-dimensional vector it coordinates
how much the element moves in each
direction
let's set the box shadow
minus 80 pixels
60 pixels
15 pixels
sells an rgba value 2
0 0 0
0.4 let's say
let's set the transition to all point
four seconds
and we'll set the transform style to
preserve 3d
so just save the file and let's go back
to our page to see how it looks up to
this point
so as you can see the image is flat for
and ready for 3d effect
now let's design the 3d hover effect on
it
so for the 3d over effect
we'll use the
cover property image
colon hover
over the image
we'll set the transform
rotate x
zero degrees
rotate flat
to zero degrees
and translate 3d to
zero pixels comma
zero pixel comma zero pixels
let's check this once again
this is right
now we'll set the box shadow to
zero pixels zero pixels zero pixels
zero pixels and rgba
zero comma zero comma zero from zero
just save the file
and refresh
now when you hover over it you will see
that the perspective of the image
changes
so this is a 3d perspective image
now
there are many css effects that you can
design using these properties
in this video you will learn what is
navigation bar and its importance on a
web page
you will also learn how to create a
basic navbar using html and css
so let's start by discussing the agenda
for this tutorial
we will start with what is navigation
bar and why navigation bar is required
in a web page
you will look at some of the well
designed navigation bars on websites
after that you will work on the code to
create the basic navigation bar using
html and css
so let us begin by discussing what is
navigation bar
a navigation bar is a graphical user
interface intended to aid the user in
accessing the information
it is usually placed at the top of the
page a navigation bar needs standard
html as the base
navigation bar can be created either
vertically or horizontally
so what makes a navigation bar so
important a navigation bar is an
important element of website design
since it allows users to quickly visit
any sections within the website
if we have ever visited a website
without a navigation bar you may have
found it difficult to locate the page
you need
you may have also had to click back
several times in order to find a link to
the next section you wanted to visit
thankfully web design has become more
standardized in the recent years and
nearly every websites now include a
navigation bar keep in mind that you
want to keep people on your site to
explore further a well-designed
navigation bar is an important part of
the user experience now let us look at
an example of a navigation bar on a
website
we are on the homepage of amazon website
as you can see this is the navigation
bar that has several elements on it
as the user clicks on these elements
they will be directed to the different
sections of the website the navigation
bar allows the user to easily move
through any section of the website
by clicking on the best sellers button
you will be redirected to the best
sellers page on the amazon
now we are going to create a navigation
bar with html in css that's going to
look like this
we'll have the following sections with
sub menus and some of them
make sure you have a text editor to
write the code
i will be using a sublime text later for
this purpose we will create two new
files index.html and style.css where we
will be writing on html and css code
respectively
let's start by adding the standard wall
update
keep the title as css nav bar
link your css file with the html file by
using the link tag and htf attribute
this navigation bar is going to consist
of a bunch of ul tags which means and
another list and list items
let's create our first another list and
this will be our main menu of the
navigation bar
i have options such as home about
contact services and news so this is
going to be our main menu
save the file let's see what it looks
like right now by opening it inside our
browser
you can see it is just an unordered list
with no menu at this point let's go
ahead and add our sub menus home will
not have any sub menus but the about
list item is going to have a sub menu
add another ui tag inside the ally tag
this will create a sub menu inside the
about item save the file
just copy paste it and paste it inside
the ul tag
name them as team
clients
careers and legacy
just make the indentation properly
if you see this in a browser you will
see that we'll have
the sub menus inside the above let's do
the same thing for contacts just copy
paste this whole section and place them
inside the contacts list rename them
according to your wish and save the file
if you go back to the browser
you will see that will have the submenus
inside the contacts as well
as you can see this is our complete
submenus without the styling all the
html content is ready now we are going
to write the css for it in the css file
let's apply the background image first
because it will make the page look a
little bit nicer
i have my file on my computer make sure
the image file is in the same folder as
your html and css file
i am using attack.jpg
and for the background size i will set
it to the cover which is going to adjust
it to the image screen and it's going to
cover the whole background of our web
browser
keep the font family as arial
let's see what it looks like at this
stage you can see we have a background
image and the font is changed to arial
now let's make sure our unordered list
does not have any margins or padding by
setting it to zero
also put the list style to then because
we don't want to have any kind of
bullets under our listing
now unordered list list items they are
the main items that are going to apply
the style to the list items of the main
url tag
float that all the text to the left
and set the given formatting
we will set the background color with
the hash value 003542
you can choose your own value from our
website known as colorpicker.com
we will fix the line height to 40 pixels
this will center the text vertically
text align to center
this will align the text horizontally
and font size to 20 pixel
font size 20 pixels
let's see what it looks like now you can
see the text is floated to the left
now let's tell the actual menu link so
the menu link will be ullia
ullia
the text decoration
to none and color white
keep the display as block
now it's time to set the hover effect of
our arri the urli hover will set the
formatting when the user hovers over the
menu
we will use the background color of the
hash value de1 fcb
save the file and let's see what our
page looks like up to this point
you can see we have the hover effect
over our menus and we have the sub menus
under the main menu we want our sub menu
should be visible only when we hover our
menus so we will set the uli to display
none and we will set the hover effect to
the block
let's save the file and see what our
page looks like up to this point
now you can see
our navigation bar is ready
with all the sub menus and menus at
proper places we have this nice over
effect over the menus
in this video we will discuss some cool
tricks that every web developer should
be familiar with and which will help you
during the time of your designing of a
webpage so let's jump onto the sublime
text editor and see these tricks so
the first trick is called the css blend
mode the css background blend property
set the blend mode for each background
layer and you can blend it with image or
with different colors with the help of
this property we can blend background
image or blend them with colors
so
here's an example of the css blend mode
here you can see the images are blended
with different colors
so let's see how we can achieve this
so for our example purpose i am going to
use this image
to our page
in the body tag add the image url
and the location of a file
keep the margin left and margin right to
auto
now let's add some style to our body tag
in the blend mode there are several
modes such as normal multiply darker and
lighter or screen
let's blend that image with
one color
so you can select the color from this
html color codes i use this color for my
purpose
so just copy paste here
and in the background blend mode let's
keep it to lighten
now if you save
and then refresh here
you can see we have blended our image
with color
let's go back and change here something
different
let's keep it to darken
let's try something different
let's keep it to screen
so as you can see there are several
properties for this blend mode and you
can use according to your needs the next
trick is called clipping the css
clipboard property creates a clipping
region that specifies the region that
should be shown on the page
so let's understand this with the help
of an example
here we'll create a div
and give this class any class say tr the
easiest way to generate the clip value
is to use a generator
there are several websites that give the
value of the clip
so we'll use this
website to generate a clip value
suppose we want a hexagon shaped
image on our page
so here you can
adjust it according to your needs
any shape that you want
here you can see the clip value just
copy paste it from here
now here we'll use that class that we
are specified
we'll just copy paste the clip value
here
we'll keep the height to say
or let's say 60 percent
set the width to sixty percent as well
select the color you want to give to
clipped image i'll use the same color
from the previous example
so just copy paste this color code
keep the position to absolute
and the z index to minus 1
just save and go back to the page and
refresh
now you can see we have the clipped
image on our page let's try something
different
let's say i want
a left arrow
so just copy paste this
clip
value clip path value
[Music]
just save the file
and you can see we have the arrow on our
page
another must have for web developers is
animations
css allows us to animate almost every
property that we use in the css
let's look at one example
so here an html file we'll just add one
div tag first
and to start with animation we'll have
to mention a keyframe the keyframes
allows us to create different steps for
our animations
we'll keep the keyframes name to blink
so here in this example we'll create a
box and we'll add different colors at
different points of animations right so
we'll write zero percent and we'll set
the background
to indigo
we'll change the colors five times so
just copy paste this code five times
we want next change at 30 so we'll set
the background here
suppose say red
at 50 we wanted yellow
at 70 we wanted green
and finally we will change it to say
blue
so inside the div tag we'll mention the
height and width of the box first let's
say 400 pixels and width also 400 pixels
now i will mention the
border of the box so just set it to say
one pixel
solid black
now for the animations part
we'll set the animation for 10 seconds
and for infinite number of times
write this webkit so as to support in
our google chrome
now just save the file and go back to
our page
and here you can see we have the
animation on our box
you can style each and every element in
html using animations
another thing you can do is add css
gradient
the css gradient property allows you to
add smooth transitions between two or
more colors
for this purpose you can get the
gradient value from a website called css
gradient.io
here in this website
you can get the mix and match of the
different colors you want to use
let's look at one example to understand
better
so here in this html file first let's
set the height
so we'll set the height to 100 percent
now inside the body tag
we'll keep the height as hundred percent
we'll mention when background color
let's select different color this time
so we will use save this color
this time
just copy paste the value here
now for the gradient value just go back
here in this website and you can select
the color you want
let's say i want a mix of this color
and
you can change the shades from here
now when you're done with the colors
just go back below
and copy this
code here
to your page
now when you go back to the page you
will have a beautiful gradient here
let's try one more
this time a linear gradient
just copy this value to your code
just save the file and go back to the
page
and you will have a linear gradient here
in this video we are going to learn some
of the more advanced features that can
be used to optimize your web page and
add some extra features to it
so let's get started so the first
function we are going to discuss is css
sudo class a css sudo class is a keyword
added to a selector that specify the
special state of the selected elements
sudo class lets you apply a style to an
element not only in relation to the
content of the documentary but also in
relation to external factors like
history of the navigator the status of
its content or the position of the mouse
like hover which lets you know if the
mouse is over an element or not
so the first pseudo class we are going
to discuss is css hover
this sudo class is used to add a special
effect to an element when our mouse
pointer is over it
let's work an example to understand how
this works
so we are on our sublime text editor and
we have added a standard wall update to
it
so first i'll create a box element
we get the div class box
let's save this and see right now what
is the status of our page
so as you can see we have this simply
learn tag and the heading that we have
given and the color changes when you
hover over me
now add a style tag to define the
styling of the box
so
we'll keep the background color of the
box as
pen
we'll keep the width to 300 pixels
and height to 200 pixels
we'll set the margin to auto
let's keep the font size to 40 pixels so
that we can see the text clearly
and we'll align the text to the center
just save and go back to the page
now you can see we have this box
with the tag the color changes when you
hover over me
now to add the hover effect
you just have to mention the class
with semicolon and hover so we'll
mention the class box
with a semicolon and hover
we'll mention the background color to
which the box will change when we hover
our mouse
so we'll keep the background color to
say a sand color
just save and go back to the page
so if you refresh and when you hover
over it you can see the color changes
so
this is how the sudo hover class works
the next video class we are going to
discuss is an active pseudo class
the active sudo class represents an
element that has been activated by the
user either by pointing a device or by
touchscreen device
let's work on an example to understand
how to use the active class to change
the color of active elements the
possible values could be any color name
in any valid format
so we'll use the same example with some
minor changes
first
let's change this text here
we'll keep it to click here
to see the effects
we keep this part as same and instead of
over air we will use the active pseudo
class so
we type active and we'll keep the
background clear to cyan
let's text align this h1 to the center
when you refresh and go back
so you see here it is click here to see
the effects now
to see the difference now you can see
when we are hovering over it the color
does not change it instead of it when we
click on it the color changes
so
this is how the active hover class works
the next advanced property we are going
to discuss is a css pseudo element
a css pseudo element is a keyword added
to a selector that lets you style a
specific part of the selected element
you can use one sudo class element in a
selector
it must appear after the simple
selectors in the statement
as a rule double column should be used
instead of a single column this
distinguishes the pseudo classes from
the pseudo element so the first pseudo
element we are going to discuss is the
first letter pseudo element this pseudo
element applies tie to the first letter
of the first line of the block level
element
let's work out an example to understand
this better
just delete everything
so let's add some content to the body
and we'll add an h1
which says welcome
to simply learn
and we'll add an h2
which says
this is an example
of
first
letter
sudo element
let's add a style tag
we
align the text in the body to the center
so we'll use text align
center
let's just give proper spacing here
now to this h1
tag we'll add the first letter sudo so
to add the first letter sudo element
just use the double column and type
first
letter
we'll keep the font family of the first
letter assay lucida
calligraphy
there's a spelling mistake
we will keep the font size to 3
centimeters
we'll keep the color to red
and just add a text shadow
for better animation
so we'll keep the text shadow to 5
pixels
8 pixels
9 pixels and color cn
now when you save and go back
just refresh
so this wc is a first letter sudo
element
as you can see we have changed this
first letter with the proper shadowing
of a cn color and a different font size
so this is how the first letters
pseudo element works
the next one we are going to discuss is
the before pseudo element
the before sudo element can be used to
insert some content before the content
of an element
let's work out an example
so just add the standard water plate
inside the body
let's add
welcome to simply learn
we'll add the text inside the queue tag
the queue tag defines a short quotation
so inside the queue tag
we'll add welcome
tag closed
now that we have the text inside the
body let's add the styling
so we'll keep the font size to of all
the
text to 30 pixels
this is the all selector we have used
font size 30 pixels
now before the text we are going to add
some symbols so we'll use double column
q before
will add the content with sun symbol
like this
will keep the color of this
symbol to blue
and we'll use the after sudo class to
add the content
like this
we'll keep this color to red
now that we have everything in place
let's go back to see how it looks
you can see the symbols before and after
our text so this is how the before
studio element works
so the next function we are going to
discuss is css loader
the css loader is an animation that
shows the wizard about the page when it
is loading it is helpful when a page
takes some seconds to load the page
content it is similar to the buffer sign
so let's see how to create a
loader
so i hope you remember the concept of
the keyframes and animations
if you want to revise the concepts you
can watch the previous videos on the
keyframes and animations from the
playlist
so
let's create the loader
we have the standard wall upgrade
so inside the body tag just add the
center tag and inside it
will add one h1 which says
welcome to simply learn
we'll add
five div tags with the class a1 a2 a3 a4
and a5
just copy paste it five times
so this is a one a two a3 a4
and a5
let's open our style tag
inside our style tag we'll first add
color to our h1
so
let's keep the color
of our h1 to orange
now comes the div tag
so for the div tags
we'll keep the display to block
uh keep the position to absolute
we set the width and height to 10 pixels
each so width 10 pixels
and height 10 pixels
we'll use the cat function to determine
the left margin so to use the calc
function to add clc
fifty percent
and minus one em
the calc function performs a calculation
to be used as a property value
we'll keep the border radius to say 1.3
em
em is related to the font size of the
element
1.3 em means 1.3 times the size of the
current font
we'll use the transform origin function
with the value one point three em
and two year
the transfer margin property allows you
to change the position of the
transformed elements
2d transformations can change the x and
y axis
keep the animation
to rotate
i will keep the animation iteration
count
infinite
i will keep the animation duration to
two seconds
let's save and go back to the page to
see how it looks at this point
so as you can see we have our heading
and
you cannot see it but we have a loader
ready and we just have to add some
keyframes and animations here
so
let's define
keyframes
with the name of the animation rotate
so at zero percent
we use the transform function to rotate
it to
zero degrees
just copy copy this
at hundred percent when it's complete
it'll rotate to the complete 360 degrees
so here we give the value 360 degrees
now let's design each of the
classes here that we have defined
so
dot a1
the animation delay
will be of 0.1 seconds
so for each of the classes that we have
here we have to define them with a
different color
so that when the loader appears we can
see them clearly with the different
colors so
for this
a1 let's keep the background color to
say san
just copy paste it
so that we don't have to write down code
again and again
three
four
and five
let's make changes here
so for the a2
we want it
to appear after 0.2 seconds
with the color pink
let's keep this to 0.3 seconds
the color purple
black
we have kept the animation delay to so
close like 0.1 seconds 0.2 seconds 0.3
seconds so that the
loader appears in a complete sync with
each other
so just save the file and refresh and go
back to the page
now you can see this is the loader we
have our heading and
this is like a buffer
and it will show when you have some
content to load
in this tutorial we are going to discuss
what is responsive design and how we can
achieve this using the css media queries
so let's get started making a website
with an adaptable layout is called a
responsive web design
and css media quiz are one of the most
important part for responsive design
in the past building a website was much
simpler today a website layout should
adapt itself not only to computers but
also to tablets mobile devices and even
tvs
so
let's see how we can create a responsive
web layout using css media case with the
help of an example so here we are
sublime text writer we haven't our
standard wallet ready so let's create
something
so let's start by creating the four days
here
we'll give it a class name box
with an id box one
we'll name this windows
just copy it 4 times
let's rename this id to box to and here
we'll type
macos for the box three will have
linen and the box four
will have android
let's add some styling over here
so just open the style tag
i will text align the text keys we'll
set the text align to center
uh we'll set the background color
let's select some color
so we'll go to this html color code
choose a good color
we'll set the text color to white
and we'll set the font size to say
something to pixels
and just save the file let's go back to
refresh the page
so after you refresh you see we have our
lives with windows mac os linux and
android and with this background color
so
to design the responsive web pages use
the media queries
so what are media queries let's first
discuss this
so a media queries are used when you
want to customize the website's
presentation according to the user's
screen size with the help of the media
queries you can display different
markups based on the device's general
type mobile desktop sub tablet you name
it
a media code is a logical operation
whenever a media query becomes true then
the related ps is applied to the target
element
so
to start the media query just type at
the rate
and media
now here we'll mention the max weight
to save 400 pixels
and inside this media query we write the
css code that should
take an effect when this condition is
satisfied
so here
we'll set the box one
to display block
now
if you go back to the page and you
refresh
you see nothing happens because we have
not made this display to none so first
go back to the css code
and set display to none
now you can see we don't have any
display here so let's inspect the page
first
so you'll see we have our contents here
now you can see this is the
layout we are currently using the
current weight is 685 pixels into high
256 255 pixels
now we are setting the max width to 400
pixels this means if this bit decreases
to less than 400 pixels how this css
code will kick in so let's decrease the
width layer
so as you decrease
this width
you see as soon as you get less than 400
pixels our css kicks in so we have our
windows displayed here which is
the box id1 so this is how the media
query works
let's add some more media queries to
understand it better so let's copy this
code down
so now let's set this minimum width
to
401 pixels
and maximum to say 600 pixels
now when this condition is true let's
say we want our box to
to display block
with color
green
so let's set the background color here
to let's
say green
now
we'll add one more media query
so just copy this code
[Music]
paste it here
so when the bit is from 601 pixels to
say
pixels
so we'll set the box 3 display
to block and color
to
shipping
so
just save this and let's understand it
on the page
so
let's
change the width of the screen
so see as soon as the width goes less
than 400 pixels we have our windows on
display
now when we increase the width size and
it goes more than 401 pixels we have the
mac os display
keep on increasing it
now see the width is more than 600
pixels and we have linux on display so
this is how we create the responsive web
design for the different devices in this
session we're going to cover the topic
of what is angular
i'm sure all of you use mobile and web
applications be it from social media to
health care e-commerce and net banking
these apps are used by billions of
people across the globe now the main
reason we use these apps is that they
offer seamless user experience and
interface but how are they developed to
provide such reliability one of the
frameworks that is widely used to build
such robust apps is angular so let's
dive into the session now so here is a
list of topics that we're going to be
covering
first up we'll see why angular was
introduced
then what is angular
features of angular
angular architecture
advantages and limitations of angular
the learning curve of angular and
finally we'll look at some of the
companies that deploy angular so without
further delay let's begin
why angular now javascript is the most
commonly used client-side scripting
language it is written into html
documents enabling interactions with web
pages in many unique ways
so as a relatively easy to learn
language with almost pervasive support
it is exceptionally well suited to
develop modern applications but the
question arises
is javascript ideal for developing
single page applications that require
modularity testability and other
features perhaps not however we have a
variety of frameworks and libraries
designed to help us with such things
with respect to front-end development
angular and javascript together bring in
structure and consistency to your web
applications and also provides
scalability and maintainability
angular is specifically developed for
single page applications so now the
question arises what exactly is angular
angular is an open source javascript
framework written completely in
typescript
now it was primarily aimed to develop
single page applications and is
maintained by google
angular as a framework provides a few
advantages while also providing a
standard structure for developers it is
designed for web desktop and mobile
platforms if you have a doubt here as to
what exactly single page applications
are let me help you with that now these
single page applications are basically
applications that get loaded just once
so the main page gets loaded onto your
browser so any further interactions does
not lead to loading of subsequent pages
anything that has to be done further is
just an addition to the already loaded
page so these single page applications
are primarily developed using angular
moving ahead let's look at the features
of angular
we have four features that we're going
to be discussing
we have the document object model type
script data binding and testing now
let's look at them one by one now the
document object model treats an xml or
an html document as a tree structure
now here every node in the tree
structure defines an object representing
a part of your document
angular uses the regular dom now let's
suppose you've made 10 updates on a
single html page
so every time you make a change the
corresponding dom or the tree structure
needs to be updated
now angular updates the entire tree
structure of html tags
moving on to our next feature
we have typescript
now typescript defines a set of types to
javascript which helps you write
javascript that is easier to understand
now all the typescript code compiles
down to basic javascript that can run
smoothly on any platform now typescript
is not mandatory for developing an
angular application but it is highly
recommended the main reason it's highly
recommended is that it offers better
syntactic structure while making the
code base easier to understand and
maintain now typescript can be installed
as an npm package now to do that you
just have to run the command npm install
hyphen g type script on your command
prompt next up is data binding now data
binding is a process that allows you to
manipulate web page elements using the
web browser now it mainly employs
dynamic html and does not require
complex scripting or programming
it is used in web pages that include
interactive components like calculators
tutorials games etc now incremental
display of a web page makes data binding
extremely convenient when pages contain
a large amount of data when it comes to
angular it uses two-way data binding so
any changes needing the ui element is
reflected in the corresponding model
state
and conversely any changes made in the
model state are reflected onto the ui
state
this allows the framework to connect the
tom to the model data via the controller
the last feature we're discussing is
testing
angular uses jasmine to run its various
tests the jasmine framework allows
various functionalities to write
different kinds of test cases
karma is a task runner for the tests
that use a configuration file to set the
startup reporters and testing framework
so with that we've covered the features
of angular
so let's go ahead and understand
the architecture of angular
angular is a full-fledged mvc framework
it provides a strong opinion on how the
application should be structured and
offers bi-directional data flow and
updates the real dom mvc short for model
view controller is an architectural
pattern that separates the application
layer into model view and controller the
model here relates to all the data
related logic view on the other hand is
used for ui logic of the application
and controller is the brain of the setup
now it is an interface between the model
and view
moving on let's look at the advantages
of angular
first up we have custom components
angular allows you to build your own
components that can pack functionality
along with rendering logic into reusable
pieces
data binding as discussed
angular allows you to effortlessly move
your data from your javascript code to
the view and react to user events
without having to write any code
yourself
dependency injection angular allows you
to write modular services and have them
injected wherever they are needed
this greatly improves the testability
and reusability of the same don't worry
if you can't wrap your head around these
topics we're going to discuss them
further in the coming videos
next advantage is testing angular has
been built from the ground up with
testability in mind
you can literally test every part of
your application
comprehensive angular is a full-fledged
framework and provides out-of-the-box
solutions for server communication
routing and more
lastly we have excellent browser
compatibility angular is cross platform
and browser compatible an angular
application can typically run on all
browsers
beat chrome firefox safari and platforms
like windows mac os and linux
now many versions of angular have been
released ever since its inception all of
these versions have added to the
efficient working of the framework now
here are two different versions released
first up was angular 1. it was built on
javascript and completely based on
controllers next release was angular 2.
now this incorporated the component
based approach wherein the entire ui was
divided into several components and
lastly integrated to give the final
logic
next was angular 4 it included router
updation angular cli or command line
interface 1.0 was introduced however not
deployed
in this release the angular cli was
optimized and commands like ng update
and ng add were added
in the angular 7 release prompts were
introduced which provided tips in cli
about the functions being used
in angular 8 iv renderer and bazel were
introduced
and finally the most recent release was
angular 9. now this came with the better
framework and angular material now this
completely switched to the iv renderer
as a default compiler now that we've
learnt about the pros of using angular
let's look at some of the limitations of
angular
first up is a sleep learning curve now
since angular is a complete full-fledged
framework it becomes difficult for
learners to begin with
you need to be acquainted with simple
topics and then move on to more advanced
topics to become proficient in this
language
next up is limited seo options
now angular offers limited seo options
and poor accessibility to search engine
crawlers
it's verbose and complex
now a common issue faced by the angular
community is the verbosity of the
framework
it also poses to be complex compared to
other front-end tools
and lastly migration now one of the
drawbacks of angular is poor migration
now it becomes difficult to port legacy
code to angular style architecture
also with each new release it is painful
to upgrade and a lot of them are not
backward compatible
next up let's look at the angular
learning curve
now if you wish to learn angular you
need to be acquainted with basic topics
in angular
some of them are directives
modules declarators components services
dependency injection
pipes and templates
now once you've mastered your basics you
will want to go and understand more
advanced topics such as change detection
zones aot compilation and rx.js
however the learning curve of angular is
clear-cut
in the beginning it could be a little
intimidating but once you start using
the tool it becomes way more easier to
comprehend and understand what is going
on
and lastly let's look at some of the
companies that use angular today
many top tier companies like nike
forbes google hbo sony upwork among
others readily deploy angular so moving
on let's look at the prerequisites for
angular
first up we have nodejs angular uses
node.js as its base for a large part of
its build environment
so as a result to get started with
angular you will need to have node.js
installed on your environment so head to
their official website and download the
latest release for your corresponding
operating system
next up is the angular cli now this
command line interface is a tool that
makes it easier to bootstrap and develop
your angular applications now to install
the latest version run the command npm
install hyphen g
at angular
front slash cli you got to run this
command on your command prompt
and finally to confirm installation
check for its version
now the next thing that you will need is
an ide or a text editor to type your
code now there are several ides that you
can choose from but in this series we've
used vs code throughout so it is
available on all platforms so go ahead
and download it if you haven't already
now moving on to the final part is the
demo now that you have a basic
understanding of angular and its
prerequisites i think you're ready to
create your first angular application so
let's head to our vs code and begin
here i've created a folder called
angular on my desktop and opened it on
my visual studio code so to create your
app you need to open the terminal just
go here and
select new terminal
and now type in the command
ng
new
and provide the name for your app
so i'm just going to say hello world
so now this is going to create
just say yes
so basically what happens is that when
you run the command it will
automatically generate a skeleton
application under the folder that is
hello world in our case
and it includes a bunch of files and
installs all the necessary dependencies
for the angular application
so this could take a while
so once you've created your application
to run it first change the directory so
let's say cd
hello world
and now use the command ng serve
now once it's compiled you need to go to
your browser and type in localhost 4200
and once you do that
you can see your ui
you can see that the application has
been loaded onto your browser
and it says hello world app is running
so this is how you create your
application
so let's go back to our vs code now as
you can see here
there are many files and folders that
are created right so let's look at a few
of them of course we can't explain
everything but i'll rush through a few
of them
so the first main component is basically
the root component now the root
component here is the index.html
so here if you open the file and see
it's a very small crisp code right but
the most important thing in the file
is this app root element
so what this does is it's basically the
marker for loading your application code
so this is extremely important so the
next important file is the main.ts now
this is a part of the bootstrapping
piece all right so the index.html file
is responsible for deciding which files
are to be loaded correct the main.ts
file on the other hand identifies which
angular module is to be loaded when the
application starts so this is just a
brief explanation as to what they are
doing
next we have the app folder now here we
have the
app.module.ts file now this application
module file can be thought of as the
code configuration of your application
so here's where the source code starts
from and moving on we have the
app.component.ts so these are all
typescript files hence the extension ts
now this file basically is a root
component of your application
and then we have the html file for the
same which defines the appearance of
what you can see on your browser so let
me just change the message that is being
displayed
so i'll say hey
welcome to this
angular
tutorial so let's save this
and when we go back to our browser
we can see the message hey welcome to
this angular tutorial being displayed
so like this we can make a simple change
and then it gets rendered onto your
browser so this was just a brief
explanation of what happens in the
background of your application first
we'll get acquainted to what exactly
angular components are
then i'll help you create an angular
component by showing a quick demo and
lastly we'll learn about component
decorator metadata but before we begin
make sure to subscribe to our channel if
you love watching new and interesting
technology videos also hit the bell icon
to never miss an update so what exactly
are angular components
now i'm sure everybody uses web
applications and one of the most widely
used applications is gmail correct now
to help you understand what components
are consider them as lego blocks now
they basically are combined together to
form the final application
so in this case here we have the logo
component then you have a sign in
component
an image component and then a create
account component now all of these
components generally don't affect the
working of each other
but however when embedded they define
the ui of your application
so i hope you understood what components
are
so to go ahead let's discuss some of its
common features now firstly they are the
building blocks of an application
generally you have a root component
which is basically the app component and
then it branches out into other
components creating a hierarchy
and these components are a subset of
directives now don't worry about what
deductives are because we'll cover them
later on in the series but to give you
an idea there are three types of
directives you have the structural
directives the attribute directives and
the component directives
only one component can be instantiated
per element in a template now components
are typically custom html elements and
each of these elements can instantiate
only one component
now don't worry you'll understand this
better when i show you the demo
nextly a typescript class is used to
create a component now this class is
then decorated with the at component
decorator now the decorator accepts a
metadata object that gives information
about the component now a component must
belong to the ng module in order for it
to be usable by another component or
application
and finally components control their
runtime behavior by implementing life
cycle hooks
so this was just a brief introduction to
what angular components are
now you will only be able to understand
the working of components when i show it
to you practically so let's head over to
a visual studio code
now here back in my vs code i've created
a folder called angulardemo within which
i've created an angular application
called demo components
once executed the browser looks
something like this
so if you haven't watched our previous
video on getting started with angular
that is angular hello world i highly
suggest you go through that video first
it helps you create your first angular
application so um
now let's go ahead and create our first
component now the command used to create
our component is ng gc and your
component name
once executed it creates four different
files now let's just see how this works
on rvs code
now what you can do is head to your
terminal and type in the command ng
g
c
and provide a name for your component
for example i'm going to just call my
component text component
all right
so what it does is that it creates four
different files you can see you have
four different files that have been
created and finally it updates the file
that is app.module.ts indicating that
this new component has been created so
here in your source folder
within which there's an app folder and
again here you can see that your four
different files have been created first
is the html file where you can define
all the code that you want for your
component next you have the css file for
your styling
then you have the dot ts file which
includes the component decorator and
finally you have spec.ts which is
basically a unit test file all right
and then in your app.module.ts
you can observe that the company that
you've created that is text component
has been imported that is what the
message conveys here all right now let's
go back to our app.component.html
now this basically has all the code for
your application so let me just get rid
of it
[Music]
and i'm just gonna
display a basic
heading saying
hello
welcome
all right so let me save it
and if you go ahead and look at your
browser
hello welcome message is displayed now
let's go back to our component
dot html file and here
let me
provide a message
[Music]
let me say h
and let me display a message saying
welcome to this tutorial
on angular components
all right
now in your text component dot ts file
which is your typescript file the
selector mentioned here is app hyphen
text component now go ahead and copy
this
and in your final
component.html go ahead and create your
custom html tag with the selector that
you just copied now this indicates that
the component that you just created that
is the text component is being
incorporated in the final render
so what happens is that whatever is
defined in the component.html file is
also being rendered in your final output
so when i save this
let's go ahead and check
our browser you can see that the message
welcome to this tutorial on angular
components is displayed
so this was a simple creation of a
component now for this let's give it
some styling
so here go to your dot css file and
provide some styling say for example
here i just
say text line
and let me say center and also in my
app.component.cs i'm going to give the
same thing
and say each one
text align
is center
all right so let me save this
and there we go
now we can also create multiple
components and define the tags in the
app component now the components are
executed sequentially so now let's
create another component just to give
you a brief insight into it let's say
nggc
image component
now here i'm going to be adding the
simply learn logo so i'll show you how
that works
now you can see that a new component has
been created with four files again so in
my assets folder here i've added the
logo
so what i can do is back in my html file
i can go ahead and create an image tag
so first let me just display another
message here
just to avoid any confusion and let me
say this is the image component
[Music]
and then
let me say
image
source
equals
so the source is basically assets
slash
logo
dot png
and class
equals
center
[Music]
all right so you can also head to your
css file and provide any sort of styling
that you need
so let me just say
text
align
to be
center
and then let's create
a styling for the image
and here i mentioned the code for the
image
so let's save this
and from the dot cs file
let's copy the selector
and create a custom html tag in our
final component.html file
so there we go
let's save this and check the output
and there we go
first the hello welcome message is
displayed
next you have the message displayed from
the first component and then you have
the second component
so this is how you can create
your own components and don't forget to
incorporate these selectors into your
final html file
so moving on to our next topic component
decorator metadata now as mentioned
earlier the at component decorator
accepts a metadata object that provides
information about the component
correct here is a list of properties of
the metadata object first up is the
selector now basically the selector is a
css selector that identifies this
particular component in a template now
this corresponds to the html tag that is
included in the parent component you can
create your own html tag
however the same has to be included in
the parent component so to help you
understand that better let's head back
to our vs code and say for example in
our text component
here
the selector says text component
correct for the time being let's change
it to say n component
all right
now when you save it and look at the
browser
the message is not displayed
so what we can do is you can copy this
selector
and then include this
here
and now you can see
that the same component has been
rendered onto your output
all right so the selector plays a
crucial role in that
next up we have the template now a
template is an inline defined template
for the view now the template can be
used to provide some particular markup
the markup could typically include some
headings or paragraphs that are
displayed on the ui
next up we have template url now it is
the url for the external file containing
the template for the view
so here you can see
this is basically the external file that
contains the template for the view
next up you have styles now these are
also inline defined styles that can be
applied to the components view
so any code that you provide in the dot
css file can also be included here
next you have the style urls now this is
a list of urls to your style sheets that
are applied on your components view
next up you have providers now this is
again an array where certain services
can be registered for your component
lastly we have animations as the name
suggests these are animations that can
be listed for your components
first we'll understand what exactly
dependency injection is
then we'll understand the demerit or the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
then we'll understand dependency
injection as a design pattern and
finally i'll help you understand the
entire concept with the help of a demo
so let's begin
what exactly is dependency injection so
let's consider this i'm sure you're
aware that angular uses the concept of
components the entire ui of the
application is divided into several
components
now what if all of these components
perform similar tasks be it accessing
the database rendering images etc now
instead of writing the same piece of
code for every component you could write
the code once and then perhaps inject
the same code into every component
now this is supported by dependency
injection
now to give you a better example
consider two classes a and b
now let's assume that a uses the objects
of class b
and normally in object oriented
programming an instance of class b is
created so that a can accesses objects
with using dependency injection we move
the creation and binding of dependent
objects outside of the class that depend
on them so dependency injection or di
keeps the code more flexible testable
and mutable also classes can inherit
external logic without having to create
on its own and lastly di benefits
directives pipes and components
next up let's have a look at the
drawback of not using dependency
injection
now let's consider class
postal details that is dependent on the
number and the address class
in the postal details class the
constructor creates copies of the number
and address
so when you instantiate a new postal
details class the constructor
instantiates a unique number and address
now although this looks simple there's a
problem with this code
let's assume that the number and address
class constructors now accept parameters
when we change the numbers class the
postal details class gets broken
now to overcome this what we need to do
is we need to pass parameter to the
number constructor so this applies to
address as well
the first drawback of using this
traditional method is that the code is
not very flexible
anytime the dependencies change the
postal details class needs to be changed
as well
and the second drawback is that the code
is not suitable for
testing once you instantiate the new
postal details class you get the same
number and address even if you change
the number and address classes every
time what if these classes are in turn
dependent on other classes
then it's going to be a chain reaction
so to overcome this we make use of
dependency injection
now let's look at di as a pattern
dependency injection as you all know is
a coding pattern where a class receives
its dependencies from an external source
rather than creating them on its own so
here in the above example we have moved
the definition of dependencies from
inside the constructor to the
constructor's parameters
so the postal details class doesn't
create the dependencies anymore
it just consumes them so the postal
dependencies class doesn't create the
dependencies anymore
so with that we overcome the drawbacks
of not using di
so now that you know what exactly
dependency injection is and how vital it
is let's look at a simple demonstration
to understand the concept better now
services classes modules
competence all of these are benefactors
of dependency injection so in the demo
i'm going to be showing how dependency
injection can be used with the help of
services and injecting these services
into classes so the main
thought behind this is normally
components are used to ensure just a
good user experience
these components do not generally
execute tasks so to execute these tasks
we make use of services so a component
can delegate tasks like fetching data
from the server any network related
issues etc to a particular service and
these services can be made available to
components
with the same thought what i'm going to
be doing is i'll be creating a service
that performs the task of displaying an
employee list
later we're going to inject the service
into the class using dependency
injection
so let's head to our visual studio code
for the demonstration
all right so as discussed i'll have to
first create a component that displays a
button for the employee and then i have
to create a service class and inject it
into my component now this service holds
the employee details such as name
employee id email id etc
so first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here let me just type
nggc
and the name of the component i'm
providing is amp
info
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free
visit scale up by simply learn click on
the link in the description to know more
all right so as you can see here in my
app folder i have the component
with four different files all right so
the next thing we have to do is we have
to create a service so to create that we
make use of the command
ng g
s
you can either give s or service and the
service name i'm providing is records
so let me just say
records here
all right here you can see two files are
created there is a spec.ts file and the
dot ts file
all right so now the service contains
all the employee data that needs to be
displayed right so let's go ahead and
write the data so first we're going to
make use of three arrays i'm going to be
displaying employee records for three
employees so i'll have to create three
arrays and provide certain information
so let's go ahead and do that
all right so the area i'm creating is
called info one for the first employee
and i'm going to be
passing
information like name employee id and
the email id
so the arrays of type string
and within which let me just mention the
details i'm giving random information
i'm just saying adam taylor
and some random
employee id
and let's say 80 at
abc.net all right so i'm going to be
creating three records so i'll just copy
the same thing and paste for the rest
too
let's just change here
provide a different name here
and same for the last one
and
let me change the name of the idea as
well
all right so with the agenda to retrieve
this data in our component we make use
of the method for the same right so this
method returns the employee data
so let's go ahead and create this method
i'm going to call it get info
and then just say string
and then this will just return
this dot in four one
all right i'm going to be calling it get
info one for better understanding
same for the rest two as well
i'm just going to return different
arrays here
all right and lastly info 3 all right
now in order to retrieve this
information in our component we need
three more arrays right three more
arrays that will receive this data let's
go back to our component dot ts file
here
and then type in the following code
so i've created three arrays again or in
four received one two and three
now what we need to do is we have to
accept the information that is being
sent from the service correct
now as
i mentioned services are implemented
with the help of dependency injection so
what we need to do is we'll have to
first import the service
into the component.ts file
the key reason behind doing this is that
when angular creates this component an
instance of the service class is also
made to perform the necessary tasks
correct so let's go ahead and just
import it here
so i'll say import
records
services
i'm sorry service
from
and let's say records.service
all right and what we have to do next is
that we must also declare this instance
that is being created in the providers
area of the component
all right
so
let's just say providers
and then say records
service
all right now we've created the instance
of this class
right however to access this instance an
object is also created so this object
will in turn access the methods and
variables of the service class so for
that we have to create another object so
let's do that here in our constructor
method
let's say constructor
private and the object i'm creating is
called our service you can give a name
of your choice
and then i'm going to just say records
service
all right now this
object will help me retrieve data from
the service so let's go ahead and use
this in order to get the employee
details
all right i've created three different
methods here get info from service class
2 1 and 3 and these methods will
retrieve the data and add it to our
array here that is info received all
right
and lastly
we'll have to create an unordered list
in our html file here
we haven't added anything so let me get
rid of this
so now i have to create three different
buttons for three different employees
and when the user clicks on the button
the data is retrieved from the service
and then displayed on the ui
right
so as you can see i've created buttons
for three different employees
and then i've made use of a bootstrap
class called list group info
and then i've
interpolated
info which displays the contents
of the info variable all right now in
order to call the methods in the dot ts
file we have to bind them with the
button so since it is bound with the
click event every time you click on the
button the information is
displayed
so now the last thing we have to do is
we'll have to create a custom html tag
for the component and then add it to the
main component
so let's just do that
let me copy
this here
and then in my
appcomponent.html let me get rid of this
and then let me just create this
i've just created the custom html tag
for my component
and now just to beautify the code i'll
write a heading
and let's say
employee
details
and then i'll also add the simply learn
logo
say image source
[Music]
i've i've added the image here so let me
just say logo dot png
i've also added some styling to it
all right
so now let me just save this and have a
look at the browser
so here we go we have the logo here and
then employee details heading and then
we have three different buttons created
that is employee one two and three and
when i click on it
the information of the employee is
displayed the name the id and their
email address
so yeah so this is how you can make use
of dependency injection and inject a
service class into a component
dependency injection plays a crucial
role in angular
we'll understand what angular forms are
then we'll look at the different types
of form building supported by angular
next up we'll get acquainted with
features like form control and group
control
and we learn all of this with the help
of a simple demo so without further ado
let's begin
so what exactly are angular forms
now i'm sure every application that you
use comes with certain amount of form
filling correct be it your login
credentials or your sign up forms or any
sort of registration forms etc so forms
are an integral part of a web
application
you need forms to update your profile or
to enter sensitive information are also
to perform any sort of data related
tasks so now let's look at the different
types of form building supported by
angular
first up angular supports two types of
form building
first you have the template driven
approach and second you have the
reactive approach
now let's look at them one by one
so talking about template driven
approach in this method the conventional
form tag is used to create forms
so angular automatically interprets and
creates a form object with the help of
the directives
now controls can be added to the form
using the mg model tag
now multiple controls can be grouped
using the ng control group module so it
basically uses several module classes to
provide controls now if you don't get
this don't worry you'll understand
better when i'm showing you the demo
next up is json values so form value can
be generated using the form dot value
object
form data is exported as json values
when the submit method is called
lastly basic html validations can be
used to validate the form fields in the
case of custom validations directives
can be used so arguably this method is
the simplest way to create an angular
form
so moving on to the active approach now
this approach is the programming
paradigm revolving around data flows and
propagation of change
now with reactive forms the component
directly manages the data flows between
the form controls and the data models
now reactive forms are code driven
unlike template driven approach
reactive forms eliminate the
anti-pattern of updating the data model
via two-way data binding so it does not
use two-way data binding
and typically a reactive form control
creation is synchronous and can be unit
tested with synchronous programming
techniques
so now let's go ahead and look at form
control and form group
so consider a typical form consisting of
fields like name age and location
now a form control is basically a class
that enables validation of these fields
for each input field an instance of this
class is created
now these instances help check the
values of the field and see if they are
either touched untouched dirty pristine
valid invalid and so on so this allows
you to check every field for the value
it makes it easier to understand which
fields value is invalid or which field
has not been entered etc
now moving on to form group
so a form group class represents a group
of controls a form can have multiple
group controls the form group returns
true if all the controls are valid and
provides validation errors if there are
any so i hope this was clear
so moving ahead let's look at the demo
to explain all of these features i'm
sure it will become extremely clear once
you look at the demo
so for that let's head to our vs code
so back in my vs code
i've created a component called form
component
and
i've also included the simply learn logo
just to beautify the appearance so once
you execute the code
this is what you're going to see on your
browser
so you just have the logo at the moment
the first thing we need to do is we'll
have to
import the forms module all right
so oh but before we begin let me tell
you what the use case is so we're going
to be creating a user registration form
which is going to include four fields
that is the first name last name email
id and a password
all right so now let me show you how to
import the forms module so in your main
app.module.ts file
you will have to import forms module
from angular forms
all right and then in your imports
you'll have to just call it here
all right so this is just a simple step
and now once you're done with that let's
go ahead and
start our form creation so here in my
component.html
let's enclose the entire form within a
div tag
so here
let me say div
class
is a container
within which let me just have one
heading
it says user registration
all right and now let's go ahead and
create our form
so first let me just say form
now i'm going to create a div class for
every field
so
say div
class
equals form group
i'll explain it to you a little later
now first let's create a label
so label tag
for
basically it's the first name
so let me just say first name
and the tab will basically have
first name again
all right and let me just break the line
next we have the field so let's say
input
type is text
name is
first name
and we have a class which is
the form control class
all right
so this will have to do for all the
other fields
so let me just copy this
and
paste it like four times
i'll also add the tag three
for spacing
let's do that here
and finally we'll have the button
so let's just add that here
with a type
subnet
let's just say submit on the button
so now let's go ahead and change these
values here
so here let me just change it to last
name
here as well
and here as well
and in this case it is going to be email
so let me just change it here
and finally we have passwords so
let's add that here
all right so let's save this and just
have a look at our browser
so there we go we have our
user registration form ready but i would
like to
uh align it to the center so let me just
do that
so here in my css file
i'm just going to
align all the div tags the center and
the label tag to the left so let me save
this and look at the browser now
and there we go we have our registration
form with a logo so this is how you
create a simple form
now we'll have to add a directive called
ng model
now this directive when added into the
input tag
will
provide form controls to every input
field
all right so here let's just go ahead
and say ng
model
that is it
so let me just copy this and paste it
for every other field
all right let me save this
and back in my browser
let me inspect
and here you can see different types of
classes like ng untouched ng pristine
ng ballot are added
right so this indicates that angular has
recognized the form tab
and it has added these clauses to the
form as well as all the fields
so this is achieved when you add the ng
model directive in your input tag now
back in my vs code now every form has an
output property attached to it called ng
submit all right so this property can be
bound within a method that method called
the subbit method
so once submitted this method is called
right so once we click on the submit
button this method has to be called so
to include that
we'll have to just say
form
ng submit
equals
submit
[Music]
all right so now we have to define the
submit method
in our component.ts file so here let me
just go to our component.ts file
and let me
just get rid of unnecessary code here
and let's define a function
or submit
and then here let me just
console log
form submitted
all right so let me just get rid of this
as well it's unnecessary here
let's save this so what it means is that
every time you click on the submit
button
this method is called all right so let's
just have a look at the browser so first
let's go to our console
and when i click on submit it says form
submitted
all right
so the next crucial step is to generate
javascript representation now we'll have
to make use of another directive called
ng form
that is assigned to a template variable
okay so
this javascript representation helps
with validating all the fields so i'll
help you understand that better
so back in our html file
let's just create a variable first
let's call it login
all right
and say ng
form
okay
now the mgform object includes the
javascript representation
so now while you're calling the submit
method you're going to pass login as a
parameter
so let's just say login here
and in my ts file
again let's just say login
and along with it
i want login to be displayed so
i say login again
so now let's save this
and if you have a look at the browser
let's click on submit
and now here you can see the javascript
representation
so
within form
i can
check
for
email
or say first name and here for this
field first name you can see different
properties attached you can see
invalid is it invalid or is it
untouched
which is true or are there any errors so
this basically gives you all information
about the particular field
so we can make use of this feature to
validate the information so we're going
to learn about that in our next segment
moving on to form validation one way to
ensure that incorrect fields are not
submitted is by disabling the submit
button
correct now apart from this you can also
specify certain properties in your input
tag for the corresponding input field
now
let's say that the fields that
now let's say that the fields can't be
empty
and the form only accepts names with the
minimum length of two and the maximum
length of seven
all right so here in my input tag
i just mentioned a required meaning this
field cannot be empty
and min length
to
and
max length
to say 7
all right
so to check this
let's go to our browser
and here
let me submit the form without filling
the first name
and evidently there has to be an error
so when i submit it
and i look here
what's in forms and here controls
and my first name
you can see that
an error is shown here it says
required equals true
that means that there is one error
now you can make use of these form
control objects
you can leverage form control objects to
ensure field validation and display a
message whenever an error occurs
right so to do that you need to access
these objects like errors or invalid
or touched all of these properties or
objects need to be
accessed for that we'll have to create a
template variable and then this variable
is assigned to this object
so back in our vs code
let's create
a variable
let me call it
and
let's say ng
model
all right here the variable name
receives the control object
so here back in my browser when i submit
again without
the first name
you can see that the invalid
property is set to true
correct so this helps us use this
property to alert the user with the help
of a simple if logic
so back in my
vs code
let me create
another
div tag
within which i mentioned ng if
within which i'm going to use a simple
if logic
so let's say mgf
name which is
our template variable
name
dot touched
and
name dot invalid
is true
right then i'm going to alert
so i'm going to
make use of an alert
here let's say
alert
danger
all right
so in my css file i'll have to
mention the simple styling for alert
so here let me just say
so we're gonna have the background color
red
for
danger all right and here i'm going to
display the message
invalid in bold
so now let's go back to our browser and
check it
so let me proceed without entering the
last name it says invalid here
so this was a simple demonstration to
show you form validation
of course you can modify the code
depending on your requirement
say suppose the length of the first name
is too short then you can alert the user
with a different message
or
suppose they have missed out on filling
a form field then you can again alert
the user so you can basically make use
of the nested if condition right now
just to help you understand that better
let me just show it to you
now back in my html
file
instead of invalid let me have another
tag a paragraph tag
within which i make use of ngif again
now ngf
name dot errors
[Music]
dot required
is true
then i display the message
first
name
required
all right
and
if
the length of the first name is
[Music]
not 2
now if the length of the first name is
less than 2 then i'm going to display
another message so let me just say
name dot errors
dot min length
if this is true then i'm going to say
sorry
short
first name
all right so let's save this and have a
look at the browser
when i proceed without providing the
name it says first name required
but when i type in one character it says
sorry short first name but if i type in
another character it accepts so i hope
this made you understand how form
validation works
so this was just a simple demonstration
again now i highly recommend you explore
these properties and play around with
these objects uh trust me it's really
fun
so i hope this tutorial helped you out
i'm sure you all know that an angular
app is divided into several components
for example you have the logo component
you have the sign in component an image
component and say a create account
component
now these components are standalone and
each of them represents a part of the
user interface
now imagine if all of these components
performed common tasks for example
accessing the database
or rendering images on the view
tasks like those
now instead of having to write the code
for every component
you can just make use of angular
services
now the service can be written once and
then injected into all of these
components
now a service could be a function it
could be a variable or a feature that an
application needs so the main use of a
service is to write code once and avoid
rewriting of it
now the same code can be injected into
several components that make use of this
particular service
but what are angular services
so normally components are used to
ensure a good user experience now that
is the extent of it components make sure
that whatever is being rendered onto the
screen is right and pristine
but in order to execute tasks we make
use of services and this approach is
ideal
so a component can basically delegate
tasks like fetching data from the server
validating user input or logging
directly to the console to a particular
service
and these tasks can be made available to
any component in the app
so now let's talk about a few features
of angular services
now typically an angular service is
simply a typescript class with an at
injectable decorator
this decorator tells angular that the
class is a service and can be injected
into components that need that service
now they can be used to share the same
piece of code they can also inject other
services as dependencies
now these services hold valuable
business logic
and can also be used to interact with
the back end
now for example if you want to make ajax
calls you can have methods to those
calls in the service and then use it as
a dependency in files
and as mentioned earlier it can be used
to share data among several components
in angular services are singleton
meaning that only a single instance of a
service gets created and the same
instance is used by each and every
building block in the application and
finally a service can be registered as a
part of a module or it can be registered
as a part of the component now to
register it as a part of the component
you'll have to specify it in the
provider's array of the module
i'm sure you'll understand the concept
of services better if we look at a
simple demo
so in the next section we're going to
look at a demo but before that let me
tell you the use case
so basically in the demo what we'll do
is we'll create an employee details list
say for example you will have employee
information like name employee id and
their email id we'll create a database
of say three employees
and on the browser when you click on the
employee button it displays the
information about that particular
employee
and at the end we can also add
information to the employee's details so
without delay let's head to our vs code
and start learning angular services
hands-on so here first i've created a
folder called demo underscore angular
within which i've created a file called
hello world
so uh this was previously used for a
tutorial so the name is just hello world
so don't get confused
however when you look at the browser
i've written an initial code here
which is angular services and i have the
simply learn logo
so back in my browser this is what the
ui looks like
so uh to
so to understand the concept of angular
services
first let's go ahead and create a
component
so here i'm going to say ng
g c
e info
i'm creating a component for employee
information
so as you can see
inside my app
file we have the e info component which
has these four files so if you're
wondering what exactly components are
and how this is working then i highly
suggest you watch our components video
first
so now let's go ahead and create a
service
so i'm just typing in the command ng
g
service
here g stands for generate
and we're generating a service and the
name of the service that i'm providing
is
data
so now it creates a service
which is going to be
a dot ts file
so you can observe that dot service is
appended this indicates that it is a
service
all right
as mentioned earlier we have to display
the employee details correct so for that
in my component.ts file i'm going to
create an array
that displays the employee information
in our case i'm creating uh three
different employee records so for that
i'll have three different arrays
so let me just call the arrays info
received
1 indicating this is the information of
first employee
and this is going to be of type string
and i'll just initialize it to null
for now
all right and i'm going to create
two other
arrays
and let me just
change
the name of that is all right
so now uh to retrieve the information
i'll have to create a method again i'm
creating three methods for uh the three
different employee records
so i'm going to call the array get
info
from service
one
indicating it's again for employee one
and
i'm just gonna leave it as it is for now
i'll tell you how the information is
being received
and i'm gonna do the same for the other
two uh employee records
so let me just
copy paste and here
i'm just gonna change
the name of the methods
all right
so this is the initial code for
retrieving information
however we'll have to create the
employee record in our service
so back here in my data.ts
file
what i'm going to do is
i'll create
three different
records for the employees so let me say
info 1
which is going to be of type string
all right
and
let me just give random names say for
example i say john
matthew
[Music]
all right
and
employee id say
e
and let me just give a random
email id and say jm
abc.net
all right so i'm going to do the same
for the other two uh records
so let me just create another one and
call it info two
and
the name i'm providing is say rob
listen
with a different employee
id say 673
and i'm just going to make it
rw at abc.net
and another record
for employee number three
and
i'm just gonna say rose adams
[Music]
with
some employee id
and
an email id all right
so now
we've created the employee records
so what i have to do is i have to create
a method
that returns these employee records
correct so for that i'm just gonna
create another method called get info
one
which is of type string
and it just returns
this
dot info one
all right
similarly for the rest of the two
records i'm just gonna retrieve them
[Music]
let's say in four two
and get in for two
and again
i'm just gonna make it get in for 3
and this is going to
return
in 4 3
all right so i'm sure you've got an idea
as to what i'm doing here
so basically this information is going
to be retrieved in our employee
component correct so for that i'll have
to make use of dependency injection
so here i'll have to import the service
that i've created so let's go ahead and
say import
[Music]
the service was data service
all right
from
[Music]
slash data dot service all right
now the main reason we're doing this is
to tell angular
that when the component is created
the service instance is also created and
this instance is being used to perform
particular tasks and for that we'll also
have to include this in our providers
array so here
let me just say providers
[Music]
and let's say data service
now to access this instance of service
that is created we make use of a
property
so this property basically allows us to
access all the methods that are defined
in the service class
all right so here in my constructor
method i'm just going to say
private
and you can give any name for your
property and here i'm just giving the
name d service
all right
and which is of type data service
so now with the help of this property i
can retrieve information from the
service
class so here i'm just going to save
this
dot
info received
equals this dot
d service
dot get info 1
all right so what it basically does is
that it calls the get info one method in
our service
which returns the information of the
first employee
and this information is being stored in
the array that is info received one
so similarly for the next
two methods i'm just going to use the
same piece of code
let me just change it here
and
same for the third one
all right
so now that we have the logic behind
what is being displayed
let's go ahead and create the ui for it
here in my html file
i'm going to create
an unordered list
[Music]
and now i'm going to make use of
the ng
for director
to uh basically loop over the record and
display everything
so for that i have to make use of a
particular variable so i'll just say
let
info of
info received
so um you can check here in our ts file
the
array is info received correct so i'm
going to make use of the same array here
and since it's displaying the first
employee record i'm just going to
say
info received one
all right and let me just create a class
a bootstrap class of list
group
item of list group info
and we're just gonna have to interpolate
in four
all right that is basically going to
display what the information holds what
the info variable holds
all right and here is where let me
create a bootstrap class
called list
group
all right i hope this was clear to you
so basically here
the information is being retrieved with
the help of this method right that is
get info from service one so in order to
call this method we'll have to bind it
with a button all right so that's what
we're going to do
let's just
copy this and here i'm going to create a
button
all right
and the type
is button
[Music]
with name
button again
all right so i'm going to bind it with
the click event
so what happens is that when i click on
it
this particular method gets called
all right i'm just pasting the method
here
and finally let's just
provide the name employee one
for the button all right
so uh similarly we'll have to do the
same for
the other two records as well
let me just make this look better all
right
so what i'm going to do is i'm just
going to paste the same
twice
and here i'm going to just change
the names i'll say 2 here
and this is again for employee 2
and i'm going to change this as well
it's going to be employee i'm sorry it's
going to be in 4 received 2
this is going to be in 4 received 3
and finally employee three
all right
uh and lastly we'll have to include
the selector that is app hyphen e info
in our main
component
or html so here
let me just
create a custom tag all right and save
this so now let's go back to our browser
and see what it looks like
so here you can see that uh three
different buttons have been created for
employee one two and three and when you
click on it
it retrieves the information that is
the name the employee id and their email
ids so we've successfully created an
angular service and injected it into our
component to retrieve information all
right so now the last part of the use
case that we discussed
was uh to add another
detail that is the employee detail in
the record
all right so for that we'll have to take
uh input from the user and in our case
we're taking the location
now uh we're also adding the same
location for all three employees
so this is what services do you know
they can be used to update modify alter
anything
that happens in the backend so you can
tweak the code a little bit
and you can change the entire uh view of
your application you can add information
you can delete you can retrieve you can
alter etc
all right so for that what we're going
to do is back in the html file
we'll create a form
that basically takes the input
so i'm just going to say um
all right
within which i'm going to be defining a
div class
[Music]
within which i'm going to be defining a
div tag
inside of which i'll have
the input tag
of
type
text
and
the name i'm going to be providing it
will be location
all right
[Music]
and we'll have a value and i'll just
leave it blank and finally i'll have ng
model so if you're confused as to what
i'm doing here then i suggest you watch
the angular forms
video
it basically teaches you how to work
around with angular forms all right and
now
after this we're gonna have a button
so let me say button
[Music]
all right
and i'm gonna just say add
info
okay
all right so now when i'm creating the
form i'll also have to create a
template variable to access all the
values within my form
so if i have to access the location then
i need a variable to access it so here
let me just go ahead and create a
template variable let me call it
frm
and i'm going to make use of the ng form
directive
so this tells angular
that
this variable can be used
to
access all the values within the form
and since i'm using form here i'll have
to import it in my
module
file
so here
i just go ahead
and say
import forms module from angular forms
and here in my imports
i'll just say forms
module
okay so i've imported the forms module
so now back in my html file what i'm
going to do is that i'll have to make
use of this template variable
to update my information correct
so i'll have to create another method
that will update information into the
records
so here in my component.ts file i'll
have to create another
method
and i'm going to call this method update
info method
all right
and
this basically takes in the template
variable that is form
and let me just specify any
okay and what this is going to do
is that it updates
the record correct so i'm going to say
this
dot
d service
add info now you must be wondering what
add info is
i'll just let you know in a minute and
and the value that i'm going to be
passing will be the value that you've uh
provided as an input which is nothing
but form
dot value dot location
all right so now
what happens is that i'll have to again
specify what add info is and this method
is going to be defined in the service
file correct
so here
i'm going to create another
method that's add
info
and i'm going to pass info as a
parameter
and what this method does is that it
just pushes the information or the data
into the arrays so since i'm going to be
pushing the same information into all of
these arrays that is info one in photo
and info three i'm just going to say
this dot info one
dot push
off
info all right and the same for
the other two areas as well
let me just
change these all right so what exactly
i'm doing is that i have i have a method
called add info which gets information
from the component
all right and it basically pushes this
information into the array and also i
have to return it so i'll say return
this dot info
[Music]
all right
and i'll save it
and here we have another method called
update info which basically calls
the add info method in our service
and passes the value to it
and in my html file
also note that the button type here is
submit
and not button
so
what happens is that
now the value that we've received as an
input has to be
uh passed on to the method that is
update info so here i'll say ng submit
and
i'm going to call the method update
info
and i'm going to pass
from as
the argument
and now let's save this
and execute
so all right here you can see that we
have an input field and a button saying
add info
so now i can just go ahead and see type
usa
and when i say add info
and when i check on my
employee one details usa has been added
to the list
and same goes with employee 2 and
employee 3.
so i hope this simple demo on angular
services helped you understand the
concept better i highly recommend you
play around and explore other
possibilities
let's understand what exactly is
bootstrap
bootstrap is a powerful toolkit
basically a collection of html css and
javascript tools for creating and
building responsive web applications and
pages it is a free and open source
project based on github and originally
created by twitter
now to put it more easily bootstrap is a
giant collection of handy reusable bits
of code written in html css and
javascript
it's also a front-end development
framework that enables developers and
beginners to design quick and responsive
websites
now there are several advantages to
using bootstrap
to name a few bootstrap comes with a
responsive grid
you don't have to spend time working on
your layouts
bootstrap comes with its own code for
automatically resizing images based on
the current screen size
it also comes with different components
that you can use for your web page
these components could be navigation
bars drop downs progress bars thumbnails
etc
it also offers excellent documentation
and is customizable
so bootstrap comes in extremely handy to
create responsive
user interface
so now before using bootstrap it needs
to be embedded into your application
so let's see how to embed bootstrap into
angular
now there are two ways to do it
first up is by using the bootstrap cdn
or the content delivery network
now this enables users to load css
javascript and images remotely from its
servers
the other method is to use bootstrap npm
bootstrap jquery and other packages and
frameworks can be installed via the
command prompt
in the tutorial that i'm going to be
showing you i've embedded bootstrap
using npm all right so i'm sure you'll
only understand the concept better when
you look at a demo
so let's go ahead and create an
application with the help of angular
bootstrap so in this tutorial what i'm
going to be showing is the creation of a
blog post
so let me show you what we're going to
be doing
so here i've created a simple
blog
for simply learn and i've added the
simply learn logo i've also written a
few lines about simply learn and what
they offer i've also mentioned their tag
line
and when you scroll down you can see
that i've mentioned the different
courses they're offering
and when you click on the more info
button
it navigates to the official page that
gives you the overview for that
particular course
so this is for lean six sigma the same
for full stack web development
as well
and
the same for the last one that is cyber
security
and finally i have added a simple video
here to just make it more
beautiful so i've added a simple video
and lastly
i've also
linked our youtube channel so when you
click on the youtube icon
it will navigate to the
youtube channel
to our youtube channel here all right so
this is what we're going to be creating
uh using angular bootstrap so i'm
hoping you're all ready for it so
without further delay let's jump in so
first let's find the template that we
want to use for our blog
so for that i'm going to just go ahead
and say
bootstrap
blog
template
and i'm just going to click on the first
link that i get
and here
you can choose the template that you
like
so i'm just going to look for more
templates here
and the one that we are going to choose
is
oh yeah this one so which is small
businesses so you can go ahead and click
on that
you can then click on live preview
and once you do that
you can just
say view frame source
so here you can see that the html code
is available
it has the head section and then the
body section
so the head section consists of a lot of
meta tags
and then you have the title
and then you also have the css file
references
and then if you look at the body tag you
have different code for different parts
of the
ui there's code for navigation bar and
then you have page content code
heading row
call to action and all of that
and lastly you have the footer
so what we're going to be doing is that
we'll take all of the code and then
we'll have to create components for each
of it and then we'll include all the
components in our main
html file
so that is the best practice that
angular uses so we're going to make use
of components
and you can also see that when you
scroll down you can see that
it has certain dependencies so here it
has the bootstrap dependency and then
you have jquery so
we have to
download them
so we'll have to install them
and as mentioned earlier we're going to
be installing them with the help of npm
so for that we'll have to head back to
our vs code here
back in my vs code i've created a
folder called angulardemo
and then i've also created a file called
demo components
and here
i'm just going to say cd
demo components
within which i'll say npm
install
jquery
[Music]
so this could take a while
and once you've installed jquery go
ahead and type npm install
bootstrap
[Music]
all right so we've successfully
installed jquery and bootstrap
so now we need to add the references to
these javascript files to do that
go to your
angular.json file
and here we have to add them in our
build section so here you can see we
have styles and scripts so in our
scripts array we define the relative
path to these javascript files
so these files are generally
stored in your
node modules so go ahead and
here you can look for bootstrap
here you go and
then in your dist file
and then click on js
and then you can see you have
bootstrap.min.js
oh well i'm sorry we need
bootstrap.bundle.min.js so here
you can just right click and say copy
relative path
and back in my json file in my scripts
i'm gonna just paste it here
and make sure to
make it a path by providing by providing
forward slash
[Music]
all right and then the next thing we
need is the
jquery.min.js files so for that
again
in our node modules you will have to
look for jquery so here there's jquery
and then click on dist
and then we have jquery.min.js
so again let me just
copy the path
and paste it here
[Music]
follow the same procedure for this as
well
all right so we've embedded both our
files in our
angular.json file
so now in our code here
in the beginning they've also included
the css file
so we'll have to embed that as well so
here back
in
bootstrap
let me just add the css file as well
that's
bootstrap.min.css i'm just going to copy
the relative path
and just provide it here
[Music]
let me just change these
to forward slash
[Music]
okay so we have our custom style sheet
so what i'm going to do is
i'm just going to copy this
and just paste it in our
[Music]
and then you can just paste it here
all right
so i think we've added all the
dependencies
and the custom style sheet and
everything so now let me just
close all of these files
uh what we can do now is that we can go
ahead and
take the code from the
source here so i'm just going to copy
the body tag
all right
so
i'm going to copy this till the footer
and then i'm just going to paste it in
my
component.html file
[Music]
so as mentioned earlier i will create
components and then place the code for
specific parts of the ui in these
components
so
let me just see if i've got everything
here
okay
so i'll be creating four components the
first one will be for the navigation bar
the second will be for the introduction
and then the third one will be uh to
display the courses that we're providing
and then lastly we'll have the footer
component right so first let's create
these components i've also created a
components folder here in my app folder
so i just have to
type in the command
ngc
first we'll create
the
component for the top navigation bar so
i'm just saying nggc
so i'm just going to say components
[Music]
slash nav bar
all right so uh the component has been
created so what i'm going to do is i'll
just
copy this
[Music]
and paste it here
all right and the next component i'm
going to be creating is for the
introduction right so i'll say ng
g
c
[Music]
components slash intro
all right so
so i will have to take
this code here i'm also going to be
including the call to action part
so i'll just
copy paste this one in my
intro.html file
[Music]
so let me do that and then i'm going to
have the
main course content
component so for that i'll say nggc
components slash courses
[Music]
and we're going to copy the next part of
the code
[Music]
all right until uh till the footer
let me just add it here
and finally we're gonna create the
component for the footer so
i'll say ng gc
components slash
footer
and the last part of the code i'm just
going to add it there
[Music]
all right
so now we'll have to create the custom
html tags for these components and then
place it in our html file
right so first one that we created was
the navigation bar so here
head over to the ts file
just copied the selector
[Music]
and then here
and then in our
app.component let me just
create the tags
similarly for intro
[Music]
i'm just going to copy the selector
and then for courses
so
we have app a hyphen courses
that is well
and then lastly we have the footer
components so let me just copy that
paste it here
[Music]
all right so we've included all the
components so let's just run this
application and see if everything
is displayed intact
so here let me just say ng
serve so when you execute the command
you can see that the template is being
displayed so you have the navigation bar
you have the
intro component and then we have the
courses component and finally we have
the footer component
right okay so now that we have the
template ready we can go ahead and
customize it according to our needs
so now i'm going to be making a few
changes to the code we're going to add
the simply learn logo we're going to
change the tag line here we're going to
display something else over here all
right so let's go back to our vs code to
customize
and display the final output
so here
the first thing that i'm going to be
doing is
changing the message here i'm going to
display simply learn for that
in our navbar component
let's go to the html code
and here instead of start bootstrap let
me just type in simply learn
[Music]
all right
so when you save it and when you look at
the browser
you can see that
simply learn is displayed
and the next thing that i want to do is
i want to add the image right i simply
learn logo
so what i've done here is i've already
added
the logo
dot png file in my assets folder so i'll
just go ahead and provide the
path to this
so that's going to be in our intro files
so here
image source
is going to be
[Music]
assets
slash
[Music]
logo.png
so let me save this
so there we go the logo is displayed
so the next thing is we'll have to
change
this part of the ui so the information
that i want to display is this
i'm going to be displaying
world's number one online boot camp and
other information so what i'm going to
do
is back in my vs code i'm just going to
delete
this
and instead of that i'm just going to
copy this that's world's number one
online boot camp
and then within the paragraph tag i'll
display something else so let me get rid
of this
[Music]
let me just copy the information that i
want to display
paste it here
[Music]
and let me just give a line break
let me save this and see if it's
displayed
so yeah we can see that the information
is being displayed
next up here instead of displaying call
to action message i'm going to display a
explore programs message
so let's go back to our vs code
let me just say explore
programs here
and then
lastly
instead of this message here
i want to display the message uh get
certified get ahead with our programs
so back in our vs code
i'm just going to get rid of this
[Music]
and paste this instead
so when you
have a look at the browser
let me refresh this
you can see it displays the message get
certified get ahead and all of that
well now what i'm going to do is i'm
really not happy with the font size and
everything so i'm just go ahead and add
certain styling you can customize this
and provide your own font size and all
of that
so here i'm just going to mention style
and then say font
size
and i'm going to make it xx large
all right so let's see
[Music]
yeah all right so it's the font size has
increased so i think i'm happy with this
all right so the next thing we have to
do is add information here for our
courses
so back in our vs code
we'll have to go to the courses
component
so here i'm going to just
type in the code for the different
courses so i already have it here
so the first thing is this message that
i want to display let me just copy that
and for our first tag i'm just gonna say
post graduate program ending six sigma
and the next information i'm going to be
providing is the duration
so here
let me just get rid of this
[Music]
paste that here
let me just break the line
to beautify the
code
and then
and here for our
reference link i already have the link
here so i'm just going to paste that so
once you click on the
more info button it will automatically
navigate to this page
all right
so let me save this
next up i'm going to do the same for the
other two courses as well
so it says postgraduate program in full
stack development
and then we're going to mention the
duration and the cohort so
let me paste that
and also
provide a blind break
and then
link i have it here so
i'm just gonna paste that
[Music]
and finally for the third card
i have
the third link here
[Music]
let me get rid of this extra code and
paste this instead
[Music]
and then let's also provide the link for
the same
[Music]
all right
so let me save this
and have a look at the browser
so you can see that
the information has been added
you can see it displays postgraduate
program in lean six sigma full stack
development and cyber security
so once i click on more info it leads
you to that
page
that shows the overview all right
so now the next thing on the agenda was
to
display a short video and then the link
to our youtube channel
so let's go ahead and add that in our
courses component
uh so what i'm gonna do is i'm just
gonna get the code to add a video from
google and then i'm going to
provide the source
which is going to be the video that i
would want to display
so i've received the code i'm just going
to paste it here
so you can get the code
on google so go ahead and just paste
that
also for the source i have a video in my
assets folder which i have provided here
so when i save it and look at the
browser here we go you can see the video
here
all right
and once clicked it starts playing
[Applause]
[Music]
all right and lastly we'll have to
provide the logo for youtube and then
the link to navigate to the youtube page
so let's go ahead and do that
so here again i've pasted the code
for the youtube logo so here you can see
that i've added the image that is
youtube.png in my assets folder and i've
provided the source
and accordingly i've also added
the styling i've provided a white
background and i've also aligned the
text to the
center of the page
all right and i've also displayed the
message saying check out our youtube
channel for technical videos and
tutorials
and then i've provided the link to our
channel on youtube so let me just save
this and head back to the browser
and here you can see that
we have the youtube logo
and we have the message displayed
so once you click on the
logo it navigates to the simply learn
channel on youtube
all right so uh if you want you can also
change the message here for the footer
so here in
footer.html i can just
remove this and
paste this i say simply on solutions and
all rights reserved
when i save it and look at the browser
it must get updated
so yeah there we go
so with the help of bootstrap we have
successfully created a website which is
basically a blog
and we've also added the reference links
and images and logos to customize it
according to our requirements
so yeah this is it this is how you uh
make use of bootstrap and embed it into
your angular
for more responsive and better user
interface let's have a look at the
basics of routing
now i'm sure that you observed that the
url changes every time you click on a
particular link or on an icon on the
user interface correct now this
basically indicates that you are
navigating throughout the application
now to achieve this navigation we use a
mechanism called routing routing is
essentially used to navigate through a
website or a web application
but how is it achieved in angular
especially in angular routing plays a
major role it is used to create single
page applications
now these applications are loaded just
once and new content is added
dynamically
applications like google facebook
twitter and gmail are a few examples of
single page applications the best part
of using single page applications is
that it provides an excellent user
experience and you don't even have to
wait for new pages to load which by
extension makes single page applications
extremely fast but how is this new
content loaded
enter routing now routing is the
mechanism that as discussed earlier that
is used to navigate through the
application and load new content
routing helps angular configure the
route and the component that needs to be
displayed
now i'm sure you're going to understand
the concept of routing better when you
work on it hands-on so in the demo we're
going to be navigating to the login and
the home pages of a web application with
the help of routing
so let's head to our visual studio code
so basically the objective of our
application is to navigate to home
and the login pages so when i click on
the login icon here
it loads the login
page
and here you can see the extension
slash login and similarly with home once
you click on it some new information
gets added and the url changes
with the slash home appended
all right so this is the main objective
of our application so to create it let's
head back to our vs code all right so
here i've created a folder called demo
and underscore angular and i've created
a file called demo routing
now the first thing you want to do is
open the index.html file and make sure
that the base tag is added
now although this is generally
added when your app is created if it is
not then add a base tag with href
attribute which is set to a forward
slash
all right now this is generally done to
tell angular to construct the url while
navigating with a forward slash all
right and the next thing you want to do
is open your
app.module.ts file and check if the app
routing module has been imported
if not go ahead and import it and then
also mention it in your imports
array with that the initial setup is
done
now to create the nav bar the code that
i'm going to be using is already
explained in the previous video that is
angular bootstrap i highly suggest you
go through that video before watching
this
so uh the code is already available i'm
just going to create a component and
write the code for it
and paste the code in it so let's do
that
let me say nggc
navbar
[Music]
all right so this component is now
created
now here in my html file
i'll just get rid of this and paste the
code for the nav bar
so here we go i've pasted the code for
the navigation bar
and back in my
app.component.html file
i'll just remove all the
unwanted
code here
and just specify the
custom html tag for my navbar
so
let me just create one here
all right let me save this let me just
run the application and see if it's
displaying correctly
all right so when i open the browser
the navigation bar has been created
along with
these different options that's home
about services and login all right and
we also have the simply learn icon here
all right now the next step is to
generate the components to display the
login page content and the home page
content
now again i have used bootstrap to
define the user interface for these
files you can easily find the code
online just search for
bootstrap login templates and depending
on your requirements you can choose the
appropriate one
so first let's create the components for
by two files that is for the home
component
and the login component
so
let's go ahead and do that
ngc
i'm just going to call it login for my
login component
all right and then i'm going gonna say
nggc home for the home component
all right
so i'm just going to copy the
code for the login component
so back in my login.html
file
i'll just paste the code here
okay
also note that i've added the simply
learn logo in my assets folder
and then just provided the source for it
here in my login component
all right
so next up is the home component
and if you've seen the previous video
that is angular bootstrap you might have
seen that we created three different
components that is intro courses and
footer which included the content for
the intro message for the courses and
the footer message correct so here we're
going to just paste the code for all of
these three
and then just display it when the home
button is clicked
all right so what i'm going to do is
i'll just
paste it here
[Music]
so this basically has all the content
one thing i want to tell you is that in
the previous video we made sure that the
code was written in three different
components however for this i've just
added all the code in the same component
now i agree that this is not the best
practice so if you want you can go ahead
and create three different components
and separate the code into these three
components and just add the custom html
tags in your home component
i'm just hoping you're following me
right now
and also here in my assets folder i've
added
a video and the youtube logo that needs
to be displayed uh when the home icon is
clicked
all right so now that we've created the
home and the login components
the next step is to configure the routes
for the application
all right so here you can see that we
have a file called app routing module.ts
file
so here
we have the routes and the router module
that is imported
and we also have a constant called
routes which is strongly typed to routes
from the router package
all right now this array is used to
define all the possible routes in the
application
now each route is basically an object
with a path
so here in my routes array
i'm just going to go ahead and create
the paths that is we have two different
routes right one is for login and one is
for home
so i'm just going to create a path
object so let's say path
sorry within curly braces i say path
and then the path that i'm going to give
is
login
this is basically what will appear
on the url
all right
and the component that needs to be
navigated to is nothing but the login
component
so let me just say login
as you can see the login component has
been automatically imported
now same with
the home
path so let me just say
path
home
and the component that needs to be
rendered is the home component
[Music]
all right
now the next step is to link these
routes to a button
in the nav bar that is the home and the
login button right so we're gonna make
use of the nav tag and an anchor tag for
this
you can see that we have a nav tag
and an anchor tag
which encloses the login and the home
components
all right now we're going to make use of
two directives
from the router package called router
link and router link active
now these are specified within the
anchor tag
the router link basically holds the path
to the page
and the latter that is the router link
active specifies one or more css classes
that will be applied when the router
link is active all right so to do that
let me just
add
router
link
all right in our case it is home here
and we're going to have another
director called
router link active
[Music]
and we're just going to say
active here
[Music]
all right
same for the login icon here
let me just copy this
[Music]
and instead of home
the path we created for this was login
[Music]
all right
so this is how you can bind the route to
your specific button on your ui
now despite of all this
how are we specifying where these
components are to be displayed
right the answer to this is using the
router outlet directive now again this
directive is available in the router
package
so we have to add that in our app
component.html file
so here just go ahead and type
router
outlet
all right
so with that we've created a simple
navigation bar which has different
options that is home about services and
link and once the user clicks on the
home icon it displays the content that
is in the
homecomponent.html file
and once the user clicks on the login
component it displays the content in the
login.html file
all right it's as simple as that
so now let's go to the browser and see
if it executes correctly
so all right we have the navigation bar
and once i click on the home icon here
right yes we see that all the content
has been loaded
you can see we have
the intro section we have the courses
section and the footer section as
discussed
and the most important part is that here
in our url you can see that slash home
has been appended this shows that a
route has been created that navigates to
the home component
so we've successfully created a route
here
and for login component when i click on
this icon
you can see that the path changes here
and the login component gets displayed
alright so this is how routing is
achieved in angular
in this session we will learn about the
database and the need for a database
then we will transition to sql and see
some basic sql queries after knowing
what a sql query is
we will see the features in application
subscript query and then we will have a
hand on some of the basic sql queries so
hey everyone i am abhisaruja from simply
learn and welcome to this video on sql
basics for beginners but before we begin
if you love watching tech videos
subscribe to our channel and hit the
bell icon to now miss an update
let's start with database a database is
a vast collection of data that is stored
and retrieved electronically from a
system
in today's world data has become the new
oil which has mandate companies and
businesses to rely on an excellent
database to store the vast amounts of
data
every millisecond the tech giants are
accumulating vast amounts of data that
need to be stored
the database comes with features to
update and effortlessly manipulate data
and not only that
these database provider companies ensure
the data to be safe and secure
they also provide tools to extract
useful information to help the companies
make meaningful decisions
after knowing about the database let's
see how sql communicates with the
database to get desired results
sql stands for structured query language
the structured query language is the
standard language used by database
operators and developers to carry out
different operations from manipulating
updating and retrieving data from
relational databases
now let us see how we write a basic
query
there's a customer table with columns
customer id customer name age gender
date of purchase address item and price
and we need to extract the customer id
and customer name from this table
so we will write a query select customer
id comma customer name from customers
semicolon
when we will execute the query in my
sequel workbench we will get the desired
result that is the output table with
customer id and customer name
this is how we write a query to extract
the information from the database we'll
see some more queries as the session
proceeds
now we'll see what the features of sql
are
sql lets you access any information
stored in a relational database
with sql queries data is extracted from
the database in a very efficient way
the structured query language is
compatible with all database systems
from oracle ibm to microsoft and it
doesn't require much coding to manage
databases
now we will see applications of sql
sql is used to create a database define
its structure implement it and lets you
perform many functions
sql is also used for maintaining an
already existing database
sql is a powerful language for entering
data modifying data and extracting data
in a database
sql is extensively used as a
client-server language to connect the
front-end with the back-end thus
supporting the client-server
architecture
sql when deployed as data control
language dcl
helps protect your database from
unauthorized access
after knowing sql with its features and
applications
let's go through some basic queries in
sql
that is ddl data definition language dml
data manipulation language dcl data
control language tcl transaction control
language
ddl or data definition language consists
of the sql commands that can be used to
define the database schema let's see ddl
commands create command is used to
create the database or its objects like
table index function views stored
procedure and triggers
drop is used to delete objects from the
database truncate is used to remove all
records from a table alter is used to
alter the structure of the database
dml or data manipulation language
consists of the sql commands that deals
with the manipulation of data present in
the database
insert into command is used to insert
data into a table
update is used to update existing data
within a table delete is used to delete
records from a database table select
this command helps you to select the
attribute based on the condition
described by the workflows
tcl or transaction control language
these commands deals with the
transaction within the database
commit commands commit a transaction
rollback command rollbacks a transaction
in case of any error occurs save point
it sets a save point within a
transaction set transaction it specify
characteristics for the transaction
dcl or data control language it consists
of the commands such as grant and revoke
which mainly deals with the rights
permissions and other controls of the
database system
grant command gives user access
privileges to database
revoke it withdraw user success
privileges given by using the grant
command now we'll have hands on some
basic queries in my sql workbench
if getting your learning started is half
the battle what if you could do that for
free visit scale up by simply learn
click on the link in the description to
know more
now we will see some basic queries
executing in my sql workbench
so we'll start
and first query will run will be use
sys
that is the database
this command is used to select the
database
in which we want to create or manipulate
any data
now we'll see another command that would
create a table
now we will add attributes to the
customer table that would be the columns
first would be the customer id
and we will
act at
it as a primary key
the next attribute we would add would be
customer name customer underscore name
and its data type would be very care
next attribute we would add would be h
within data type
next attribute would be gender
with character data type
next we will add as date of purchase
date data type
now we'll add another attribute that
would be address
with data type where
next we would write
the attribute item
that would be the item purchased with
data type where care
next would be the price
okay for price we will
make it as float
and
let's shift this to next line and now
we'll execute this command
yeah you can see that the table is
created
now we have to insert values into it
for that we'll write a command insert
into
customers
values
and
i have all the reports written in the
notepad
so i will copy these
paste it here
these are 20 records
like all the attributes they are in the
order
so we have written
all the records in the order only
like customer id that would be 101
customer name that would be joseph
age that would be 22 gender made date of
purchase this is the date of purchase
address pune
item that is vegetable purchased price
that is 80.
so now we will run this command
and all these
records they would be inserted into the
table
and these are 20 commands
20 reports
you can see insert into customer values
the command has been executed and they
have been inserted into the table
now we'll see
the table
for that we'll write the command select
star
from
customers
here you can see the table
in the output grid
okay i will make sure you will see the
whole table
with all the 20 codes
you can see
all the 20 reports they have been
inserted
now you see
another command
and for that we would just
get the output as customer id and
customer name in the output grid for
that
we'll write the command select
customer id
comma
customer name
from
customers
semicolon
and we'll run this command
and we will get both the columns
customer id and customer name
in our output grid
now let's see another command that would
be draw the drop command just removes
the component from the database
so we'll write
drop
table
and table name that would be customers
and semicolon
and we will execute this command
now the table has been removed from the
database
to verify whether the table has been
removed from the database or not we will
run a command select
star from
customers semicolon and execute this
command
and what we will get is select start
from customers error code table says
customers doesn't exist the table has
been removed from the database so the
drop command worked here
now we don't have any table that is the
customer table has been dropped from the
database so we have to create that table
again
so we'll go at the top
okay
yeah
and we'll create the table again
and we'll insert all the reports again
into the table
both the commands have run now we will
run this command to see whether the
table has been created and the reports
have been inserted into the table or not
both commands have worked
now we'll see another command
that would be truncate
the truncate command just manages all
the records from the table
truncate
table
table name
semicolon
and just run this command
the command has been executed
now we'll see
yeah you can see that all the records
from the table has been vanished so the
truncate command worked here
now to carry other operations we have to
insert all the reports again into the
table
we'll do that
we'll again go upwards
and run this command
insert into customers values
and all the reports
and will execute this command and that
command has been executed and all the
records
are again in the table so run this
command and check it
yeah you can see all the reports then
set it into the table
now let's see another command that would
be alter
alter command is used to update any
recovered into the table
you will see
folder
table
table name that is customers
and now what we should do
uh okay we'll drop the column h
from the table
so right command drop
column
h
semicolon
i'll run this command
the command has been executed
and now we'll check whether the
h column has been dropped or not select
star
from customers
semicolon
and we will execute this command
yeah you can see
the age column has been dropped off the
table
so the alter command has been executed
successfully
okay so
now we'll see another thing uh like if
you want to comment something
during the execution you can do that
just write two minus signs
and the text
this would be the comment
and you can also use
slash
star and that
text
inside it and star and slash
so this is also the comment section
you can write comment
with this syntax or with this syntax
they both work
now we'll see another command that would
be update
this is also used to manipulate data in
the table to update any record into the
table
so we will write
update
table name that would be customers
and what we should update okay we will
update our record
we will change the customer name
and address
and we have the primary key as customer
id so we'll use that
so update customers
set
customer name
equal to
james
coma
and address
equal to
[Music]
boston
where
customer id
equal to
one zero one
okay
you can see here in the table one zero
one
customer id the customer name is joseph
and the address is pony
we have updated command and we will
execute it let's see okay okay
we have an error here
uh yeah that's correct we will execute
this command
yeah the command has been executed
successfully and now we check the table
with the command select star
from customers
semicolon
you can see the row has been updated
the customer name is james here and the
address is boston so the command has
been executed successfully
now we'll see another command that would
be delete
so delete command is used to delete any
particular record for any particular row
so we'll write the command delete
from
customers
where
customer id
equal to one zero two
semicolon
so the second row that is with customer
id 102 that would be deleted and we will
execute this command
now we'll check into the table
yeah you can see
the record has been deleted
now we'll see distinct command
that is used to return different values
so we will write command select
distinct
and the column name for which we want
different values
to be in the output grid
we select address
from
customers
and we will execute this command
yeah
these are the address so these are the
cities in the address
which are different and which are unique
and we have get that through the
distinct command
now we will see minimum command minimum
command is used to get the records
or get the data that is minimum of all
the data
so
for that we will write the syntax
select
minimum
like min
in bracket we will write the attribute
name or the column name
for which we want the data to be minimum
as
less price
this would be the attribute name
from customers
so we will execute this command
and what we would see is
that 60 would be the last price
like the customer table they have the
column price
and in that we all we have all the
prices and from that
the minimum price is 60 and we have get
it at less price
similarly we have the maximum command to
get the maximum amount from the column
we will use the maximum command
select
max
in bracket we will write the attribute
name
as
max
price from customers
and we will execute this command
and what we get is 3400 is the maximum
price from the price column
now we'll see another command that would
be count
count command it returns the number of
rows according to the query so we'll run
the query and see like how it works
we'll write select
count
and the attribute name
that would be
a customer id
customer id
from customers
semicolon
and when we'll run this command
we will get 19 as a result that is it
counted the number of customer ids that
is 19 in the table
now you'll see another command
that would be average
so it just gets the average of the
numbers
and how we do it
let the query
select
avg
and the attribute name for which you
want the average
from
table name
semicolon
and we'll execute this command and we'll
get the average of the price
from the customers table
now if you want
to add up all the prices from the
customer table you can use the command
sum
so how will execute that command
select
sum
in bracket we will write the attribute
name that would be price
from
customers semicolon
and we'll run this command
and we'll get the sum of the prices from
the customer table
now we will see where command
where command is used to filter records
uh let's say through syntax
so we will write select
star
from customers
where
address
uh yeah we will
wear address equal to
pune
[Music]
semicolon
and then we will run this command
and yeah this is the table we will get
records with addresses spooning
so this is the functioning of wear
command
now we'll see group by command
that is used to
just group the number of rows that have
the same values we will see it through
the syntax
like we will write
select
count
attribute name that would be customer id
comma
address
from
table name
and group by
accordingly with
address
here the comma will not come
yeah this is the command
select count customer id
comma address from customers group by
address
when we will execute this command yeah
we will get this table
that would be these are the different
addresses
and these are the number of times
the number of persons who live in this
address with the count with respect to
customer ids
now let's see having close with the help
of an example only
select
count attribute name that would be
customer id
comma
address
from
table name that would be customers
group by
address
having
count
customer id
greater than
unit 3 4 3 2
semicolon and then we will execute this
command
and you can see
the output we have got through this
command that is group by command
goes this
and when we have added having closed
having count customer id greater than
three
just got the customer id count with four
now we'll see another command
that is order by
select star from table name that is
customers
and we will order this output by address
semicolon
we have got the output with respect to
the address
the address has been assigned
alphabetically here
this particular topic which we have
already decided to work on it is very
interesting in this current scenario
because if you see carefully lot many
companies are moving towards nosql
database
and there is a reason behind this why
mongodb is very very popular
so it is not actually replacing your
existing rdpms which is there in the
market but it is giving you complete
different approach
where you can be completely free
from all those restrictions what a
traditional idb message is gonna offer
it to you
so in this particular tutorial we will
be learning
what mongodb is all about and their
advantages and some practical
demonstrations so let's get started now
so here in mongodb we would like to
discuss about what is the mobodb so as
we know the mongodb is known to be a
call a traditional
document based database
okay which stores the data in a document
okay no sql means
it doesn't say like no to sql instead it
says not only sql that means
it is not only sql but it is supporting
the other approaches too
okay so the document based when you talk
about it actually represents the typical
heretical relationship using the single
records
that means how the records are related
with each other so that's how exactly it
represents
and it is a pure schema free environment
so that you really do not need to have
a schema before you go and develop this
program so it is a pure schema-less
environment
due to that it is giving you far more
better flexibility when you talk about
completely unorganized environment
so what is nosql so the here's the idea
about a nosql so it is completely into
the non-relational database like
traditionally if you see
any non-relational database
you talk about
typical nosql
it's purely into the document base here
nosql does not use any tables like in
rows and columns a traditional idb base
approach if you see
there they are using a complete table
structure like they talk about columns
they talk about rows and are all about
so here
in nosql it stores the relationship data
in the documents so the different type
of nosql databases are available like
you talk about called document based you
talk about key value base you talk about
white column based
and graph based
different options are available for the
nosql but the one which we are using it
mongodb it is a purely document based
database
now here we would like to go ahead with
some demonstrations like talking about
like how mobo db installation works and
the other aspects
okay everyone so now we're gonna start
working on
the first option called mongodb
installation
[Music]
okay
see mongodb installation is very simple
if you open a website and go for this
website name called
mongodb
download
if you talk about mobile db download
you're gonna see
the official website called mongodb
community download is available
when you click here
so you can see it is taking the current
version to 4.4.6
mac os it by default detected my
platform
however you can select
depends on which platform you have it
and after that you will be clicking on
this download
okay so it'll get ready for if you're
from windows
i would say
in this windows
you can
select
appropriate option like two options are
available you can talk about msi or talk
about zip
my recommendation is you can stick to
the zip power portion because it won't
start any mobo db services behind the
scene
that is really helpful because you
really do not want the mobility to be
there running unnecessary even if it is
not required my suggestion is to stick
to the zip file so
here once the mongodb is there so you
will be seeing that two files available
inside the mongodb folder inside the bin
so once you download the zip you will
find two different type of files are
available let me mention those
so
inside the bin folder
you will see two files one is called
mongodb
okay the other file which is available
called mobo
mobo d is to basically start the mongod
server
and the mongodb is actually the client
which will connect with the mongodb
clear so if you are in
windows environment so once you are
inside this bin folder of your
zip file
you will get the mongod so you have to
double click on this it will start a new
command prompt
so you do not need to do anything
further just minimize this command
prompt and go inside the bin folder
again and click on the
another binary file called so it
will get start as a client
okay since i am using the macbook here
the concept is little
different about how mongodb can be used
okay so this is just a basic way of how
the mode is being used into your code
okay everyone so now
as we are in the
macbook so here to start mongodb we have
a very special way to start with so here
i'll start with my terminal
and here i would like to paste one very
simple command to start my mongodb
database
that is called mongodb
and after that you have to say hyphen
iphone db path it is the place where
your database will be starting and one
more important thing i forgot to mention
like mongodb would not start
automatically
inside your
windows machine unless
inside your c drive you have to create a
new folder name called data and under
this you have to create a new folder
name called db
because automatically when the mongod
starts it looks inside the c drive data
inside a db folder there your all
records will get stored so do not forget
whenever you're trying to use the
mongodb so you must make have you must
have this particular
fold structure in place in your local
machine otherwise this is not going to
start
every time you start your mughadi
without this location it automatically
terminates so to avoid those make sure
that you have this data db folder ready
with you
however you could also change the
location of this particular folder
structure for which we will discuss it
little later on but as of now
we can see i'm giving my
location that is called iphone 7 db path
slash data db i hit enter you can see
now my mobile db is starting now
and since it's stuck so i have to start
the new terminal now
so here
i open
the another tab
and type
and the moment i type mobile now you can
see it is now connected with my mongodb
and now it is ready
that's the first thing you need to
remember
okay
now
to check
which other databases are available to
you so you can just type show
dbs
so it will show you the number of
databases which are already there
inside your existing
newly installed mongodb
but you can go back and create
new database too here you can see some
databases are already present however
you go back and create the new databases
into your system
and to create this
database we have very simple option
available here
name call
use
simply db
if i say use simplydb it automatically
creates this database and take you
inside
let's see now you can see you say you
simply db it automatically creates
though it is not there but automatically
takes you in while creating those
okay so that means your current database
name called simplydb
so if you're not sure which database you
are in so you can just type dbs
or db
and it will show you that your current
database is simply db
that's it so your database is set
and we are all good to go ahead with our
next level development
hello everybody and welcome back
in a previous videos you have seen like
how to create a database and
how to identify whether my database is
there or not so if you remember
previously we have created our database
using use keyword so if i just see my
databases which we have created yes last
time so how we can check this out we can
say
show
space dbs
okay so you can see we have a got
database
list but we do not have any database
which we have created last time is
registered here that's quite surprising
because
when we have created of a database it
should be listed here but it is not
let's do one more time i'm saying use
sn db
and
i'm saying switch to sldb
now
when i say once again show dbs
so i still don't see my databases listed
here there is a reason the reason is
according to the mongodb rule unless we
have minimum one
record or collection is stored inside my
mongodb it really can't show in the list
now i want to tell you about a few
important things
now
here when we talk about called mongodb
in this mongodb
compared to the relational database
here the table
which is actually
in rdb message is called here it is
called
collection
okay
db
is still called
db here
okay that means the database will be
still called database
but
row
what you use this word in a traditional
rdbms here it is known as called
document
if you remember i told you
like it is a document based database so
here every single record what you try to
insert it is not called
a typical row it is instead called a
document so every table is called
collection and every single row it is
called
document
that's what exactly the difference is
okay
now here once it is ready we will go
ahead and talk about our next feature
now
well
we have to basically go and create a new
collection
okay so what you can say db dot
create
collection and here i can pass my
collection name i can say
demo
collection
so once it is done
i can see it is collection is created
in typical language i can say
the table is created and now when i try
to see same show dbs
i can see my database is now listed
okay that's how exactly it works so the
very simplest way of how we use in my
code
well in our previous examples we have
seen like how we can create a collection
and we can give the name and i can see
the details are listed
when i say show dbs but there's a
another alternative option available
where you can just do that without even
saying db dot create collection
well
if i want to create a collection i
really don't need this particular
functionality called create collection i
can directly use this statement name
called
db
dot
db dot sl
student
dot
insert
and here
we would like to add the property like a
name
and here we can say
admin
now what is that meaning is when you say
db dot sl student dot insert
and i hit enter you can see the
uninserted one
and surprisingly when you try to say
press enter
you will see this sl student
is not a collection which we have
created earlier
so what this line does this line
not only create the collection for you
but also add a record inside with this
property called name because that is a
mongodb and mongodb is always following
the json based structure and due to that
it goes with the key and value appears
so db is a predefined keyword sn student
is a collection name insert is a command
through which you are trying to insert
the record
now to check how many collections are
there
okay so we have one
property called
show
show collections
when i say show collections i can list
down those number of
collections or else i can set tables in
a typical rdbms language
which are there added in my system
so essence student in which i can see
the record is inserted so if i want to
confirm i can simply say
db dot
sl
student dot find find is a function
through which i can list out those
number of records which are added i say
find and you can see that the records
are
received at the same time when i say db
dot the name call demo collection
okay db.democollection.find
i'll find no record reason because this
collection was created but there was no
record which was inserted in
but you will see when i
write this command called sl student dot
insert it not only
create a new collection for me but also
insert the record into my table also
called a collection
that's where exactly it is giving you
the advantage when you want the
collections to be created along with the
data this is the way how you can really
do this
clear
but
whenever you talk about
db dot create collection many people
always think about what is the
significance of having this db.create
collection
look db.create collection is having its
own significance we never recommend
this technique
okay to create a collection because when
you create a collection you always
bring
some restrictions
some terminology which missed out
whenever you talk about this line
so having this db.create collection you
can also offer some
additional capping which is not possible
when you use tbi.org
collection in what is insert so you
might be thinking about those cappings
you're talking about let me try to brief
you
when i say db
dot
create
collection and here we are providing the
first name called support student
okay when i say student
so after this student additional
parameters what we can pass is this when
i say
capped colon
true
what are we saying cap colon true so you
are enabling the capping
after that the next parameter i am going
to pass that is known as call size
in this size we are providing the size
suppose i am saying
5 2
and also we are saying 2 8 0 that is the
size of 5 mb and here we are giving call
max
colon
what exactly that meaning is see the
meaning is very simple whenever we try
to bring this create collection option
so capping true means you are enabling
the capping so what is that meaning is
it is trying to say
in this particular collection name
called student
maximum number of
documents
can be either 5
or less than 5.
clear and the collective size of
documents cannot be increased to more
than 5 mb
that means you're trying to say
either
by adding the total number of five
records the collective size of five
document will reach to five mb
okay or else the maximum number of five
documents can be
stored so whichever fills earlier you
may have a total number of four
documents which are pretty heavy and
they
reach to the size 5 mb and beyond that
the next document won't be added or else
you can have the five documents which
has not yet even reached so any option
will help you to achieve this
so that's where exactly you can offer
the capping but this is only possible
when the user is trying to
say db dot create collection this option
is not possible when you're trying to
use this
so that's the benefit of having this
db.create collection and this is what we
always recommend
well
now we would like to talk about our next
feature here
inside the same
mongodb so we now know how to create a
collection how to create a database and
how to switch from one database to
another database
now we will tell you like how to insert
a document so far we have already seen
how to insert a document inside the
mongodb now we would like to also show
you how we can insert the documents
using multiple techniques
so remember one thing
mogu tv comes with two different type of
documents
one is called
relational document and second is called
embedded document
mostly while working with mongodb we
always recommend you to use
embedded documents because that helps
you to scale up your application without
any hurdle
okay the embedded documents means what
that means the
i would say the parent record as well as
the child records both stores in the
same location
fine so
how exactly that is let's take a look
about this example
here we would like to insert some
records by saying db
dot
student i do not have a student
collection but i'm just telling you
db.student
dot
insert
here
we would like to add
some records what i'm trying to say the
registration number
registration number i'm just saying
uh
one two three four
you can give anything
now the next one we need to talk about
caller name this name we can say
student one
followed by the next one i'm talking
about which course the student has
registered so we can say
course
inside this course we would like to say
the course name let's say
course name
we are given the course name called
mca
okay
followed by
another property called duration
okay i'm giving this duration
is called
three
years
like that
that
this curly braces is closing
that means
see
the idea is like you see the course is
an embedded document because from course
you have got few more properties like in
course name and duration
i am closing this and starting the
another
property and that is called address
okay
sorry let me remove from here
and from address and address we can say
one more curly braces
and inside this address we can say city
i'm giving the name called what
backload
another one we are using that is called
state
let me remove this state
colon
ka
okay and the third property we're using
that is called country
here is saying
i that is called india
so it is closing here
okay and it is closing here so the inner
document and outer document both are
closed
hit enter and now you can see the
records are inserted one thing you might
notice
the course
and the address these two are embedded
documents and they do not have
any
primary key of its own instead the
course and address both are directly
dependent on
the student object
or the student database so
i will say student have the registration
number
fine
and the primary key so the primary key
will be associated with the most outer
document and the inner documents are
directly
associated associated with them and now
when i try to say db
dot
student
dot find
can see now the records are
fetched
i can understand many of you are
thinking every time
while adding the record we do not add
any object id
and here you might have observed and
then also your option
then what exactly that id is now let me
brief you this id is nothing but a
unique primary key your mongodb has
offered you
that means mongodb says whichever data
you are inserting it
so by default with every single document
mobodb will associate this by default
property called underscore id which you
can't even ignore
however you can overwrite
i haven't provided any
underscore id as a property because this
is a predefined property associated with
every single
mongodb document if you want to override
it you can overwrite
from this value to any value because if
you do not pass any value
this value will be automatically
provided that is a typical hexadecimal
value
however if you want to override it you
can override the value of underscore id
but you can't change the key name
let's try
with some
another record
so the same record if i try to add
let's go
i'm using call
student two
and here i'm saying one two three four
five here if i want to override it i can
just say underscore
id
colon now i can give the value call what
one zero one
this you need to remember so i'm
overriding this value with one zero one
now adding it now the records are added
now let me call find now you see this
time the records when i fetched
so in this record
the first record contains a default
underscore id in a second record it is
the one which i have provided
and remember one thing in mongodb you
really can't offer any property other
than underscore id as a primary key
here there is no concept of having the
cons
like in composite key which you used to
do
in tradition
rdbms here you have only underscore id
and this is the only property which you
can override it else by default the new
value will be given to you so this is
the first way of how the insert document
has been done will be telling you the
another ways where the other documents
are also added
okay so in the previous examples you
have seen like how we can add the
records
but i also tell you there's another
alternative options are available if you
want to insert the records in a bulk
that option is also possible in mongodb
how we can do let's try to understand
here
here we would like to use one very
simple concept for
my
emp equal to now starting with
a typical
object
like this and after that i mean
adding this
and within this i'm adding the first
property called emp
id
colon one
after this
okay now you can see it is not
understanding because that is a
challenge when we talk about call
uh you know
the logical part
because you go with multiple lines it is
not supporting however you have to
follow the same lines now
emp id one and we just give the second
property called emp name
so
emp id uh just
remove this i just say emp id and i say
amp
name
colon
admin
okay adding it here
so
first record here
again i'm adding another one
that is called
emp id
colon2
okay and now
colon
manager
okay again
colon three
and
colon
qa
add it
okay and this curly braces is closing
after this
your square bracket is also closing
and once it is done come down
and say db
dot
new amp
insert
okay and here you pass the name
of the object called my
afb
and you can see now it is telling you an
inserted tree that is known called bulk
insert when you are inserting multiple
records in a single shot
see how easy it is for you
okay now you simply use
db
dot the collection name is what your new
erp
dot find
and you can see now all three records
are inserted with its default object id
okay so that
is a really nice idea to have
the id to be provided
okay remember this statement
so
you understood finally how we can
add the records in a bulk
going forward we will also talk about
which is related to your
update as well as delete in your
upcoming demos
okay but here that is the first thing
which you realize it how we can perform
those kind of operations in very very
simple and straightforward manner okay
everyone so now we have got three
records with us and in case if i'm
planning to perform update
on any of my records how will i do this
now so we have a predefined functions
available name called update function
let's see how this update function can
really work so we use this statement
name called db
dot
what is my collection name which is
known as call our new emp new emp
okay
dot
update
okay so what i will do i will say db.new
emp dot
update here
okay
now when we talk about call update we
have a
statement available
okay what is that that is called
emp id what we call emp name so we say
wherever the emp id is this i want to
change what the name how can i do this
now
very simple
uh
to perform this what i would like to do
now
i want to basically add few more records
to give you some more better idea
uh you can see now here we have a call
admin
id name
so
i just do one thing
i just change the ids
one two three i just say four
iso 5
is 6.
okay
and i
call this
again the three records are inserted now
let me try to call find
now we have total number of
six records are available where
admin is repeated manager is repeated qa
is repeated
now let me try to update the record
okay now i want to say db
dot
new emp
dot update
here
i would like to perform the property
like in what
uh
[Music]
name
i think emp name
amp name
colon
i say admin
okay
so i just close that
and i use
another curly braces with dollar
set that means you want to set the new
value here we are giving
emp name
okay what i want to do
i say wherever the name is admin change
to what
admin new
that name i want to change it
close this
and run
now you can see it is saying n match to
1.
and the record fields are updated like
this let me check
well here i will see
the value called admin new is updated
but i have one more admin called admin
it is not changed and there is something
which you need to notice
what you need to notice is notice is
like when you try to perform update
so what mobo dv does it starts from the
top
find the first record
change the value or modify the value
and come out from the loop it doesn't
carry forward its search process for the
next level of results and that is
something which is
i really want to do that
so in case if you are planning to change
those values
multiple times so what you need to do
let's take a look here in the similar
example here we have a call name admin
second property we have called manager
let's try to say
managers are repeated twice we just want
to change to
new
underscore
manager and i want to update multiple
values so what i will do here
i will put comma and say
multi
colon
shoot
okay saying multi colon true that you
want to say hey i want to update
multiple
search or multiple repetitions
hit enter this time you can say it is
saying
and match 2 and modify 2 that means 2
records found and 2 records are modified
let's check there we go we have got new
manager is updated in both the location
that's something which is really
awesome
because this is how you try to perform
the multiple changes
well in our previous examples you see
like how we can perform the update part
but we have one more beautiful feature
available inside the mongodb and that is
called how exactly we can perform absurd
clear let's talk about upset upset is a
combination of update and insert
let me try to show you one magic here
here
when we talk about call update part
you see now
here we are trying to say
uh
this point
yeah you see what multi true we have
used
now here this
multi true
is we're trying to update but let's talk
about something called manager 2
enter now you can see it is saying no
records formed
clear now no records found
but there is one concept available name
called absurd absurd means if i try to
perform upset it means if the records
are not available it will insert the
record
i want to show you one simple example
now here we are using multi-troop
okay
so
as i can see we're using something
called name
and we're performing this update part
so in this update part we are using this
dollar set new manager
so here rather than using multi true
we are saying
abstract rule
when i say absurd rule so what happened
now
they say
n matched 0 and up inserted 2 and
modified with id this that means when i
try to call this find function you will
be seeing now we have a got
the another record has been added are we
clear now
as a new record
so absurd does what absurd says like if
the records are found
i will update it if it is not i will
insert it
that means if i try to call the same
thing manager to
find it is added as a new manager now if
i just try to say
uh
not manager to i will call qa
qa and here we saying emp equal to new
underscore qa
and now you can see it is saying n
matched one and upsorted zero and
modified one so it is clearly telling
you like hey i did not find any
uh
inserted part but yes i matched one
record i found one record and the one
record is updated now
that is very very beneficial feature
when you really want to perform absurd
so that is the
advantage of upsell that is what's
called update plus insert
very
important feature that depends on the
requirement if you want to add you can
certainly add this so the way we have
tried to add this
up certain part we can also try to
perform the delete part also
okay so mongodb also helps you to
perform the delete part and how you'll
be trying to add it now let's try to
understand here in my code if i want to
perform any delete part i have this
statement name called db
dot
the option we are using it that is
called collection name emp
a new emp sorry
dot we have option number remove
in this remove we would like to offer
the property
okay and what we're talking about now
here
let's try to add
the id here
or the name which you would like to
import so i want to say like
emp name admin new so we just say
name
okay
and then
name scoreboard
admin new
okay emp name admin new when i say
remove
we can see it is record removing the
first record
so you can see now the records are
removed
fine because there is only
one admin new is available
okay now in a similar way if i try to
remove
the property call
new underscore manager
new underscore
manage with hit enter now you can see
the three records are removed so it's
not like update which removes only one
sorry update only one record it can also
eliminate more than one records at the
same time that's the benefit of remove
so now you can see we have already
implemented some records
as i seen earlier like we have
performed the delete part now
now when i try to say db
dot
new emp dot find
three records are available with me
three four and six
now when it comes to see
insert part we have seen update part we
have seen delete part we have seen now
it's time to basically fetch the records
so find function we've already seen but
in find function we also have some
conditions so-called queries so in case
if you want to limit the number of
records into your application you can
also do that let's see db
dot
new emp
find
clear now
so in fine you can also
pick up the specific records too
like when i'm saying dot find and here
we can just say
name
colon
admin
sorry
here to put curly braces
it says there is no record with the name
called admin
because it is a emp name not a name so
let me change back to
now you can see it finds
one record
so like that you can also apply a
condition
okay enter your code
now
in a similar line if you really don't
want to offer any condition
okay but you want to limit the number of
records to be
shown so you have this function
available name called
limit
to to means only two records now you can
see
though i have three records but it is
only showing me two records because i
have limit
those number of records into my code
also we can perform sorting in case if
you want to perform the sorting in
ascending and descending order that also
you can also do so here rather than
saying limit
we just put this option name called sort
and in this sort on which property you
want to sort it that out you can mention
so we can just say empty name
okay and
using ascending order or descending
order so we can just say
minus one let's go descending order
hit now you can see it is showing a
descending order now if i just say
minus one if you just say one
what is showing you in an ascending
order so you can pick up the specific
property behalf on which
you can tell it should be either on
descending order or ascending order
so that option really works very fine
okay
so that's like how you can perform the
queries but remember one thing you can
also
search
the records based on their embedded
columns too because if you see in a
previous records we have
some records added
okay that is
let me try to say show
collections
i will call
sl student
and student
okay
db dot
dot
find
okay
you can see we have records which are
embedded records
now if you want to search the records
based on their embedded properties like
i am talking about address this is one
property name called city
fine so if you would like to pick up
those records these are also possible
so how you can do this
very simple so you say tb dot
student
dot
find
okay so inside this file
you can provide the specific properties
like
my outermost property name is called
what address so we are using this option
called
address
dot
city so we say
city
are we clear colon
i'm giving the city name called what
bangalore
okay
let me close this
and that's it
okay
so we have to start passing
another curly braces here
hit enter and you can see now i find two
records
because both the records belong to what
[Music]
bangalore so i'm getting this
city bangalore with me
that's really awesome like you can also
pass the city accordingly
a part of that we also have
the other details also
okay in which
you can
have the conditions based on less than
greater than or whatever values you
would like to make it
is available and possible
okay
so that's how the conditions are
satisfied
so suppose if you would like to pick the
users
i'll be clear
where the range which you would like to
consider so those are also possible like
you can see we have this property name
called what emp id 3 and 6.
i just want to pick up only those
records whose id is greater than
what two so what i can say
db
dot
new
emp
okay
dot
find
and inside this file we can say
the property
okay so what's property we're using emp
id we are saying emp
id here
colon here we'll be using
dollar
gt
gc stand for what greater than colon
we're giving the value called what one
why
close this
run you can see you have received three
records three four and six in case if i
just look forward for higher than 5
you will see only one record so greater
than
that's called gt
okay
same option if i just say lt
you can see we have found
two records so less than greater than
okay so that's how exactly you offer it
okay and also you can provide the
condition so called limit as i can say
find emp id the way we provide it so
here i will not use
less than
okay
instead i'll be providing another
property let me show you what
so here in emp id whatever we have taken
so let me
try to take the property call file and
here we are providing emp
id and then
and we're using other curly braces and
we're using dollar in
is very important property dollar in
colon here you provide the details i'm
saying
inside so the properties three four six
we are saying
three
comma
six
close this
and you can see we got two records
which matched with three and six that's
the benefit of having
this
okay everyone so in our previous example
we have already seen lot many activities
this time we are trying to offer you
something very interesting feature and
that is known as call working with
indexing
see mongodb is one of the most popular
tool
and one of the reason why it is very
popular because it is having the
facility of having indexing now what
exactly the index does so friends main
job of having this index is to basically
give you the concept of like how
uh one particular
uh
document which is huge document in case
if you would like to perform any sort of
indexing inside this how you will be
applying this
so to apply indexing into my code
let's
try to understand why index is really
required without indexing
and with indexing how will be making a
difference into the code
so to make it happen we would like to
insert some records
to confirm
okay
so what i will do is in step number one
previous records if i see i have got
four six three four one depends on what
early records we had it
so we had to call
new emp
so db dot
dot find
so we have total number of three records
are available so it's okay we can have
this three recorders with me
now let me try to apply indexing
without indexing if i want to find a
result what outcome i'm gonna receive
so to know about
how much time it gonna be taking if if i
have a got large number of records with
me
i'll be using this statement name called
tv
dot the name is called new emp
dot
explain
and here i will be using one predefined
functionality called
execution stats
execution starts
okay
now here after the execution stats will
be using dot
fine
we'll be using the first property here
okay
and
what user would like to find it that you
need to basically offer it so we are
giving the name called emp name
colon
i'm giving the name call
qa
okay let's close
okay
now when i press hit enter execution
stats is a predefined
functionalities which will tell me
when the query was executed what exactly
the query plan was hit enter and now you
can see a lot of details
are available with me
like you can see
pass query winning plan and everything
one thing you need to remember by
default
here when i try to run
it says and return one
advance one need time
total everything it is showing me
but one important thing which you will
see here
is
total number of documents is scanned
so it is telling me total number of
document examined is three
clear now
and returned one that means one result
is returned and the total number of
documents examines three in order to
find this record
just imagine a use case here
when i say total number of documents
examine three in case if i have got
millions of records with me
that means to search the record it will
examine all the millions number of
records to search the result which
certainly gonna be taking huge amount of
time
and that's where exactly when you try to
search the record
fine when you
have no indexing is available
okay so you need to understand one
important thing is
by default
index is applied on your underscore id
db
dot
new emp
um
yeah db.ump dot
when i say
db.newemp.getindex is a predefined
function it tells me like hey
by default index is applied or
underscore id
that's the
fact because by default
index is applied on underscore id not on
the other properties
so i need to identify
which of the properties are required to
be get indexes mongodb advantages it is
supporting multi-column indexes
and that's what exactly we would like to
see
so let's see in our next demo
now we will try to apply index in on our
own property
okay so to apply the index what we need
to do we have to say db
dot
certainly we will be talking about call
collection name call
new emp
dot
create
index
here you have to pass
two things number one
on which property you would like to
apply
okay and it has to be ascending or
descending
so i'm trying to apply on
emp
name
and i want the index to be applied on
ascending order
okay so here
colon 1
hit enter you can see now
it is telling me
like
number of indexes before 1 and number of
indexes after 2 that means earlier index
was available only on one particular
property now it is applied on two
properties
if you want you can check
now you can see there is another
properties added called emp underscore
now if i try to execute a similar query
which i executed earlier
qa
now you'll be seeing there's a different
statistics all together
here
if i see
in my code
see it will tell you total document
examined one
see now earlier the number of document
examined were three but since this index
is applied notice telling me the total
number of document examined is one so
performance is certainly improved
so to search your document it won't be
searching the complete
collections
okay rather it will search what
only
that particular column in which it is
actually applied for
so that's the benefit in fact i would
say when you will be using these kind of
indexes
into your code
okay
so hope we all are clear and understood
about this concept so let's go ahead and
get this implemented into our system
well this is the first way of how the
index can be applied
so you can also apply index on multiple
properties
clear so that we will show you one by
one how it is
okay everybody so we have already seen
in our previous example how we have
applied
indexes in our existing mongodb
application
so it is also a possibilities where we
want to also apply the index on other
number of properties too as you can see
in our existing database
okay an existing collection my
collection name is new emp which
contains
two different properties one is called
emp id and second called emp name
just now we have applied index on our
emp name but in case if i want to apply
index on emp id i'll be using the same
technique okay let's try to apply index
on the same
so first of all get indexes i'm having
this index applied on two different
properties now we would like to say db
dot
create
index
and here in this db dot create index we
can just
i will say db dot collection name so our
collection name is called new emp new
amp
dot create index
first parameter is certainly the name
of which property we are applying so
here we are saying emp id
and in this emp id we will just offer it
has to be ascending or descending let me
decide descending order
so we are saying
-1
okay
now let's press enter and check the
status
okay now you can see earlier indexes
which we have graded that was 2 and now
it turns to 3. so it is very clear that
index is improving now let's check this
out uh dv dot
new mp dot get indexes now we have a
total number of three indexes are
available
so you can apply index or
n number of columns if you want
okay at the same time
the way we have created the index in
case if i want to drop an index
so we can also drop so what we can do
new emp
dot
drop index
draw
index
and in this drop index we have to
provide
which particular index we would like to
draw
remember this point in case if you're
planning to drop any sort of index so
you need to provide which
index so you should have that particular
index name
okay so here
we are providing my index name so it
should not be uh i would say the
traditional name called emp id no it has
to be emp id
underscore minus one or
emp name underscore one so this should
be the name i'm saying emp
name in case if you try this
you see it is saying index not found
with the emp name because internally it
maintains with this name
let's try this out we say emp
name
underscore one let's try
and now you can see new index was
three okay one
okay
now you can see we have a call emp id
and underscore id
so
now we have
only two indexes left
there's no emp name anymore this is how
exactly you can drop the indexes
so it is very simple and straightforward
way of how
in mongodb you can perform your
activities hello everybody and welcome
back
in a previous examples of mobodb you
might have considered
we have used lot many operations in our
last video we have seen how to utilize
uh indexing into our code now in our
next
journey of our mongodb we will see how
aggregation works see in mobile db
aggregation plays a vital role and
aggregation comes with so many handy
functions with mongodb which will help
you to perform
and to apply some very simple code
snippets into your ongoing
uh i would say the requirement which can
make your query so much seamless now we
will see how this aggregation really
works and to work on an aggregation we
have taken some default database name
called aggregate db and here we have a
call student as a by default collection
in which we have some set of
records are already added
now
if i just want to apply aggregation now
i would like to tell you about what
exactly the aggregation is
see ideally when you talk about call
aggregation okay so aggregation is
nothing but a call aggregate like rdbms
if you see medical aggregation there so
the unix command like you talk about
shell pipeline means the possibility to
execute an operation on some input and
use that output as an input for the next
command
that means the output of one particular
execution becomes an input for others
so mongodb also supports same kind of
concept in aggregation framework there's
so many type of
functionalities are available which we
will see one by one
into our next code
okay now here we want to confirm about a
few important things
now here let me try to bring some of the
important
well-known
i would say the functionalities of our
aggregation framework first we use the
term name called dollar project
the project is basically designed for
select
a specific
specific fields
dollar project is designed to select
what is specific fields from the
collection we used to talk about call
what
dollar match the match is responsible
to filter out the operations
are we clear now it is designed to
filtering out the operations
you talk about dollar group
talk about dollar group so it
does the actual aggregation
fine we talk about call dollar
sort
okay it basically sort the document
okay like that there's so many
operations are available which we will
see one by one in our aggregation
behavior now my first example the one
which i want to execute i have a call
student record with me which contains a
student name
okay the section
and the marks and the subject on which
subject the person or the student is
appeared
now here my first requirement is we want
to filter
data based on a section a because
students belong to the different
sections
as you can see now it is a they belong
to the different section section a b c d
so i just want to
filter the data based on section a
okay so for filter out i would like to
use dollar match
let's see how it works so i just would
like to filter out only those students
who belong to the section a
so how we would like to use it now i
will say
db
dot
student dot
aggregate
and inside this we would like to use
this
square brackets and then curly braces
and then use
dollar
match
with this
i would like to use another curly braces
can i say
section
a
okay and i close this
close this
close the square bracket close this
okay so db dot student dot aggregate
aggregate should be always associate
match is known as aggregate
functionality section a
hit enter and you can see now it lists
down all those students who belong to
the section a
okay
very simple and straightforward example
now we would like to use the second
example so we want to find out all the
records
where the section is a and we are using
and operator marks is greater than 80
there are so many students over
different marks like 70 19 and whatever
so we want to use both the conditions
together so how are you going to be
using this now remember not only the
section a
but also marks were greater than 80.
so similar thing we have a call
match
okay after this match we are starting
this curly braces
okay
so
after this match we would like to bring
and
we say dollar
and again colon
again we are starting this square
bracket now
okay we talk about what
section a
number one
and after the first
curly braces we would like to use marks
we say
marks colon and once again
they would like to start
curly braces and here we use
dollar
gt that is called what
a greater than colon
okay
all are closed
so you see like here we ever got this
square bracket in noun brackets
so
what else is left
so we have a call 80 we are using
another curly braces needs to be closed
here
and then
square bracket
okay and followed by again curly braces
again curly braces
again
square bracket again round brackets
okay
let's see where it has gone wrong so
we're using this
db.student.aggregate we'll use this
yeah square bracket
then curly braces then we use
dollar match
okay after the dollar match
we are using another curly braces
and we will call and operator
after this and we have a call
this square bracket then curly braces
section a
outer section is getting closed we are
using another curly braces marks
colon
dollar jt
okay and we are using what
colon
after that we are closing this
and using two more currently this is
square bracket in this
okay so this where exactly you can
utilize that
so
db.student.aggregate and like this it
will be able to get it now okay so in a
previous example that was the only
missing point was after this
uh
this dollar match we didn't apply this
curly braces
that was only missing point which was
there and now we have applied another
code is giving me this outcome and i
have only one user who's scoring greater
than 80. well that was the first thing
which we have it now
along with this i would like to go ahead
and talk about few more things now i
just would like to bring selective
fields not all the fields like as you
can see we have a call student name
section marks everything i'm getting it
so i really don't want to bring all the
properties from this document i would
like to selectively take specific
property
so
let's talk about how we can use this so
we'll be using project you remember
about project is responsible to select
the specific record
so i just use the statement name called
tb
dot
student
okay dot
aggregate we're using it now after that
now square bracket
and curly braces
now we are trying to say
dollar
project
what we would like to use dollar
project and colon we are trying to use
student name
okay colon
okay remember one thing one means i want
those zero means i don't want so
whichever property will be enabling it
by giving the one as a digit that means
it is
it is expected to be displayed so i'm
saying one comma i'm saying section
colon
one
okay and i'm also
looking forward for marks
colon one that's it so now
you can see now i am once again picking
up only those
like student section and marks now if i
go back and
remove some properties like
i only want
student and section you can see i have
only student and sections
are used
here if i just use this statement name
call
underscore
id colon 0
now you can see only
the names
and sections are visible id is not
because i really don't want id by
default id is shown but if i says is
zero that means the id will not be
visible here so like that you can select
the columns or the properties
accordingly that was the one way another
thing i would like to use
what if we want to find out the student
name
section and marks from student once
again we want to find out the student
name
section and marks from the student
collection where the section is a
okay so here it will be the combinations
of match as well as the project
how we can use this let's take a look
towards my implementation
if you see the previous one what we have
used here
you remember about we have used this
statement called aggregate match
okay so now we would like to go back and
utilize
after this dollar match
this is the curly braces i'm giving
section
colon
a
okay section colon a and after this i'll
close this
okay
and close this again
again i am opening it up
by using this option called
project
dollar
project we are picking up the project
right now and here with this colon
symbol we can use again
and say
student name
student name colon we're using one
comma
section colon one
and
one
marks colon one and now
closing this
now you can see i got those
so the requirement was
we want to find out the student name
section and marks from
student collection where the section is
a
so you are not only using the match
okay but also using what the selective
details like this you can implement it
okay that's where exactly the projection
really works so projection
gives you lot many opportunities
which you can utilize it for your own
and also it comes with lot many
predefined functions like in some avg
and all
so let's talk about those
functionalities too so this is the first
thing which we have seen aggregations
are taking place
now in case if you would like to perform
the group like if i want to find out a
total marks
group by
okay
section like each and every section i
would like to confirm the total marks
in every section then how do i basically
do that
so let's try to get this example also
so
here
let me try to
go back
and we will not be using match here
because i would like to use the group
part
so
after this curly braces
we want to use
dollar
group
okay let's go group by in rdb is how you
use it
here we use this curly braces
again
here we are passing this
underscore id
okay you have to provide underscore id
in a group because you cannot skip it
that part you need to be always remember
you really can't skip dollar id whenever
you're trying to talk about group this
is a compulsory field you need to have
it
after that
i'm using this
section
in this section
we are saying dollar
section
because we would like to make it on a
section basis
after this
closing
and here we are using what
total marks
colon
here curly braces
again
dollar
sum
okay colon on which we have i want to
use in mark so i can say dollar
marks
naming convention is very important
because it is a javascript so it is a
case sensitive
okay then
and you can see now
section wide i'm able to get all the
marks
isn't this an amazing that's where
exactly the aggregations are playing
very important role while retrieving
such kind of records
so hope you are clear about how we
utilize this together
so in a previous example we got it like
hope you are basically taking this
marks in my application
fine so
we are clear about how we are picking
that up but what in case if i would like
to take a marks for the specific section
so it is also possible
so we'll be using the same group but
only thing is what will be bringing the
match between because here we are trying
to get
the all the section marks but if you
would like to bring it only for the
specific section we know it very well
what we need to do so here
before i talk about call dollar group we
can use one more curly braces here
okay so we can use this option called
dollar
match
okay and here we are using this
uh option called section a
sorry
here
in dollar match we are giving this call
section
colon
here we're giving
so closing this
closing this
followed by
the other areas like a group which you
want to start now
so you can start with this curly braces
hit enter and you can see now only the
specific section you are able to receive
the records
and that's very simple now
okay so
that's where exactly would like to
perform and there's another option like
in case if you would like to perform at
an average suppose if you want to
fetch the count of student in each
section
and total marks
and average marks as well as so total
marks as well as the average marks you
want to get it so how are you able to
take it now
so it is very simple as you have seen
earlier also into our code how we are
taking call group underscore id section
talking about section
total marks with the sum
we are also using this after that we can
also use the average
okay
so
this is we have taken
called group underscore id sum
so here onwards we will start
so when we say sum marks
after that
we can just put curly braces
and we can just use
count
okay
and
after this
we'll be using this colon
curly braces and use
dollar
sum
okay
colon
one
okay and after that i'll put
comma here
and we use
average
and inside this average i will use
in curly braces we can say
dollar
avg
okay
colon of what
dollar
marks
very simple
so curly braces is closed
okay so total how many three curly
braces will be closed
one square bracket and round brackets
and now you can see you got the average
markings
in each and every section
so just imagine how easy it is for you
to deal with the aggregations so
aggregation seems to be very very simple
approach provided by mobile tv that
really create a difference of how
the
aggregation changes the way how you
react
okay everybody so after going through uh
the idea of like how we can utilize
the concept of
aggregation it's time to talk about like
how
when it works with
mobile db mobile db is properly known
for
i will say
for replication that is called high
availability and that feature comes by
default with mongodb you really don't
need to install any software for this
because it is a building feature for the
mongodb
so when you download that it
comes along with this so no additional
uh configuration setup is really
required when it comes to the mongodb
part okay so let's get started and talk
about how mobo db
can offer the replication see the idea
behind the replication is what
the idea behind the application is like
you are replicating it
okay
so when you talk about your application
you are replicating your data to where
the multiple child so here in mobile db
we have one concept available
okay that is known as call master
okay and
slaves
okay
master is one and there will be multiple
slaves
okay so these slaves where your records
are actually stored and this is a master
which will be responsible to replicate
the data to all its childs when the
request comes due to that in case if one
particular
node fails so automatically the data
will be taken from the other nodes
that's the beauty of having this master
and not slave process so to make this
possible to be a very simple option
available
in mongodb we have one concept like
called mongodb atlas
so there we can go and get our cluster
ready so here we start with the concept
name called
db atlas
let's search for mobile db atlas and
here i see mobodb atlas database as a
service see this is a free
tool it's the cloud environment where
you really don't need to install mobo db
in your local machine it is a
cloud-based mongodb support which is
free to use with a limited amount of
space but yes for the testing purpose it
is the best suitable so i can start with
the start free or else i can say the
login here
okay from there onwards i can go ahead
now it is getting ready
now this is the place from where you can
start working on your cluster
see as i've told you like initially when
you will be working on this
mobile tv it will ask you
to create a cluster
initially
okay since i already have a cluster with
me
okay
so
i really don't need to create it and as
a free tier it will not
allow me to have more than one cluster
setup ready so if i say create a new
cluster
okay and i say
by default aws
okay and let me close on this
notification aws you can select any
other cloud provider
and
8gb ram cloud backup cluster name you
can see now it is taking me
0.54 per hour
reason being because i already have a
cluster with me hence more than one
cluster is not allowed in a free tier
cluster so i have to cancel this
but
you can go and create a cluster the way
it was offered there so if you want to
create you can just go ahead and do
nothing just select by default aws
select your location
okay give the name of the cluster you
want to give anything you can give it
here otherwise let it be the by default
name cluster and say create cluster
it will take a while minimum two to
three minutes depends on
the availability it creates a cluster
for you
and your cluster once it is ready it
looks like that
okay so
here in this application you have to go
back and understand what is there in a
crystal when you click on cluster 0
you can see now here we have got
three
nodes available one is called primary
node which is called master as i
suggested earlier
and now we have a call slaves
automatically when the clusters are
created inside this mongodb by default
it will be three node cluster where the
one will be the primary and two will be
secondary
based on your package
whichever you have taken it you can
increase the number of nodes later on
but as a free i'm gonna get or i will be
receiving total number of three nodes
available here
so records whichever will be stored
it will get stored automatically in both
the nodes
secondary nodes and from the primary
i can insert the record and secondaries
i can read the records remember you
can't insert the records into the
secondary so you can only insert a
record only in your
primary record secondaries are not
allowed
to insert
so this is your replica set okay these
are the nodes which are available to you
so when you click on this primary here
you will see
it is telling you no whatever no data
available no data available
nothing is there because i haven't
stored any records as such
so i just go back to my cluster
so initially i would like to go back and
create few things now okay i would like
to go back and set up few initial things
at a time of creating the clusters
because when a cluster is created clear
now so in that point of time no setting
is configured you have to do few
settings now
first setting is you have to put it
remember the steps first step will be
your network access
so in network access you have to go and
you have to say add ip address
and in this add ip address you have to
select this option
from which location you would like to
accept
only those ip addresses will be
whitelisted otherwise what you can do
you can see here in my options i have
given
0.0.0 that means all ip addresses are
acceptable
so all ip addresses are used
okay so this you have to enable it
otherwise you won't be able to get
this network access from any third-party
locations
next you have to talk about call
database access which is required for
you to create a new user that already
some new users are created but it is
recommended that you to go and create a
new users here
okay so you can go back and add a new
user
so by default it is username and
password is given
so you can go back and create a new user
when i say add user
you can give
the username as well as the password
as per your own convenience so new user
i'm going to create it that is called
sl
okay
user
and here we're giving call
admin
so sl user admin
123 remember this will be the username
and password i'm saying add user
new user is automatically added sl user
and we went to three
so
once you have provided this network
access database access
next you have to create a new data
so what you need to do when you go back
to your
statement
okay network access database access it
will ask you
like you want to create a new database
so i just go back to my project zero
will be on an option called collections
you have to go back and create a new
collection here
now it is
retrieving the list of databases
now you can see there are already some
collections are there mrdp is one of the
database which is there
demo db is there lot many databases are
there so you can go back and create some
new database and connect through
so i just create database i already have
a simply learn db with me
user app
is already when collections are created
so creating a databasing correction is
very easy if i give you the quick demo i
say create database
give the collection name called
sl demo
okay and give the username call
amp
slw employee i can say create
now you can see slw create it is there
with me
so there is no record right now
and once it is there ready
so remember slw
and employee i'll go back to my
code again project zero
and from here i can say connect
because i want to connect it so to
connect it from because your mongodb is
already there so you want to connect it
through so to connect it through we have
very simple option available you can
just click on this
connect option multiple options are
there through mobile share connect your
third-party application of the mongodb
compass
so
since i already have a shell with
me
so mac os i have this mac os with me
so you can just use this line
okay so if you have a window you can
select your window since i have this mac
os
i'm selecting this line but i need to
replace with this uh
you can see this username
okay
and you have to give the username here
well i'll selected this i'll open my
terminal
okay and this is i'm just closing this
and opening up
another terminal here
since i want to connect to the
shell now
so what i need to do here in this
i'll just paste that
the command which i have it now
username is
you remember i told you
you call
some users which you have already
created
let's check
here
sl user
i
say
that's a user
i hit enter
it lasts me the password so i've given
the password admin
and now you can see it is connecting
with me
to this
particular see
now see it is connecting me to this a
particular replica set you can see in a
logs it is telling you very clearly
okay saying that it is a username 4.2
and you can see it is correcting with
your shard cluster the cluster which is
created and this is where exactly i have
it with me
so i'm connecting with this environment
so primary is there if i just want to go
back and say show
show collections
so i can go back and create a new
collection here
okay so
it's up to you now by default collection
which is their employee so i can say db
dot
employee dot
insert
and now here we can just add
name
okay
now you can see
some exception is raised
so
you understand
now you can see the records are added
into my primary cluster so if i just go
back and
go back to my project zero where we have
got
collections
here you will be getting
the
[Music]
sl demo
employee
loading the documents
so it takes time to get this but this is
where exactly
you see
the records will be stored
okay so that's where exactly it works
fine for all of you
so we have this
record
okay so when i say
show collection so we have a call
employee
and i say dv dot
employee dot
fine
so i can see we have got new collection
name called
this is added right now
okay so like this you have got
the first connection established and the
records has been inserted
and so with that we come to the end of
this full stack java course
if you have any doubts or queries let us
know in the comment section below thank
you so much for watching keep learning
and stay tuned to simply learn
you